for
all right good morning everyone it's uh
900 a.m. and I'm going to call the uh
house Judiciary Committee to order and
I'm first going to recognize
representative gon to lead us in the
Allegiance
Al the flag United States of America to
the rep for it stands one
nation
right
will yeah
yeah it is my yeah no my so I guess I
will introduce it yeah yeah termination
so I've got you can attach a a pink card
clear
M and we now recognize representative
Lynn thank you Mr chair
um Mr chair members of the committee uh
I'm Bob Lynn I'm a representative from
wendam um I'm here to introduce uh House
Bill uh
1353 relative to authorizing the
commissioner of the Department of
Education to issue
subpoenas um and I I guess I would say
on this that um you may recall we had um
the the issue of the Department of
Education having subpoena power was uh
came up in connection with a bill uh
last year
um
this uh this bill represents the product
of
uh as I understand it and I want I want
to emphasize this this bill although I
am the prime sponsor this bill and the
details of it represent the product of
what I understand to be discussions
between representative kutab who was
primarily respons responsible for the
details of the Drafting and discussions
she had with uh representatives of the
Department of
Education um and and I and I believe
some other Representatives on this
committee although I'm not positive
about that um and I so I think that as I
understand one of the concerns last year
was that the subpoena power was too
broad and there was a
concern um of potential
abuse um I think that the the way it is
worded now as I understand it is the is
what representative uh kutab did was to
speak with the Department of Education
and in particular the
investigator um and maybe the attorney
for the Department as to what were the
specific uh types of Investigations that
they did involving teacher credentialing
of know uh uh or violations by a teacher
uh that would that would result in loss
of credentialing or potential loss of
credentialing um that should be the sub
subject of subpoenas and that is what is
reflected um in the bill um so I hope
that that will um address um the the
concerns uh that that were uh uh
discussed about potential uh over breath
of of the uh of the subpoena power um it
I guess what I would say is the the only
other point I would make is one of the
things we heard I think as I recall from
the testimony last year was
that the way things stand
now there can be situations where the
Department of Education
receives um information indicating some
that a a uh teacher for example has
committed some violation of
uh rules or regulations including you
know potentially very serious ones that
even could amount to uh in some
circumstances could amount to criminal
conduct or or subject the school
district to liability or something like
that um and when the Department of
Education goes to investigate that um
they have no often there will be
resistance on the part of the school
district and the department has no uh no
authority to compel that they basically
can the school district can sort of say
go pound sand and there's not really
very much that the uh that the
Department of Education can do that you
know whether it seems to me that that
should not be the law and it shouldn't
be the law for the Department of
Education or any other department if
they have
authority uh to uh to
investigate uh to if they have a to
regulate and investigate and they have
authority to conduct hearings um and
impose discipline then it seems to me
they ought it it should not be the law
that somebody can just say you know go
pound sand um so that's that's why I
think this is uh this is appropriate I'm
happy to answer any questions
representative
Smith thank you Mr chair do you want to
answer questions rather than I mean if
you want to I happy to ask the questions
well no sure I mean my my sense was that
that since I you know since I've now
testified that I would not be answer be
be asking any questions once I you know
step out of this seat okay well of
course as you know you don't have to
answer any questions I asked and it
might be more appropriate for someone
else um I I was interested to hear your
summary of what happened last year be I
I pulled out my notes uh of last year's
Bill and they differ somewhat from from
your presentation in that the gentleman
and I apologize because I've forgotten
his name who was the chief
investigator indicated very clearly that
he didn't have any problems he was
concerned that there might be problems
in the future and therefore that was why
he was asking that he in fact had not
had any interference and so perhaps
someone else could correct me on that
but when i' I've looked at the bill and
I know how hard our colleague worked on
this and I looked at the material that
was prepared for this committee which
lists the subpoena power of all the of
any other agency where there is subpoena
power
and as you know I'm not a lawyer but
when I look at this in every case that I
see um it is a case where there is a
formal hearing where there has been a
charge and there is a formal hearing and
in that
case there you know they have the power
to subpoena Witnesses they don't have
the power to subpoena Witnesses unless
on Miss reading all of this
to
initiate a search or an investigation
the power of subpoena which is very very
important is only when there has been a
charge and there is a hearing and I
don't see anything in this that
indicat that would apply in this
situation this seems to be much more of
a preliminary search effort and can you
help me
understand where tell me where I'm
wrong sure well first on on your first
point
um my re you know I my recollection was
that I thought that the that the um that
the uh investigator did say I mean I I I
do remember him saying that
most of the time at least that's what I
thought he said most of the time he you
know that this has not been a problem
but I thought he did say that there were
there were some occasions when there was
now I could be wrong that it was about
it being him maybe it was someone else
that said that but I do
recall there being some evidence that
there were that you know of of a lack of
cooperation and not being able to do
anything about it I thought it was from
the investigator but I could be wrong on
that it might have been some it might
have been someone else is the is is the
investigator in the room by any
chance I don't yeah I don't I don't I
don't know I don't know and I don't and
I have to say I don't remember I don't
remember his name either I do do
remember he was
a oh okay far okay yep I know I remember
I do remember he was a retired state
trooper I believe but uh um and on the
on the other uh issue I guess I would
say I guess I would say
this if I have haven't looked at the
subpoena power of the other agencies
recently but if it's true and I accept
what you I accept what you say it it
seems to me that that's a problem for if
if if the other agency subpoena powers
are limited in that fashion they
shouldn't be in other words it seems it
seems to me that if you are an if you
are an agency that has the power to
investigate and to conduct hearings you
it it shouldn't be the case that
regulated individuals can simply say
sorry I'm not cooperating that again I I
have to emphasize
here
subpoenas are not search
warrants if the if if if you give the
power to this agency or the Department
of Environmental Services or the
Department of Labor if you give them the
authority to issue penis it doesn't mean
that they can you know run over to some
school district for example and just
grab the records they have to send they
send a subpoena saying produce these
records the school district if they
think there's this is in bad faith or
there's something wrong with that they
can say no I'm not going to I'm not
going to comply with that subpoena and
then this they to enforce the subpoena
the school district uh the department of
Education would have to go to court they
can't this isn't as I say this isn't
like a search warrant that they just
come in and see stuff they they make
this formal request the the school
district responds uh either by either by
moving to I suppose they the school
district I suppose could go to court
initially and move to quash The subpoena
but if they didn't do that and they
simply didn't answer then the next step
for the Department of Education would be
to go to court to enforce it so this is
you know and I guess what I would say is
if the if there are other agencies that
don't have that power but have similar
investigative responsibility I think
they should have that power I we will be
able to talk about it I know there are
other people who want to ask questions
and other people who were here the only
point that I want to make is that the
other agencies are able to get the
information that they want collect it
decide that there is a reason that there
is a problem and then hold a hearing
with the an appropriate person and uh uh
conducting that hearing and at that
point they have subpoena power the
question is how early in the process if
someone wakes up in the morning and says
gee I wonder what's happening I don't
think that's enough for you know
subpoena but I I'm conscious of taking
too much time this morning so I'm going
to stop now and I hope perhaps we can
continue the
discussion representative organ um yes
thank you very much Mr Vice acting chair
thank you very much for taking my
question um this um seems like it's
limited only to Educators as defined by
something in RSA 219a to dou C1 and that
refers to a code of contract for
licensed and certified Educators so is
this intended only to investigate uh
illegal or otherwise questionable
activity by licens and certified
education Personnel or is
or would the intent be to cover opinion
by like other people in the school
Community because there are like uh you
know non educational Personnel who may
be doing these terrible things I suppose
even students might be doing these
terrible things in the school setting so
why is this uh is that by Design or is
that why is that is that limited only to
Educators and if so should it be made
that's that's the intent of the bill
yeah sure so I I think the answer to
your question is yes in other words as I
understand and that the the whole the
whole rationale for this is that the
Department of Education has the
authority to regulate teachers and
regulate their licensing and you know
suspend them or whatever and so it's and
hold hearings for the purpose of doing
that and so I think it is limited to
regulated regulated Personnel for lack
of a better term which I think would
include would include teachers I mean
maybe
I don't know School nurses but School
nurses probably are more regulated by
you know the healthc care I uh I don't
know whether they whether they would
fall within the school regulatory
Authority also if they do then I guess
maybe that they would be
covered and another omission and maybe
this simply because we don't
particularly have a state law governing
that is about weapons in school if a
educator is you know carrying a weapon
without authorization from the school or
under questionable circumstances so is
that uh was that admitted because
there's no state law even though that
can be a violation of federal law and
they could be violating you know state
laws other than our non-existent
gun-free School law but and if there was
such a law we'd be hearing that and that
be across the road in education anyway
so is that is that a so is that like a a
deliberate deliberate Omission or is
that just uh this just because this bill
can't cover everything that can happen
in the school setting and it got left
out I
I mean I I'm
not I'm not sure that I'm not sure that
but are you saying if some if if if it
was a violation of school policy for a
teacher for example to be carrying a
weapon uh and that and that constituted
a violation of some Department of
Education regulation
um I don't know whether that would fall
within any of these uh let me take a
quick look
here
uh probably could be I mean certainly
they could be using it to assault
righty well I I mean I suppose you know
um any act any alleged Act of
endangerment or cruelty I mean maybe
that you know arguably that falls within
that so
sure thanks thanks representative Manos
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question in the absence of this bill
would the Attorney General be authorized
to issue subpoenas on behalf of the
Education I I don't think so um I mean
you know in other words if the Attorney
General went to court if the attorney
general actually uh uh initiated a
lawsuit of some type that then I think
surely surely they could issue a
subpoena just you know like in
connection with anyone else that that
that is in court but I don't think
because and what leaves me to say that
is there the Attorney General I think
does not have sort of
General um subpoena power in fact I
think don't we
have um somebody I think has a bill
about um giving the Attorney General
for civil rights I think that's right I
think isn't there a bill that I think we
may have it that that purporting to give
the attorney or which seeks to give the
Attorney General subpoena power for
civil
rights um
cases uh because he doesn't have that
now and I I think if I recall correctly
from speaking with the Attorney
General's office about that the only
only subpoena power that they have right
now is in connection with charitable
trusts and consumer
protection um they don't have and in
fact I I I remember speaking with uh
attorney Assistant Attorney General lock
uh when there was a when you know he
sent me an email or something about the
bill basically saying you know why I I
don't disagree with with your having
subena power for civil rights cases but
we really should have General subpoena
power why why shouldn't you the Attorney
General why shouldn't you have General
subpoena
power any other questions for this
witness representative
Stapleton thank you thank you for taking
my question um on page page
one Roman 13
line3 um I think that paragraph answers
several of the questions that have been
posed issuing subpoenas for for persons
and for the production of documents
tangible objects and other items and
things whenever the co commissioner has
reason to believe that a violation of
the code of conduct for New Hampshire
Educators is established in RSA 21-9
colon9 and so far has
occurred um in the case
of the teacher with the
weapon um
is that in the code of conduct or not
and if it's not in the code of conduct
then it has to fall into
another Authority or venue for that
problem that I mean that's what I would
I mean you know
arguably
could without getting into the whole you
know gun control issue about whether or
not those these gun free school zones
actually do anything assuming that they
do I suppose someone could argue that
any alleged Act of endangerment or Co or
cruelty uh this I suppose this could
involve an act of endangerment um I
suppose I'm not sure that I would uh I
say I'm not sure that philosophically I
would think that that's true but uh um
we don't know what's in the code of
conduct right we don't yeah and that may
be a evolving document as time goes on
we follow up yes um is this subpoena
really not a um a tool of Discovery
after which then hearings and process
can ensue oh no absolutely that's that's
exactly what it is it's a it's a it
basically is is designed to ensure that
the um that the Department of
Education has the ability to if if it if
it has investigative Authority that it
has the ability to to compel people to
you know to cooperate essentially that's
uh that's that's what it's designed to
do
followup another question I had was on
page
two um relative to service at line 11
and sub five a service uh shall be made
on persons who are not lenses or
certified individuals in accordance with
the procedures and fee schedules of the
Superior Court
Etc um is that just a guideline in how
to be served or do they have to actually
run that through the court for that
class of persons no I I I they they do
not have it's just that's just by
analogy in other words they they don't
have to go through they don't have to go
to court first um but they do have to
you know follow the same sort of
procedures yes thank
you any further questions for
representative
Lynn saying none thank you thank you uh
Hawkins thank you Mr chairman members of
the House Judiciary Committee for the
record my name is Megan Tuttle president
of Nea New Hampshire representing about
17,000 Educators across the state and I
have Brian Hawkins with me who's the
government relations director for NAA
New Hampshire I'm here today to express
our opposition to House Bill 1353
relative to authorizing the commissioner
of Education to issue
subpoenas we contend that the language
of House Bill 1353 is too broad
fundamentally unfair and inconsistent
with other New Hampshire licensing
agency and court procedures the first
question question this committee should
answer before examining the language of
this bill ought to be is it necessary
for the commissioner of Education to
have subpoena power to properly carry
out his charge under the New Hampshire
educator code of conduct in the public
hearing on the non- gerain amendment
last year the department staff indicated
that it was not currently necessary and
that this Authority was a prospective
need if there were documents that a
school district would simply not allow
them access to this question of whether
there were documents not being made made
available to them was asked both in a
subsequent retained Bill subcommittee
meeting and in follow-up conversations
had with the doe and their answer
continued to be no there were not
documents that the doe could not view in
determining whether to recommend whether
a violation had occurred and a
disciplinary sanction warranted unless
something is changed we submit that
subpoena Authority the commissioner
seeking is
unnecessary House Bill 1353 is written
is too broad it does not give the doe
authority to issue subpoenas for all
alleged violations of the code of
conduct most of the included categories
in the bill which are meant to narrow
the types of alleged violations have to
do with student safety but House Bill
1353 includes the authority to issue
subpoenas for alleged failure to provide
appropriate supervision pursuant to
local Schoolboard policy we have concern
over the inclusion of this because the
way the doe has applied this rule when
justifying the opening of of an
investigation not providing appropriate
supervision sounds like it's related to
student injuries from a recklessly
supervised science lab experiment or
something like that but the doe often
uses this provision to investigate
curriculum or classroom materials or
speech in classrooms category 9 in the
bill has essentially been used as a
catch-all for anything that doesn't fit
anywhere else in the code of conduct but
the commissioner has wanted something
looked
into as written We Believe House Bill
1353 is fundamentally unfair specific
Ally under the due process clause of the
14th Amendment the government is
prohibited from taking adverse actions
against license holders without
providing due process at its most basic
level the requirement to afford due
process forbids the government from
denying or thwarting claims of statutory
entitlement by a procedure that's
fundamentally
unfair and or add to that the New
Hampshire Supreme Court has held that
the ultimate standard for judging a due
process claim is the notion of
fundamental fairness ruling that
fundamental fairness requires a
government conduct conform conduct
conformed to the community sense of
justice decency and fair play clearly
that's not happening under this the doe
is asking for the ability to issue
subpoenas to solicit information during
investigations yet there are no
Provisions that the subject educator may
also issue subpoenas which would assist
in their defense during the
investigation period or a judicatory
hearing phase Educators should be
granted the ability to subpoena Witness
and documents in their own defense I
hope we can all agree that proceedings
such as this should be fair House Bill
1353 is not consistent with other
agencies or Court subpoena procedure
agency regulations relating to subpoenas
are not uniform however they have
consistency in having subpoenas as part
of the adjudicatory um process not
necessarily the investigation part it's
also consistent in other agency rules
that both sides are allowed to both
request subpoenas and move to quash
subpoenas this bill only proposes
subpoenas for the commissioner to issue
during the investigation phase and there
is no quashing process and I have some
examples in written testimony that will
turn in both sides having the ability to
utilize The subpoena power would be an
actual Fair process the bill should be
amended so both parties can request and
quash
subpoenas we heard last year from the
Department staff who testified that
subpoena power is something the office
of professional licenser opl C has but
how and in what phase that power seems
to vary it seems prudent that this
committee seek that information from the
oplc themselves rather than from another
agency my written testimony also has
some observation examples of this other
boards don't have subpoena powers during
the investigation phase only the hearing
phase the naturopathic Board of exam uh
examiners is one such board additionally
anyone served with a subpoena in a court
action or in these other agencies can
move to The subpoena on various grounds
that should be available in doe
proceedings just as is in other agency
procedures House Bill 1353 is a
continuation of an overreach of
authority that the doe has been seeking
since the Inception of this bill last
year while we do not agree that this
Authority is necessary even if we did
this bill is not written sufficiently to
ensure a fair process or the necessary
safeguards to prevent abuse we urge this
committee to find House Bill 1353 an
expedient to legislate and urge the doe
to work with stakeholders to better
identify the challenge it's seeking to
fix and explore the possible solutions
than beginning with the suben authority
it's looking to acquire and there is
written testimony with more um that we
will turn in and we're happy to take
questions representative
Perez thank you thanks for taking my
question it's my understanding that an
educator is credentialed once in their
career um so I could graduate from
college and to work at age 25 and be
credentialed and have a background check
done and perhaps the school district
that I went to work at did a background
check and I could work for 40 years with
never having to have another background
check and never to have to be
credentialed is that correct thank you
for the question um as far as I know
with the background checks yes there
have been other bills introduced to have
talking about now okay then yes but I
will add for the credentialing pieces
that you asked about you do get
credentialed once but you do have to go
through a recertification process every
3 years and through that recertification
process you have to have professional
development hours your principal your
superintendent has to sign off on it and
then that goes through the Department of
Education to allow your certification
for another three years and when you go
through that credential EMP power I know
when I was a nurse I had to renew my
license every two years and I had to
have so many CEUs but I also had to
certify under penalty of prosecution or
law
that I had not been arrested or anything
for any type of any type of minor or
major crime I'm sure that is still the
case as part of their ongoing
education do uh Educators also have to
sign an affidavit saying they have not
been arrested or uh charged with or
whatever any
crime any
crime uh I believe excuse me thank you
uh there's a duty under the code of
conduct to report no that's not what I'm
asking I'm asking as part of their every
threeyear
process that you just said that they had
do they have to sign an affidavit saying
under the penalty of perjury or whatever
I'm not a
lawyer that they have not been charged
or arrested or convicted of any type of
criminal activity yes or it's a yes or
no I think we' have we'd have to get
back to you on that um I would just
continue to submit though that um under
the code of conduct there is a duty to
uh disclose um uh under under the code
of conduct I understand that's a duty
yeah but if I'm an educator and I'm at
the summer in Hawaii and I get arrested
for
ddii there's nothing that forces me to
come back to the to the doe and say I
got arrested for DUI correct so I'm I'm
not sure how that's relevant to this
bill this bill is about subpoena power
right it it does have it does so I'm
just saying that I can work for 40 years
never have to sign an affidavit that
I've never done anything wrong and be
credential continue to be credential in
anything I don't know represent is there
a question there yes I if you know of
any other
professional agency or profession that
allows
that I'm I'm sorry that allow Mr
chairman that allows I'm not sure I
understand the question that allows
what any further questions
representative
Kat thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question so I guess I I do
want to ask you made comment about there
not really being another area where
subpoenas are issued in this manner and
I just I wanted to ask under RSA 168 C
16-a which allows
for hearing officers at the doe to issue
subpoenas under special
education
um impartial due process
appeals are you finding that that is
currently being abused because that is a
current Authority that that is
allowed I I I think our testimony wasn't
that there aren't subpoenas allowed in
other areas of state government it is
that this bill as it's written is not
consistent with those um in that if you
look at some of uh examples like in oplc
and others there are Provisions around
as we testified earlier um uh things
like I mean in this bill there's nothing
that uh restricts the subpoenas to be
relevant to the uh to the uh
investigation that's happening I don't
see that I don't see uh as uh president
tutle testified to earlier anything
relative to um quashing subpoenas um and
then
also uh
in um I think when you look when you
look at uh what are these other agencies
you also have variations as to whether
you are allowing subpoenas during an
investigatory phase and an adjudicatory
phase so I don't think we were saying
that uh they're not allowed in other uh
areas of
law may follow up followup yes so I I
mean in here I'm seeing that it is it's
when there's reason to believe that a
violation has occurred and that it's
it's offering specific things and when
I'm looking at this other one that I
just referen I don't see anything in
here about quashing Powers um but I mean
I guess my other question really is that
you mentioned on the one hand that you
felt that it was too broad but then on
the other hand you kind
of implied that it was too narrow
because you said that it doesn't allow
for all areas of conduct to be
investigated so is it that it's too
broad or is it that it's too narrow
thank you for the question I think
that's a good one so uh I think the uh
the statement about um not allowing all
um areas of the code of conduct and we
do highlight the corresponding code of
conduct uh Provisions that we think are
are parallel to this bill um
that uh that was an that was more of an
observation of the bill but what we're
saying is there are there are parts of
that bill including as we referenced
number nine that we think would po would
uh take take this too broad um and so
you know if you're are contemplating
this that we feel like that ought to
either be stricken or or uh
further follow up would would you be
more comfortable if instead of the
commissioner of ad if this was a hearing
officer that was able to to issue the
the subpoenas
I I think that would be I think that
would fall more consistent because you
have an independent third party that is
providing some guard rail to both sides
you know as to whether uh subpoena is
appropriate um so uh I hope that answers
your
question it it does I think it sounds
like that you're maybe you're willing to
work through on something with
this you know we are always willing to
work on these things you know one of the
things that uh we're very proud of on
other pieces of legislation that we have
uh uh testified on is
that um you know we have offered
suggestions on other pieces of
legislation having to do with a variety
of issues related to either the code of
conduct or safety or background checks
um as well as uh you know there's the
committee should also be aware that the
doe is undertaking a Ru making uh
revising the code of conduct
investigatory process currently um and
we uh have offered um what we what at
least in our view is productive
suggestions on how to improve those um
while also protecting as we've talked
about a little bit in this bill due
process so thank
you any other questions for these
Witnesses we'll hand in our written
testimony m sing none thank you and we
would request that if Witnesses have
written test Tony to submit please do so
and give us the reita digest version of
your written summary thank you um if we
could have more Ryan please that's the
next
witness hi my name
is okay sorry hi my name is Mora Ryan my
first time before the Judiciary
Committee thank you Mr chairman um I'm
here to support 13353 for subpoena power
for the New Hampshire doe
um first I would like to point out that
the state gets millions of dollars to be
the enforcement arm of the federal doe
and they're supposed to conduct
investigations um and that's why they
exist in part um I had a teacher from my
son's school who had been through four
schools in three years um if you looked
at the newspaper articles about the
person he'd been doing some things that
were not appropriate um but there was no
investigation of him and he continued to
move from school to school doing the
same activity there were no real
background checks done on anyone who
gets put into a school um when they move
from school to school there's a lot of
embezzlement happening my son attended
school in Manchester we had people
stealing from the boosters and people
stealing cards um which would be a code
of conduct violation which was never
investigated um my I myself reported the
school for Ida
violations um and there was supposed to
be an idea investigation of the school
due to numerous complaints and the
school refused to allow the New
Hampshire doe to look at the files now
violations of idea would be obviously a
civil rights violation which never got
investigated and never got
corrected um all of these factors put
Children at Risk I would like to point
out that DHHS has subpoena power and
they don't have to have a hearing and
that's because we This Is Us dealing
with children and children who are being
harmed need immediate
intervention um I also attended a
hearing with the Rochester school
district as an in the audience where the
Rochester school district said they had
they admitted to doing the violations
and they were given a self monitoring
corrective action self-monitoring so I
don't know how many people drive on i93
and see people going 80 90 mph they're
not following the 65 mph speed limit and
if a police officer told them to just
monitor their speed and turn themselves
in when they were speeding would they
really do that I have to ask that
because right now we have
self-monitoring for our schools and I
don't think that's
appropriate
um I'd also like to point out that
criminal proceedings have a much higher
um I'd also like to point out that in
the city of conquered hoe young abused
students for many years he started
abusing them in middle school and
continued to abuse them through high
school and that he was never stopped
from doing so where were the teachers
who were supposed to report his behavior
because he was openly engaging in sexual
behavior with dead students in the
lot
after ho Leong was gotten rid of by the
school district which was a tenuous
process at best because nobody wanted to
get rid of him he was charged by the
state of Massachusetts Never by the
state of New Hampshire where he was an
active
teacher and two other teachers were
subsequently let go for similar
activities so do I think the New
Hampshire doe needs subpoena power yes I
do are there violations of the code of
conduct yes there are is anything done
about about it no nothing is done so I
am here to support this bill because we
have to support kids and we have to make
sure that kids are going to school and
getting an education
and not going through all these other
things where they're being subject to
abuse or other avenues because DHHS will
not investigate teachers who abuse
because they say that is NHD O's job so
I support this bill and I'm happy to
take any
questions any questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you thank you we now
Downing the microphone on please sorry
good morning chn thank you uh for taking
time this morning my name is Christine
down I'm the director of curriculum
instruction and assessment for three New
Hampshire school districts those are
planfield Cornish and Gram I'm here
because I oppose House Bill
1353 in my role as curriculum director
I'm often tasked with the responsibility
of training all our staff annually on
the code of conducts which have been in
place since
2019 um I have provided some materials
in my written testimony regarding the
training around those code of conducts
um this bill does not provide specific
terms in term uh related to the phrase
reason to believe um I have the
questions I would pose to this committee
to think about with this bill is has
accessing documents and information from
districts been an ongoing problem what
public data is available to determine
what percentage of previous
investigations require this type of
action is this a a piece of
legislation a solution that ser
searching for a problem that doesn't
exist um I also want to uh point out
that another important aspect um to our
entire process in related to due process
is the presumption of
innocence allowing the commissioner to
issue subpoenas because he or she has
reason to believe without sufficient
evidence or reasonable cause could lead
to unwarranted investigations and damage
the reputations of innocent educators
I also believe that this bill needs to
be looked at closely in terms of the
checks and balances we have in the three
branches of our government many of the
violations listed numbers 1 through 12
in this bill are covered through State
statutes that are direct directly
related to the duties of law enforcement
in court proceedings there are
alternative approaches that can be
considered besides this bill for example
the commissioner could work in
collaboration with law enforcement
agencies or the State Attorney General
office to conduct investigations this
would ensure that investigations are
conducted within the bounds of the law
and PRI provide legal oversight in
addition a memorandum of understanding
with New Hampshire education department
and school districts regarding
communication and information sharing
during an investigation might be a
better First Step finally it's my
understanding that the authority to
issue a exists for the office of public
lure which oversees license holders from
various professions perhaps the
licensing of Educators should be
transferred to this office where there's
already a process in place consistent
across all types of Licensing has this
option been considered by exploring
these alternative approaches I think we
can strike a balance between maintaining
high standards for educators and
safeguarding their rights thank you for
your time I am open to
questions representative
kab thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my
question number 10 it uh is relative to
Illegal Controlled Substances
um hold on bring up the the
wrong but oh number six is relative to
impairment due to a controlled drug or
intoxication four and number five is
relative to the possession of a
controlled drug you said that these were
already covered under statute are you
aware that under RSA 318-b col 2-
C Roman numeral 8 that if a teacher were
to smoke marijuana inside of a school
and to be arrested for such under that
statute that the doe wouldn't be able to
know so that they could potentially do
take action with their license because
that would be a sealed record
thank you for informing of that I would
also point out that under Ed
5101 principle 1 Section B number five
possessing using or being under the
influence of alcohol or drugs not
prescribed for the use of the credential
holder when on school PR premise or at a
school sponsored event where students
are present or may reasonably be
expected to be present is is the the
initiation of an investigation against
the code of
conduct
understood but they wouldn't be able to
get that record without a subpoena
because that record is in fact a sealed
record I I am assuming that's correct I
haven't researched that but what I am
saying is that if any of this comes to
light I I would point out that in
principle five of the code of conduct
which is the duty to report principle
it's very clear here that any credential
holder shall report any suspected
violation of the code of conduct
following the school uh school district
and SAU reporting procedures and failure
to do that to report um is also um an
investigation against the person who
failed to report if they're a
credentialed holder so I mean I can't
speak to that RSA directly I haven't
done my research on that but I think
there are many checks and balances in
place in the current code of conducts
that allow people that if if for example
if I go to a party and I see somebody
there engaging in something that is
questionable especially with students
present I have a duty to report that
it's not my duty to investigate it but
it is my duty to report that to my
supervisors and that's one of the things
I train all staff on to make sure that
you know we have a checks and balance
within our profession as well may I
follow up one more time I guess my
question is is once you report that if
they don't have the authority to get the
tools to actually prove that this is in
fact
a an actual founding or an actual
allegation that that is founded and did
take place how are they then supposed to
actually move forward with their
investigation if they don't have the
tool that they wouldn't be able to get
this documentation because if would you
agree then that after you've reported
somebody that they should then have this
tool or do you think that they should
just take your word that they were that
they were engaging in this activity who
I guess representative I need some
clarification on who you're you're
referring to when you say they don't
have the tool to conduct the
investigation are you referring to the
Department of Education yes well so this
is where I still think there are Che
checks and balances in the code of
conduct and here's what I mean by this
so it's clear in this principle 5 and
and and this is what I train Educators
on is that we all have a duty to report
right up to the superintendent so here's
what's not connecting for me so if the
Department of Education is going back to
a school district um and as we know the
chief operate Operating Officer of a
school district is the superintendent
and requesting information and that
superintendent has working knowledge
that these are possible offenses against
the code of conduct then I would loop
back to that superintendent is in
violation of the code of conduct because
if they're not releasing that
information when when it's clear that
the code of conduct says you have a duty
to
report then I feel that's the tool right
there then the department of Ed can
certainly take that to the next level
under 511 rules in terms of their
investigative process so I mean maybe
I'm misinterpreting the code of conduct
that's been out for the last five years
but that's exactly how I train Educators
that we all have a duty report and
failure to report comes back on all of
us any further questions for this
witness seeing none thank you uh David
Trumble you're next please thank thank
you did did she excuse me did you um did
you have written testimony to submit
question good morning morning uh thank
you Mr chairman and committee members my
name is David Trumble I'm from the town
of Weare and I oppose this bill the key
thing about this bill is it's simply a
question of subpoena power this bill
would create a pathway for executive
abuse of such Powers there are three
ways that good subpoena powers can be
granted in legislation for
administrative agencies first question
is who can do it can the administrator
do it by themselves no there should be a
check on them second on what grounds
good cause is the common standard for
subpoenas not reason to believe and
third is at what time most legislation
and I'll document for you this is in
disciplinary hearings as was mentioned
doe hearings officers not in the initial
search investigation I'll ask you to
look at RSA 170e it deals with
residential care and child placing
agencies section 41 deals with subpoenas
this is Department of Health and Human
Services same thing employees and
children under that statute subpoenas
can only be granted under meets three
criteria first there has to be a actual
disciplinary proceeding that's not the
case in the bill in front of you second
there has to be good cause shown that's
far different from reason to believe and
third it goes to the attorney general
who must approve that subpoena in this
case the commissioner could do it by
themselves this bill would violate all
three principles of due process so just
just to look at those a little more in
detail first is the attorney general
there's no other commissioner in New
Hampshire who has unchecked powers to
issue subpoenas the attorney general has
the power to do subpoenas I just gave
you the Department of Health and Human
Services representative Lynn mentioned
charitable trust and consumer protection
also if a common carrier of
communications like internet services if
there's any Transmissions illegal that
goes through the Attorney General if
there's a statute if there's a need for
a third party it should go through the
Attorney General that's a Le four
examples where they do this routinely in
the state of New Hampshire what about
other states I tried to find some
research on this and started to look
around individual states but stumbled
upon a report by the national District
Attorneys Association it's a 200-page
report lists all 50 states it's called
administrative subpoena Authority there
is no other state in the country that
gives education Commissioners this kind
of power it's interesting to note
however many states in that report do
use the good cause standard so that's
first thing it's is it should go through
the Attorney General second is what
should be the C what should be the level
of proof reason to believe or good cause
many states for administrative um
subpoenas use the good cause standard
look at the New Hampshire rules of
professional conduct for lawyers rule
4.5 a lawyer shall not issue or obtain
the issuance of a subpoena without good
cause it's a phrase that's well
understood in law there's a famous case
in California that went through and set
up a seven-part test for what's a good
cause subpoena specific to subpoenas
that's far better than using the reason
to believe standard which could pretty
much mean if whenever you feel like it
third is the question of investigative
stage or formal hearing stage as I
indicated the Department of Health and
Human Services it only can be done at
the disciplinary stage the
representative asked a question about
doe special ed hearings officers that
means you're already having a hearing
once you get to that stage then
subpoenas would be reasonable but if
it's a fishing expedition to gain
information at that stage it's not
reasonable also I would refer you to the
state of Maine their administrative
procedures act specifically talks about
subpoenas in situations where there are
actual formal proceedings once you get
to that stage then subpoena powers are
normal but they should not be uh allowed
in the beginning stages for fishing
Expeditions otherwise you do have a
chilling effect on teachers and there's
all the reasons why you heard from the
previous Witnesses thank
you representative Perez thank you
thanks for taking my question may I ask
your background sir um well I uh went to
law school at Franklin Pierce law school
and I graduated in 1983 I practiced law
in the state for five years I'm is in in
the law you can be either inactive or
active I'm on what they call inactive
status I maintain my membership but I
did go to law school practice law did
hundreds of cases so I have a legal
background but I'm not offering myself
as an attorney I'm just I I'm it just
taught me how to read a statute that's
all thank you do you have copies of
represent of
tur yeah thank you and thanks for taking
the question um and and I I'm recalling
your your testimony last year on this as
well um do other state agencies go
through the Attorney General's house uh
office when when they need um to to
access a subpoena for some
reason I I I looked up the individuals
enabling statutes for other state
agencies they don't mention the word
subpoena except for the example that I
found with Department of Heth and Human
Services I would imagine though if they
have a disciplinary proceeding at that
point then they would go to the attorney
general but this this is a
pre-disciplinary proceeding
Bill any further questions for this
witness seeing none thank you do you
have written uh testimony I do and um it
only mentions uh but I didn't include
the disciplinary proceeding part because
I didn't think that was going to come up
but turned out to be quite an issue so
it's slightly different than what I said
but I'll submit it anyway thank you
appreciate it thank you
perhaps oh oh my mistake that's correct
how
good morning my name is Deborah house I
am president of the American Federation
of teachers New Hampshire I am here on
behalf of our 3700 members across the
state most of whom work in K through 12
public education uh we work with about
30,000 public school students in
districts across the state and I am here
in opposition of this bill relative to
authorizing the commissioner of
Education uh to uh be able to issue
subpoenas uh um one of the main reasons
I am opposing this is because as we
heard last year in a non gerain
amendment to another bill that this is
not a
problem
the um Department of Education is
generally able to get what it needs when
it needs to investigate lure of teachers
uh uh
investigate potential violations of the
code of conduct we heard from the lead
investigator we also heard from the
attorney that they are able to get the
documents they need uh sometimes they
don't get them quite as quickly as they
would like but they able to get what
they want I was sitting here in this
room and heard that testimony so why do
we have something that's going to change
law to solve something that's not a
problem um no one is saying that we
should be you
know allowing anyone to violate the code
of conduct but we all have a duty to
report when violations occur we also
have
investigations that occur on a local
level when any of these things are being
violated that is going to turn into an
employment issue as soon as uh there is
a report made something is seen
something happens it's also going to
turn into possibly depending upon the
severity of what is um what is being
alleged it's going to turn into a police
investigation so having subpoenas coming
out of the doe in the middle of that
could actually impede ongoing
investigations
so be very careful when you're
considering this that you don't get in
the way of trying to resolve an ongoing
situation by having a lure issue get
right in the middle of it um no one is
trying to stand up for bad actor staying
in the school but this would give you a
false sense of security because it's
aimed solely at credentialed Educators
there are many adults who work in
schools who are not credentialed
Educators you've got cust Sans you've
got food service workers you've got um
some of our par educators are not
credential under the code of conduct um
what about all the people that students
uh see who are not licensed Educators in
our public schools there are many
students who go to private schools are
students who are in um other situations
that are now funded through our Voucher
Program where is their protection so
let's not rush to pass a bill that would
give a false sense of security this bill
is is not needed this bill would only
give a false sense of Greater security
and it also does not
have the appropriate due process guard
rails um it does not what kind of a
standard is that the commissioner has
reason to believe the commissioner is
certainly not out in all the school
districts the commissioner is not
observing things the commissioner is
just
hearing one piece of information through
whatever means
that is something that really should be
coming up from the local districts
through the duty to report through the
code of conduct and through the investig
investigatory processes that are in
place in the districts there are some
things in here that are very broadly
worded um number three under the list of
things that need to be reported any
alleged Act of endangerment or cruelty
that's very broadly worded and is very
subjective that is going to open open
you up to a lot of legal wrangling
number nine alleged failure to provide
appropriate supervision P again
appropriate supervision is going to be
open to a lot of interpretation and
could be used for a fishing
Expedition um and alleged failure of a
licensed educator to report suspected
abuse at what point does it become
suspected to abuse that could be very
subjective and could lead to over
reporting to
avoid falling a fowl of this or to Under
reporting because you don't want to have
someone feel you are being too cautious
so you are opening a mindfield with this
because now you're going to be afraid of
being subpoenaed under the code of
conduct please this is not the right
tool to give someone who is also you
know holding your livelihood in their
hands with your teaching
credential there is no way to have a
productive learning relationship with
the Department of Ed that can also yank
your license when you've given them this
kind of power we urge you to find this
inexpedient to legislate I do have
written testimony I try to um give you
the Reader's Digest version and I will
pass it around I'll take questions I'm
not sure they have any better answers
than the people who testify against it
ahead of me but representative Perez
thank you thanks for taking my question
um since you meant mentioned about the
child abuse on here are you aware that
there is a statute that teachers are
mandated yes by law to report any
suspected those specific words report
mandate and suspected child abuse yes
are you aware that that is not not
covered in any way if they don't do that
conduct now I would have to go back and
read my code of conduct over again I
believe this taken right from the code
of conduct I know that it has always
been drummed into my head that I was a
mandated reporter and I needed to report
it if it's not written in the code of
conduct I thought it was so um I I I
know it's something has been always
covered in our professional development
and our annual um policy review so if
it's not there I thought it was
too follow up yes the reason why I know
it's there is I tried to get it in with
a bill this year and it was turned down
by the exact type of
um testimony that we're getting today so
it is not there even though it is a law
it is not we are mandated there's no
argument about that it's it's just you
know the wording of this makes me
concerned that we're now going to be
arguing at which point is your
suspicion serious enough you have to
report and at which point are you
overreacting um and and then
then then you get into a situation where
if you report
it are you going to be in trouble for
reporting something you know our
family's going to be suing you for
reporting it
can't but having been in that situation
of having to make the call of what
to report when a child comes
in um and I've had to
um it's never an easy call and you know
you do what you have to as a
professional um but yeah don't make
don't don't make it harder
because then you're also
breaking the relationship you have with
that family and you don't get that back
either Mr chair representative D Lorenzo
yeah thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um are you aware
that all adults of mandated reporters in
New Hampshire I was aware of that yes
thank
you any further questions for this this
witness representative Stapleton thank
you and thank you for take my question
would this be improved if uh on page one
uh Roman 13 line four instead of has
reason to believe uh there might be
something better like probable cause to
give
U the initiation of the action some
better
basis if
it um I I all honesty I'm reading
teacher I am not a lawyer so I would
like to you know have a lawyer look that
over to uh get a read on that it seems
like it might be but um that's that's a
reading teachers take on
it representative Paige thank you thank
you for taking my question I know you're
not a lawyer but given what you
know backing up with what representative
Stapleton mentioned if we were to amend
that and it was the attorney attorney
general with probable cause would that
give you more Comfort why attorney
general seems like a a much more
appropriate place because you also don't
have the conflict
between the Department of Education is
also tasked with helping to develop and
really grow the professionalism of the
whole teaching Workforce in the state so
we can better serve all our students so
when your boss is the one who's supposed
to your boss the of education is
supposed to be our boss okay supposed to
help us all learn how to serve students
better and when that's also the one
who's you know going come with the
subpoenas because you
know pil you to provide appropriate
supervision which in some instances
maybe someone complained about a poster
on your wall that
may um welcome all students so that they
feel safe and in part of your classroom
and someone thought that was
inappropriate
um yeah it it it's hard to look up to
someone who's got subpoena over that
kind
of artwork in your
classroom yeah it just does not lead to
an atmosphere where you feel you can
learn from a person like that and grow
to be a better teacher and better serve
your
students representative cutab MH thank
question I guess in regard to the last
statement that you just made regarding
you know looking up to a boss and and
the a poster on the wall I don't think
that this bill was meant to to be
anything to do with a poster on the wall
some pretty serious allegations and
isn't a boss supposed to kind of make
sure that you're doing the right thing
on here I mean would you feel better if
this was more tailored to to exclude
wherever you which whichever line you
think is saying that it can be a poster
on the on the wall like I'd like to know
which line you think that is because I'm
seeing sexual assault physical assault
endangerment cruelty like a lot of very
serious
allegations I don't where's the one
about a poster on the wall I must be
sorry
if you kept it to strictly narrowly
defined terms that might improve it but
we've also seen through the divisive
Concepts lawsuit that indeed the
department has engaged in fishing
Expeditions so I don't think giving them
more tools to allow them to engage in
more fishing Expeditions is going to be
helpful thank you representative
tur yeah I just want to ask one question
thank you by the way um following up on
representative PA's thought just a
moment ago are you aware of any reason
currently in law why the Department of
Education could not go through the
Attorney General's office if they needed
to subpoena something I am not aware of
any reason that they could not do
that any further questions for this
witness seeing none thank you uh the
last witness to speak on the bill will
Eno thank you I have no written
testimony um and no longer any direct
State
um skin in this game because my son has
now
graduated when he had when he was in
fourth
grade I was too afraid to put skin in
the game further than sending out the
email entitled with the subject matter
dragging my son through the Halls it
went to the
principle his special education case
manager the teacher that dragged him
through the Halls the guidance
counselor it went to everybody that was
a mandated reporter and made no attempt
to make a
report I had gone to him after work to
say good night to him and he was not
asleep at 1030 p.m. he screamed they
dragged me through the Halls he was
referring to the teacher and the parah
he had been sitting outside in an empty
Hall thereby not
disrupting any ongoing classes he had
sat there alone through recess the only
person on that floor EX except for
another um child who was my daughter
that happened to notice him there cuz
she was allowed to go up to that floor
to grab her
hat nobody made such a report I was
afraid to file the police
report the par professional seemed very
afraid the mandated there are no teeth
in the mandated reporter
law there's no enforcement of that they
circle the wagons this particular
teacher could be heard on a regular
basis screaming at these children from
the library to classrooms away where I
volunteered my son had sensitivity to
sound and as a special
educated trained teacher she was aware
of this she was aware of another student
being very sensitive to
light she she would use an adjacent
classroom sometimes and um get one kid
in trouble for the light
sensitivity tried to that he was in
there with my son um my son said yeah it
wasn't me that turned off the light it
was the other kid everybody knows with
him it's light with me it's
sound she would cause physical pain to
both of these children at any
opportunity
professional claimed that they were
merely escorting the child to the
principal's office but that explanation
didn't explain how he came off the floor
and um into there into the position
where he could be escorted there were no
cameras this teacher was dismissed the
following year I had asked privately
went into the principal and said keep an
eye on those cameras I've heard from my
neighbors it's a neighborhood School a
public school I've heard from my cameras
this woman from my neighbors This
Woman's been doing this for quite
sometime and now the cameras are there
they weren't there they weren't
on yet when my husb when my child was
dragged through the
hallways he will never forget it he's 21
now and wanted to bring him um to
testify but I really didn't want to um
pull up the PTSD that he still has he
said he would never forget it I believe
questions representative Perez thank you
thank you thanks for taking you said the
teacher was
dismissed do you know if the teacher
went to work somewhere else I don't
actually she was um I I guess guess I
misspoke she retired at age 47 the
following year which I thought was quite
suspicious okay um but I wasn't privy to
any background of why that might have
happened thank you any further questions
for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
is there anyone
else wishes to speak on House Bill 1353
would it be possible to get some
technical assistance from Miss Fenton
that I see as in the audience just to
ask because we did have several kind of
from the test testimony pointing out
about the doe being able to get the
documents already and I just I want to
clarify is this still the case um are
they able to actually get what they need
would that be possible M Mr chair could
I just ask a followup on the
housekeeping business is not to it's
somewhat related in that some folks have
submitted testimony with insufficient
copies if they've submitted them
electronically if you're still in the
room that's great but if you just had a
hard copy Mr Trumble and
um uh Christine Downing for two so I
just want to make sure that that's in
the record somewhere yes the clerk has
those and we'll distribute them to the
you microphone please thank you there we
go I knew I was missing something uh
good morning for the record my name is
Diana Fenton I'm an attorney with the
Department of
Education I oversee the code of conduct
I'm happy to answer any technical
questions that this committee might have
that pertains to House Bill
1353 I will just uh initially address
that um my understanding in speaking
with the Attorney General's office and I
want to be clear it's just my
understanding I I could be mistaken I'm
interested in what the gentleman had to
say about the DHHS statute um allowing
the Attorney General's office to issue
uh subpoenas on behalf of of another
agency but my understanding in speaking
with the Attorney General's office is
that they are not able to do that um it
does sound from the prior testimony that
there would have to be a a
statutory um enactment for that to occur
certainly that is a possibility that the
Department of Education would not be
opposed to but that would be have have
to be something to to be looked at um
also on page two of the bill and I think
this will help to um address some of the
issues is in line two and three it says
the
investigation must pertain to a
certified educator and the individual
must be under investigation in
accordance with the rule so that term
under
investigation is a term of art for lack
of a better uh understanding in
accordance with the Department's
administrative rules and the
investigative piece is when the educator
is notified formally via certified mail
that they are actually being looked at
they are under investigation and that is
opposed
to um the department receiving a phone
call saying this happened to my child we
want you to look into it and the
commissioner just saying all right let's
issue a subpoena and look into it we
have to have enough of a factual basis
to put someone under investigation and
that's why as part of this bill there
has to be that threshold if you will to
then um allow for the issuance of a
subpoena uh the department is happy to
take any questions the department is
also happy to work with uh the other
stakeholders and the sponsor of this
bill to further address any of the
raised representative kab thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question and coming here today we we
heard some testimony related to this
bill isn't needed that you guys are able
to already get the documents that you
need and I just I wanted to to to
clarify are you able to get copies of
the documents that you would need to
actually kind of do some sort of due
process with this so if you could please
elaborate on that I'd appreciate it sure
so in large part we have a really good
working relationship with the districts
and our partners and we want to maintain
that really good positive working
relationship
and the resistance if any that we have
received because again most districts
are very Cooperative with us the idea
being that if there's an educator who is
misbehaving and harming children in
their District they want to work with
the department they want to ensure that
that individual will not have access to
other children in other districts we're
all on the same page with that concept
um there have been times where school
districts and their attorneys will say
you have to come into the law firm
office you cannot take the report with
you you can only review it it is the
property of the school dist district and
the law firm that hired that outside
party to to do that investigation and so
there have been times where I have gone
into law firms and just been allowed to
review it I cannot take it with me and
that can cause problems moving
forward but my testimony last year and
my testimony this year is in large part
we have very good working relationships
I cannot sit here and say there was a
case that the department could not move
forward on because I could not have
access to that report
but there have been times um notably the
ho Lan case right here in conquer where
I had to go into the law firm I had to
read the report I could not take it with
me I had to follow up later and ask for
that report and send them a request
letter that they could have easily
denied they were able to turn that over
to me but in that kind of case the
department does not want to be in the
position where we are unable to get the
information that we need this really is
just a a a tool of Last Resort it should
not be used as a as a witch hunt or
anything like that any safeguards that
this committee is willing to put into
place the department is is happy to work
with this committee and the stakeholders
consensus representative Perez one last
question y sealed records do you ever
have any problem getting sealed in
records
I can't think of a time where I've had
that fact pattern in this particular
role I could imagine that that would be
rather challenging um and that would
probably be an instance in which we
would utilize a subpoena but I can't sit
here today and say oh there was a case
in which we weren't able to access those
records um that's just not an experience
that I've had and again I want to
emphasize that in large part we have
have really good working reports with
the district which is what everyone
ultimately wants um but the districts
have their own attorneys and their
attorneys work on hiring these
third-party investigators to produce
very lengthy very well done sometimes
very expensive reports and that is their
property it does not belong to the
Department of Education and their
lawyers certainly can say we want to
protect ourselves our clients and our
districts and we would like legal
process and that's really what this tool
for the Department is trying to
anticipate and and work with the
districts on that but in no way uh shape
or form does the department want to do
anything that would harm those really
positive good working relationships with
the districts thank you very much for
your time representative Ming did you
have a question please just a quick one
um is under investigation def a defined
term in the administrative rules it is
set out in our administrative rules I
off the top of my head I don't know if
it's listed as you don't have to give me
a citation but thank you because I'm not
able to do that but um uh in the revised
rules that we're currently working on we
do we do Define what investigation is
but for our purpose it it is a term of
Art and I appreciate the question thank
you representative tur yeah uh thank you
and thanks for the question these
reports that you said are owned by the
districts and and and their attorneys
are they um subject to 91a can they be
know that's a good question
I um well I I think the short answer and
I'm not a right to know expert I'm
certainly familiar enough with that
version of the law as a state employee
um yes I think the short answer is yes
but they would be heavily redacted and I
think if we we um recall the conquered
school district report as it pertained
to the ho leang case I think that um
that was released under right to know if
I recall correctly and it was released
to the public um May was heavily
redacted but again you're going on my
memory uh so please take it all with a
grain of sand but I think that's
right thank you attorney fenon if you
could just do us a favor fill out an
appearance card I will certainly do that
thank you very much thank you very much
we'll now close the hearing to House
Bill 1353 we'll let everyone in the room
know we're about 45 minutes behind
schedule so we're going to roll right
into house bill
1115 and uh if you've gotten written
testimony again please do not read it to
us we're capable of doing so give us the
sweet and condensed version and uh we'll
try to get back on course to the members
of the committee you'll get one question
each until everybody else has asked a
question and then we'll go to round two
thank
you and once again representative Lynn
stage uh thank you Mr chair I guess this
is my day to be to be a witness rather
than uh a member of the of the uh asking
questions but anyway I'm Bob Lynn I'm a
representative from Windam um and uh
House Bill HB
11115 uh I'm not going to spend a lot of
time on this because I assume you're all
familiar with this this is this is I
think the third time I've introduced
this bill it didn't pass the first time
it passed last year uh the house
but uh died in the Senate
um this bill um is uh I have to say it's
it's sort of a pet peeve of mine because
it reflects it's an effort to overturn
uh a New Hampshire Supreme Court
decision that U to me just doesn't make
any sense um uh essentially that
decision
says that if you have if a uh a landlord
of restricted property and basically
that can mean uh if you are a landlord
as small as a landlord that owns a uh
two rental units as long as you don't
live in one of them um uh if you if you
own a two unit non occupy you that you
don't live in two you rent out to two uh
you have a duplex and you rent out both
units to other people you are subject to
uh that's rest restricted
property you are then if if you enter
into a lease with a tenant for a
year at the end of the year the tenant
can can
leave you on the other hand if the
tenant does not want to leave you cannot
evict the tenant um under this New
Hampshire Supreme Court decision
um I think I've kind of gone into the
details of this previously and I don't
want to take up time because I know
we're late the only thing I would say is
I know that there are a number of a
number of people here to testify in
opposition to this I suspect that much
of what they will say is that um
particularly or among the things they'll
say is that the the uh the housing
market is very tight right now and that
the you know this is would be a bad
thing to do uh given the the housing
market I I guess I would um this is you
know based I guess on their view of
economics it would seem to me that the
opposite is actually true
because what you do what the what the
law as it now stands means to a
prospective
landlord don't take a chance on a on
some tenant that may be marginal that
may that may be marginal because if you
do um you're stuck with that tenant uh
you cannot evict the tenant and
potentially um that that you know the
tenant could stay there for a very long
time whereas if the law was that you
know if a if you make a year a lease for
a year it actually means that the lease
is for a
year landlords May might be very will
may be very willing to say well all
right you know this person's credit
report was a little sketchy or um
somehow I've heard that you know maybe
this uh this uh uh this person is uh
boisterous or whatever and I'm going to
have other neighbors are going to be
complaining or whatever um but it's you
know I'm willing to take a chance
because it's only for a year and at the
end of the year if it turns out that my
worst fears are are realized then
um then I just won't renew the lease the
the landlord can't do that now and to
the extent that that people would say
well you know if they're if the landlord
if the tenant really was uh uh abusive
or uh did something uh that you you know
was dealing drugs or doing some other
some other uh uh bad thing then then
that's a separate grounds for evicting
them sure it is a separate grounds for
evicting the problem is proving it the
problem is trying to prove it um you
know you know will will
you will you be able to get other
tenants to say that yes this this tenant
was uh was uh dealing drugs or using
drugs or whatever or will the tenants be
afraid to the other tenants be afraid to
do that U will will other tenants be
willing to say um uh you know this
person was always uh they were always
making a lot of noise they were up late
at night they were always carousing
whatever um uh and interrupting other
town or will they be afraid to do that
um that's what a landlord will have
those are the things that a landlord
will have to think about and and
uh that will discourage if the law
remains as it is that will discourage
landlords from taking a chance on on
marginal tenants which it seems to me
will will work to the detriment of the
of the very people that many of the
opponents of this bill uh say they want
to protect uh with that I'm happy to
take any questions
any questions for representative
Lynn none thank you representative
charlottte De
Lorenzo I'm sorry representative Ming my
apologies yeah thank you and uh thank
you for taking my question um since I'm
new to the committee maybe you can humar
me and um just kind of go into the
reason for the six-month term being oh
essentially the floor ceiling depending
on how you look at it yeah no no no no
that's very I'm sorry I'm sorry
representative m I I forgot about that
but no you're right I I think the
one the uh and I I remember um when I
first introduced this bill uh before I
did I had a discussion I believe with
with uh attorney Barry who is here today
who will I know who I know opposes this
bill but one of the things that I
thought he he raised a valid point on
that I agreed with and that's why I
Chang this is if if you have a very
short-term lease and I thought that the
six-month you know thing it I I think in
that circumstance it it is fair to say
that the the parties to the lease sort
of anticipate that you know it's it's
not likely that the lease is going to be
terminated in such a very short period
of time so I think in that circumstance
that that's that's why I I uh I put the
the six-month cap in uh once it gets you
know I I and I think that's a reasonable
period of a reasonable period of time
follow up um thank you um so so that
that's fine for a full for a contracted
lease um but for a tenant Let's see we
can even go to the language right here
um line three for lease or tency the
term of Which is less than six months
but which has been renewed for a total
period of six months or longer
um can you can you kind of get in get
into that aspect of it because I I I do
I I see see your point with with a
contracted term but maybe you could
address that as well sure so I what I'm
what I was think the reason I worded it
this way is what I was thinking is and I
think this may be relatively rare but
probably not you know not not extremely
rare is if you had a tenant that right
from the beginning rented on a
month-to-month
basis you know I could see even though
you even though that circumstance you
might technically say well look you you
know you you knew from the beginning
this was only a one Monon lease and
technically that's true I think most of
the time it's fair to say that a tenant
would anticipate and I think the
landlord would anticipate that you know
unless there was some something really
unusual where the tenant said you know
look I need to rent this place for 30
days but then I'm leaving um in which
case you'd presumably have uh you know a
specific term that said that but if you
if the if the landlord and the Tenant
just rent on a on a month-to-month basis
for 30 days it would seem to me that it
it's reasonable to say the tenant
probably expects and so does the
landlord that this is going to be this
is going to go on and uh and that and
that the landlord you know is not going
to is not going to throw you out at
least for six months uh despite what you
know technically uh the the the term of
the lease might say so I don't have any
problem first for with with up to six
months and that's why I put that in the
way the way I
did thank you representative
Stapleton thank you and thank you for
taking my
question
um you know in a lease or rental
contract um would there not be
um termination for cause uh or
nonrenewal for cause if there's for
instance a troubling or risky tenant and
certain actions are enumerated within a
lease or rental
contract um that that would afford the
protections
that that you're looking for here as
opposed to just a
blanket um right to cut off at the end
of the term of the lease well well no I
mean that that's a there are a number of
things in the St statute now that you
know that do constitute a grounds for
for eviction so that I mean and among
those would be you know taking action
that's detriment you know damaging the
property for example or or disrupting
the quiet enjoyment of other tenants and
those kind of things that you
know those un those unquestionably would
be grounds for terminating for
terminating the tency the problem is
that um
you got to prove that and and you know
what the
the the concern that I have uh for I
mean beyond the fact beyond the fact
that it seems to me a contract should
mean what it says but the other concern
from a sort of policy perspective is if
you want to encourage landlords to rent
property to people that might have
otherwise have a hard time finding being
able to rent property it seems to me the
wrong thing to do is to say to the to
the
landlord there will be no time limit on
this lease because then the landlord
might say well you know I I really have
some concerns I'm on the fence about
whether I should leas to this person or
not if the landlord is in that
circumstance now under existing law the
landlord's going to has to say to
himself if I if I sign this lease with
this person it may say a year year but
it's not really a year it's as long as
the tenant wants to stay there as long
as the tenant continues to pay the rent
and all that and
yes if I can prove that the tenant has
you know is a drug dealer or has damaged
the property or something like that yeah
I can use that as a grounds but if other
wi you know if there's nobody if PE if
other people are afraid to say that the
person's dealing drugs or afraid to say
that they're that they're disturbing
other tenants because they're afraid of
what that tenant will do to them I I'm
not going to be able to prove that and
so you know that will discourage me from
renting to this person in the first
place representative trip thank you Mr
chair uh thank you for taking my
question
uh if you have a
lease is does that uh give
the renter an expectation of a fixed
monthly rental
fee sure if you have a Le oh if you have
a lease I mean you the lease would say
you know the rent is $500 a month or
$1,000 a month or whatever so so if
you're on a
monthly uh I don't know what the proper
term is uh uh rental is there an
expectation that the the the rental fee
will will not be
increased no I would say if it's a if
it's a month to month I would say
probably not that you you know the the
rent could I I could be could be
increased um but you know I mean you
might you might have some expectation
that at least for some period of time
Beyond a month that you know the rent
would stay the same I would think it
would be you know pretty unusual for in
a month to month for the like at the end
of the first month that the landlord
said says well you know the rent's now
gone up 10% uh I'm not saying that
legally that couldn't happen but I think
it would be unusual so so if you were
going from a from a from a a oh excuse
follow followup
sorry so if you're going from a from a a
a fixed term lease to a month-to-month
lease is would uh would there be some
expectation that the uh the uh the
rental fee could increase oh sure yes I
mean I you know that I think generally
the law is putting putting putting this
whole thing aside I think generally the
law is that if you know if you have a
lease for a year let's say and the and
it was $500 a month in my example at the
at the end of the term if neither party
says really says anything but the tenant
continues to live there um that then
that converts from a from a one-year
lease to a month-to-month teny tency and
it it sort of continues until one party
or the other changes it so the landlord
might say at the end of the year okay
you know you've in you you sort of are
still here um from now you know now the
the rent goes up to $550 a month and the
Tenant can take that or leave it if the
tenant doesn't like it tenant can leave
okay well thank you very
much representative tur thanks thanks
for taking the question I my question is
sort of a technical going around the
Supreme Court case itself um was it that
the lease sort of just had an end date
on it and they said you couldn't prcl
you couldn't terminate someone because
essentially just the lease ended and I
guess the question I'm wondering is did
the Supreme Court case state that you
couldn't put a clause in a lease that
sort of stated that both parties agree
that it would not continue um beyond
that or I guess I'm trying to Wonder
Could could this be handled in the
language of a of a lease contract versus
a a legal thing where both parties have
consented to that I I think the answer
to that is is no in in in this in this
sense and and let me let me say as I as
I recall from that case um you know
there was a the the least term was I I
think it was a year but um I I don't
remember but in words in some sense the
parties because the lease term said this
lease is valid for one year from you
know whatever date to whatever date the
the parties I think the parties had
already agreed to what you know and in
the tenant and had already agreed that
this is the term of the lease so I mean
if you're if you're saying
could could the parties in that
situation draft a lease that said is you
know this this leases for one year and
we really mean it um that you know and
I'm and I'm and
and and I I as a
tenant understand that there's a Supreme
Court's decision that says that the
landlord can't let me can't force me to
leave if I don't want to leave but I
wave my rights under that Supreme Court
decision you know I I I don't know uh I
suspect if the theory that if
the the people who wrote that Supreme
Court decision and I have to say it was
not me for sure it was long before me um
the uh I think the argument would be
that you can't do
that that that would be just as bad for
tenants you know they could be sort of
coerced into signing that kind of a
document too and it wouldn't and so it
wouldn't my suspicion is that that it
wouldn't change anything but I I
don't know that for
sure representative
Divine um thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question couldn't it
be possible that in the first lease say
that you could have a contract with the
tenant that said any rollover into a new
lease the following year had a
stipulation that um a 10% or a 20%
increase in the rent if they do not
decide to provide
that then they have maybe 30 days or
whatever it is to you know end or
terminate the original lease oh oh look
no I mean there's no qu as why wouldn't
you do that in the state to begin with
instead of having this statute then well
but I guess I mean you know one of the
one of the things I have and I think I
said this last time one of the things I
have to say candidly to to to to the
committee
is for a landlord who who wants to get
rid of a
tenant there you know is there a way to
do that sure the landlord can just at
the end of the year can just up the rent
and and and failure to pay the new rent
will be a grounds for for for evicting
the tenant um so
you know there there is there are I'm
not saying that there aren't other ways
to do that but I guess the real my real
problem is with this is do you really
want to do that do you want to say to a
landlord you know do you if you want to
if you want to get rid of this tenant
for whatever reason you can do it just
up the rent and and if they and you know
maybe you maybe you up it to something
that you know they can't afford and so
then you've gotten rid of them I would
rather
you know I I I think that many land
owners would not want to do that and
that they would prefer they they would
just prefer to be able to be honest with
the tenant that you know we had a lease
for a year the year's up and now I want
you to go but but if but the short
answer to your question is yes you could
certainly change the the amount of the
rent follow up uh wouldn't that just be
give grounds for equal treatment to um
the tenant if it's already stated in the
original cont contract that there is
going to be an up and and you alleviate
this kind of thing all you know a new
law put into place it would alleviate it
if the landlord already was upfront this
is what's going to occur I'm giving you
you know some leeway here um and already
had it in the original lease that when
it comes up to a year up this is what's
going to happen the rent is going to go
up 20% there's no question about that
and then it'll continue say they stay
for another year after that it's going
to go up another percentage or it goes
up gradually and if the tenant already
knows
that that's how it's going to proceed
then it gives them some power to say you
know what I don't want my rent I'm going
to look around for another place or
whatever in the meantime and have that
conversation with the landlord instead
of something that is okay just based on
power power of the landlord having the
power to you know say okay you're out I
don't want to deal with you anymore
there
are it just seems to me that it would be
more equal if it was already stated in
the lease these things are going to
occur and then you wouldn't need this
and if we already can do
that in this state why would we need
this
law I guess I'm I'm not I'm not sure
that I that I completely understand what
you're getting at I mean it's the you if
if you're asking could you draw could
you draft a lease that said as an
example the rent is $500 it's a year's
lease the rent is $500 a month for a
year after the years over the rent goes
up 20% and to use your example you
certainly you could draw a lease that
what what I would
be what I would be concerned about is
presumably if in in the thing that I'm
sort of the thing that I'm worried about
is not discouraging landlords from
renting to people that that the landlord
may have questions about whether they're
so if if I was going to use the solution
that you propose to to to sort of
alleviate that concern
then I would want to make sure that what
I said the rent was going to go up to at
the end of a year was a was a pretty big
amount that I was pretty sure the tenant
wouldn't be able to make because if
because if I you know if if the rent
only went up 5% let's
say the tenant might very well be able
to pay that and if I and if my concern
at the beginning was I want to be able
to make sure I can end this lease if the
if my worst fears are are
met I probably wouldn't want to do that
because I wouldn't you know the fact
that the tenant is paying 5%
more if it's still if if he or she is
still you know dealing drugs
katab to kind of follow on rep divine's
question would you think that if you did
such a thing as saying standardly that
I'm going to increase your rent by 20%
or whatever number it may be that then
that would also C encourage tenants who
are really good tenants that the
landlord may also want to stay to then
leave because they think that their
rent's going to go up by 20% would you
think that that would happen sure I mean
I that's I think that's a I think that's
a you know exactly if you if you uh if
you have a tenant I mean if you if you
don't no I guess you you know you you
could do that you could have I suppose
you could have that Clause that says you
know I'm going to raise it by 20% but as
representative K points out you're gonna
you may then discourage people
so representative
gon thank you for taking my question if
the expiration of a lease is not
enforcable then how is any other
provision of a contract enforcable
regardless of what you put into that
contract how do you enforce
anything that's that's my problem I mean
as I I think you pointed out the last
time you know in this case Justice Netto
not Tina Netto Joe Netto who was my the
first Chief Justice of Superior Court
when I was there and then went on to the
Supreme Court um you know an appointee
of Governor Shaheen hardly a sort of you
know property rights Advocate that is
you know uh right-wing person he wrote a
concur opinion saying this basically
saying this is crazy we've we've we've
basically told uh uh We've basically
overrule this the contractual provision
saying that uh a a a year a year's lease
is a year's lease um and and uh he he
concurred rather than dissented because
there were some procedural issues in the
case um that that he felt merited you
know merited that the that uh him going
along with the majority on the on the
bottom line but uh in terms of the
reasoning he said this this just doesn't
make any sense and I agree it doesn't
follow up thank you if I remember
correctly another issue that came up
last time was the 30 days in advance
that seems to be in in in all these
landlord tenant bills 30 days seems to
not be enough time and I can agree with
that um and I thought on several other
bills that we had talked about it being
60 days uh if we amended this to be uh
providing the tenant with 60 days
advanced notice that gives a lot more
time to for that uh tenant to
find adequate housing afterward would
you be that I have no problem with that
at all no problem with that at
all any other questions for
representative
Lynn seeing none thank you thank you
Lorenzo
uh
oh thank you Mr
chair my name is representative
Charlotte D Lorenzo and I represent New
Market and newfields in Rockingham
district
10 I oppose this bill I opposed
it last year I opposed it the year
before um in current New Hampshire law a
landlord cannot evict a tenant without a
reason legally that means no eviction in
New Hampshire without just cause if HB
11115 passes the bill would allow a
landlord to EV evict tenants in good
standing for no reason at all and
through no fault of the tenant merely
that the landlord wants to take
possession of the apartment at the
expiration of the lease term this would
be a no fault eviction right now New
Hampshire law is only allow at fault
evictions this happens when a tenant has
violated the lease agreement and the
landlord wants the tenant to move the
landlord must file the eviction case in
a Ser court system the tenant has a
right to a fair trial in court in in
front of a judge with New Hampshire's
housing shortage these no faal evictions
would increase housing insecurity and
homelessness if passed HB 11115 would
displace families and create crisis
displacement could disrupt a CH
children's education daycare
Arrangements in the parents commute to
work I'm going to quote from the case
that we were talking about earlier it's
Amco versus casha ztz and that is the
statute were the expiration of a lease
to
con to constitu good cause then tenants
could be evicted arbitarily from their
home through no fault of their own such
evictions as the legislature undoubtedly
realized creat substantial hardships for
tenants at Worst Tenants may become
homeless as a result even when another
residence is procured the tenant must
hear the bear the expenses and
inconveniences of moving relationships
with friends and neighbors may be
disrupted children may be forced into
new school districts and local services
and support systems for elderly and
disabled tenants may be lost such a
result would be contrary to what the
legislator
intended furthermore were the mere
experation of the lease to to constitute
good cause for eviction it could enable
landlords to evict when the true reason
for eviction is illm motivated and I'll
stop right there um
so there were lots of questions earlier
of
um representative Lynn when um he was at
the podium one of the questions was
about um well can you can you just write
a lease that has a
annual automatic rent
increase oh yes you can
but I feel that as a former landlord
that you know I can I can write um a
lease with a 20% increase you know each
year but you know something as a landl
my job is to make a profit and with
20% I could be leaving money on the
table especially if the rental market um
goes up or the rental expenses go up um
so that's just one of the questions um
I'm ready for questions if anyone has
any thank
you any questions for representative D
Lorenzo um I guess I actually have one
representative what about in a situation
of a uh landlord like in the Sea Coast
or Lakes Region that rents uh vacation
rentals and then they enter into a uh a
winter rental say from October to March
excuse me October to May that's eight
months um would a lease like that be in
contravention to the Supreme Court
decision I mean both parties understand
that it's an 8-month lease it's beyond
the six-month what happens in that
situation I'm not a lawyer so I really
couldn't tell you but my gut is that
that would be a different type of
property it would be non-restricted
property okay very
good representative orgon
um we've been um because the prime
sponsor is telling a lot about eviction
is a way to get rid of somebody you
don't want your property but is there
anything is there anything in the law I
mean I or that forbids you from you know
doing the opposite and incentivizing the
Tenant to leave the property like
offering them enough of an inducement so
they'll be willing to leave voluntarily
and although I suppose that's not quite
as practical in the current housing
market where it's very much sellers
market and there's virtually no
inventory and the prices are so high but
there isn't anything legally that would
forbid you from actually incentivizing
somebody who you want to get rid of to
leave voluntarily is there excellent
question know there is not um AAR
against incentivizing urging someone to
move in fact um uh in my career I have I
had um paid people to move because they
were nuisances or dealing drugs or and
we couldn't you know we couldn't get
them out then you know $500 uh if you
move and they took it so that was a
great
question representative Perez you made a
comment you incentivizes them because
you couldn't get them out my biggest
concern with this and I looked up the
definition of lease agreements and lease
and this and in other states as well you
own the property right that's my biggest
concern and I also called the
registry last year I didn't call them
again this year there are a lot of
people that are turning their Apartments
into condos to get out of this situation
which is only hurting the housing market
have you heard of that happening at all
uh not
generally thank
you any other questions for
representative D
Lorenzo seeing none thank you thank
Kyer thank you Mr chair for the record
my name is John Ker I live in New Market
uh and I oppose this bill the current
rental vacancy rate is.
6% that means someone looking for an
apartment it's going to take them
several months uh our state is about 30%
renters my town in New Market is
actually 50% renters I own a small
restaurant and a number actually all of
my employees rent and a number of them
actually walk to work because they live
right down the road uh they do not own
cars in fact most a lot of them and I'm
just concerned that if this legislation
were to pass uh it could disrupt their
lives if they could not find housing in
a close proximity to the restaurant um
also some of them have kids in the
school system and I feel like their
lives could be negatively affected by
this legislation thank you I'll take
questions if anyone has any
representative
Smith thank you um do you have
difficulty in finding enough
uh staff to employ uh yes it's been hard
I got a good crew right now it's gotten
a lot better in the
last six months but prior to that it was
it was really hard so I I have a really
good crew right now and I want to keep
them so I want them to be able to stay
Apartments representative
gon thank you for taking my
question do you know of any tenants that
up uh I do not I mean I know after you
know after the year when you're on the
month to month it would be hard you know
I mean presumably your your lease is
going month to month after that so other
say any further questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
lame
hey my name is Brandon lay and I'm an
organizer with rights and democracy uh
seeing as we're 45 minutes behind time I
want to skip my written testimony here
um I actually think a lot of the
arguments uh against this bill have
actually already been said today um I
think we've highlighted how many ways we
can get rid of a tenant already under
current New Hampshire law um we've
mentioned representative D Lorenzo
mentioned something called Cash for keys
right we give you money you get
out under current law there are many
other ways of getting people out either
through negotiating with them or through
builtin Clauses in the lease and I want
to give you my lease as an
example when my lease expires in
February my rent goes up by $1,000 a
month month to month that is a provision
in my lease that incentivizes me to
resign my
lease and this is what most reputable
landlords
do so if you can't negotiate with your
tenant or you can't you know put in a
clause ahead of time saying hey when
this lease
expires um you're going to pay an extra
thousand bucks a month sorry I get very
uh choked up right now so I'm just here
because I care a lot and my pet peeve is
people being put out on the streets and
this law would make it easier to put
people out on the streets it would
destabilize tenants and it
disincentivizes landlords from working
with their tenants so I'll cut my
testimony short I just want to send you
some testimony about a landlord
Manchester who is against this bill so
questions representative gon did you
question any questions for this witness
Mr chair I'm sorry representative De
no further questions you're excused
Peg um good morning and thank you for
allowing me to testify my name is Jane
ha and I live at 1573 Union Street in
Manchester and I'm just testifying on my
own behalf although I work with the
group
called the Manchester housing Alliance
and um I really think like I'm opposed
to this bill and it seems like a bill as
many other people have said some of the
problems it seems like a bill that's in
search of a problem to solve because uh
landlords already have the opportunity
to um evict tenants you know if there's
a problem and
um I think that the sponsor of this bill
has contradicted himself coming up with
on unlikely
hypotheticals for instance um first he
said that you know if the tenant was a
problem tenant because they were
creating problems and noise for the
other tenants but then he said well
maybe those tenants will be afraid to
actually officially complain I mean it's
kind of one way or the other either you
got the complaints and you had them
write them down or you don't um we
already have eviction for
cause um we have a housing crisis as
other people had said we have
a 6% vacancy rate so it's going to cause
a lot of disruption and I think that you
know landlords own the property that's
fine we allow them to make a profit on
the property which they do but they're
also part of the community and I think
that they um they have to um participate
in the social contract that we all
participate in and be part of the
community and not not exacerbate the
housing crisis by uh having more
evictions you know and as I said there's
already the opportunity for eviction
with appropriate cause so I just don't
see why this bill is necessary at all
thank you and I'll take
questions any questions for this
sky
thank you chair and members of the
committee my name is Rebecca Sky I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
State Commission on Aging the New
Hampshire State Commission on Aging was
created during the 2019 legislative
session to provide guidance to the
governor and state legislature on issues
related to
aging the Commission on Aging advises
against this uh bill as written um the
commission feels that the rights the
bill would give to landlords will have a
disproportional harm um upon tenants the
commission's interest in this bill is
focused on of course older adults as
well as the low- wage worker workers who
um provide essential services to older
adults in the
state um the vacancy rate has already
been talked about at at um 6% uh far too
low to support a functional Market um
those older adults living on fixed
incomes relying heavily on Social
Security are often priced out of housing
at rates higher than the general
population those with mobility issues
also face hurdles the United States
Census Bureau issued a report on in
October 2023 that found that less than
20% of housing stock in New England is
age rity age rity means having a
step-free entry and a bed and bath on
the first
floor in New Hampshire the percentage of
people aged 65 to 74 with a disability
is
21% the percentage increases to 42% for
ages 75 and
older I think that the the premise of
this bill is really focusing on um
tenants who might be bad actors and I
just wonder about what are the
protections for tenants against
landlords who might be bad actors um I
just wonder let let's say I'm renting a
place I um experience a disability where
I need some reasonable accommodations
some grab bars put in perhaps or
something else as and and as a
landlord
uh um I start to make those
accommodations but I really don't feel
like it what happens to that tenant
that's where the disproportional harm
comes in I'll end my testimony now given
time uh and answer any questions thank
you any questions for this
witness see none thank
you uh Mary
Osborne
hi I am my name is Mary Osborne um I'm
from Dober New Hampshire I am a single
disabled mom to an amazing son with
special needs I actively participate in
my community frequently using my voice
to Champ housing and Disability Rights I
testified against a similar Bill last
year um emphasizing how its Passage
would affect my son and myself um deemed
model tenants for our prompt rent
payments and property care um last year
I shared the challenges I faced as a
voucher holder in finding an apartment a
process that took a dating nine
months securing a space felt like
winning the lottery um unfortunately
this year's housing circumstances are
even more dire um if this bill is
approved it will create an environment
where I hesitate to voice concerns to my
landlord fearing attention I'll be
reluctant to request repairs and Live In
Perpetual anxiety about the stability of
our home if for any reason my landlord
decides otherwise there will be no
alternative for me homelessness will
become an inevitable reality and with no
available shelter space
my only choice will be which parking lot
to park my car in or makeshift home as
an active Community member I engage with
various organizations and committees um
I have a letter that several of them
have signed on to I'm not going to read
the full thing because I've I'm giv
youall copies um but it just stresses
that the good cause requirement provides
tenants peace of mind the simple
complaint about an unsafe condition
won't result in an eviction when their
lease expires it allows individuals and
families to plan for their future
maintain continuity in their lives and
establish Roots within their communities
for more than one lease period at a time
by taking away this crucial Safeguard
the proposed bill would make it possible
for property owners to upend the lives
of renters frequently and without any
legitimate reason and that it dis
proportionately impacts lowincome
individuals and marginalized communities
such as older adults and those living
with mental illness or other
disabilities like
myself um so for these reasons um I urge
to oppose this bill any
questions any questions for this
[Music]
Cornell
I have written testimony that I will
also good morning uh my name is Kirsten
Cornell I am an attorney at New
Hampshire legal assistant and I'm here
today uh to oppose this bill a lot of
the uh a lot of what I was going to say
has been said and I know we're short on
time so I'll try to keep it to the
points that haven't been mentioned um
the the requirement for good cause
eviction so to be clear you can evict a
tenant in New Hampshire for cause so for
um things like a material lease
violation a threat to health and safety
things like that there's also a
provision that allows a landlord to EV
for other good cause which includes any
business or economic reason so
essentially New Hampshire law just
required that a landlord have some
reason to evict a tenant this can also
include taking the property off the
market doing renovations such things
like
that I think that uh representative
Divine came got to really the Crux of
the issue in her question um about where
she know she mentioned the matter of
power and I think that at the end of the
day this bill is about trying to allow
landlords to have more power and
attendants to have
less the decision that was referred to
by representative
Lynn noted that the reason that they did
not believe that the mere conclusion of
a lease term should constitute good
cause was to balance the interests of
property owners to control their
properties as well as to protect tenants
who are trying to access one of the most
fundamental needs that all humans have
which is
shelter um
it's important to realize that un leas
agreement is not a contract in the
typical sense of the word it's not a
situation where you know two or more
parties come together and bargain to
agree to terms that are uh beneficial
across the board but in a landlord
tenant relationship there's an unequal
power Dynamic that doesn't allow that
kind of bargaining that kind of
negotiation what a residential lease
amounts to a is what the law would call
a contract of adhesion which is
basically a form document that the
landlord set the terms and the tenants
can take it on either a take it or leave
it
basis tenants don't sign six-month
leases 12-month leases because they only
intend to stay in these units for that
long they sign them because they have to
and because that's their option in order
to access that fundamental
need these are people's homes uh taking
away the requirement of having cause for
eviction creates a situation where only
homeowners will be able to access the
kind of housing stability that most of
us take for granted it's been mentioned
before that in order to uh keep kids in
houses in the same schools in order for
people to maintain employment all of
these things turn on the ability to stay
house and to stay in the same
community in a housing crisis like the
one we're facing right now where there
was a 55% increase in homelessness
between 2022 and 2023 which was the
largest percentage increase in
Nationwide an eviction is highly likely
to result in some period of homelessness
and if not that displacement to a
different part of the state where a
family or an individual will have to
begin to rebuild their
lives beyond this this law allows
landlords to essentially every every 6
to 12 months not have to give a reason
to evict a tenant which makes it easier
to dodge fair housing laws because you
don't have to state in tent it's harder
to enforce anti-retaliation
laws and also prevents people from or
perhaps makes puts tenants in fear of
speaking up as you heard marriages say
about conditions issues which lowers and
which lowers the quality of Housing and
New Hampshire and makes it harder to
enforce the minimum housing
standards we heard representative L
suggest that at the end of the lease
term you know tenants have all of you
know they can say stay or go and that
landlords have are stuck with that
tenant with all due respect I have to
disagree at the end of the lease term
the relationship between the two parties
stays roughly the same landlords can
create the leas terms that they want
they can change leasee terms they can
increase the rent they can decide to
renovate the property they could take it
off the market they can do any number of
things the only thing they cannot do is
swap one tenant for another without a
legitimate reason tenants on the other
hand are still in a position where their
only option is to take it or leave it
and right now leaving it pretty much
means leaving housing so I urge you to
support tenants by opposing this bill
I'm happy to take any questions the may
have any any questions for this
witness representa keny thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um so you somewhat touched on
this at the end of your testimony uh we
heard from the prime sponsor that a big
reason uh he sees the need for this bill
is because landlords uh will not want to
take a risk on tenants um that they see
as risky without this um without this
in-law and that if they did have a
reason for cause it would be hard to
prove I just wanted to know if you had
any input on that um I I think that in
this housing market it's unlikely a
landlord will be in a position to take a
risk on any tenant they're going to have
multiple applicants for any unit I think
if we want to incentivize landlords we
can look at bills like s SP
518 um and there's there's a few others
that are trying to create circumstances
to incentivize landlords I think that if
a if a landord does take a risk on a
tenant and there's no reason to evict
tenant to that tenant for cause under
any of the provisions then that tenant
has proved themselves and they shouldn't
be subject to eviction I think that
we've heard people say that it's you
know they have to prove a for cause
eviction and that's
true but it shouldn't be easy to take
away somebody's home it's reasonable to
expect a landlord to use the lawful
process of eviction and to prove that a
tenant has done something wrong before
they lose their
housing um for more information about
the reasons that uh landlord can evict I
did send around the um the standard
eviction form that's available uh on the
Court's website so there's additional
information about reasons for evicting
there but um in short I think it's
unlikely that a landlord will take a
risk for that reason and I also think
that it's reason to have to prove
cause any further
house good afternoon to the committee um
my name is Alice house I'll keep this
short I am I live in Durham New
Hampshire and I oppose Bill
1115 um I believe if residents have not
done anything wrong they should be given
opportunity to renew that lease housing
is not just a product or service as
we've been talking about but a matter of
safety shelter and just because people
are renting should not mean that that
safety should be taken away from them um
I have rented an apartment in Durham for
the past several years being able to
renew my lease has allowed me to focus
on my studies and on building Community
with the people around me rather than
having to look for a new place each year
um as an out ofate student who doesn't
have family to let me move um or to stay
with if things get rough um and without
access to a car consistently consistent
housing is really critical and moving is
a difficult task that has to be planned
ahead for um so having to find a new
place especially if it were for a
shorter lease um would have caused me
stress and possibly
houselessness um and as we've been
talking about because house housing is
scarce in New Hampshire especially in
Durham um my friends who have had to
look for housing on short notice due to
mold issues job changes Etc um have been
very hard pressed to find anything in 30
days some did not find anything in their
price range and are um losing money by
staying in Durham but they have to um so
I just ask you not to put the option to
evict People based on end of lease in
the hands of landlords instead of
renters um I also worry that it is
easier to raise rent with new tenants is
they may not ask questions as to why
that rent is going up um in a new lease
this I saw this happen when I signed at
my apartment and the only reason I knew
that I had gone up is because I knew the
last people who lived there um the
increase made sense but it wouldn't I
wouldn't have known um that that was the
case otherwise so I just worry that this
bill especially in Durham if passed um
could be used to get rid of tenants not
for being a nuisance but just because um
of like being able to raise rent prices
or um other reasons other than what you
already can get rid of a tenant for
under the current laws so thank you very
much for listening and I will take
questions any questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
Kremer
I got one copy for everyone but I can uh
hand in the other one at the end as well
um good morning my name is Ben Kramer I
live in New Market um I'm organizing
director with New Hampshire youth
movement I represent an organization
with a base of over 100 dedicated
members and more than 5,000 supporters
ages 15 to 30 across New Hampshire um
I'm speaking today on behalf of young
Granite Staters and as a renter myself
um as I testify opposition to this bill
the real problem with this bill I think
in addition to what everyone has said I
just want to like underscore like the
problem with this bill is it puts a
trapo under every renter in the
state that it's a lever that can be
pulled at the end of their lease and
then they have to scramble to find
housing and I I just really want to
underscore the reality of what that
means if the trapo is pulled um for a
renter particularly young renters but
renters um in this day and age in this
state so I think the the fact of the
matter is under this bill the most
likely scenario for someone unexpectedly
evicted at the end of their lease
because you do not need good reason
under this law um the most likely
scenario is that they experience
homelessness for at least a short period
of time um and just like think about
everything that needs to go right in
order to avoid being homeless first they
need to be able to find new housing that
they can afford that meets their needs
and this is in a housing market with a
6% vacancy rate as people of other of
other people have said that's within 30
days it took me three months of
searching to find my current apartment
this is difficult then they need to be
able to afford first month's rent a
deposit that's likely over
$3,500 that's an upfront cost that's
money that they need to have on hand and
be able to spend at this moment people
do not have that money I do not have
that money the vast vast majority of
Myers do not have that money and then if
those two things go right they need to
be able to actually move into this new
place in time that's additional money
it's additional time that people just
don't have um so that's an extremely
slim chance of avoiding homelessness
right the most likely reality is when
their 30 days are up they're left with
nowhere else to go and I need to
underscore the statistic as it's
heartbreaking to me New Hampshire has
the fastest rising rate of homelessness
in the country 52% last year we' have a
moral obligation to House people in the
state and this bill puts in a trapo
under people who are already in housing
and want to stay in that housing for the
long term it exacerbates that issue um
finally I just need to underscore like
I've been a renter since moving to the
state almost 10 years ago the vast vast
majority of young people are renters we
need young people to stay in the state
they are a
future but we cannot stay here and we
want to stay here we cannot stay here if
we don't have stable housing here so
this will drive young people out of our
state we'll drive everyone out of our
state or onto the streets and I think
that's a reality that we can't
accept um yeah I'll keep it to that I
urge the committee um keep New Hampshire
a state where we can count on housing
for the long term make a future for
ourselves um urge the committee to
oppose this bill we'll take any
questions if you have
it any questions for this witness seeing
next
hello my name is Lee Heath and I oppose
Bill
1115 I am a student at the University of
New Hampshire and I would like to share
my story my mom was a single mom
struggling multiple jobs we had to move
Apartments
frequently because single mothers have a
disgustingly High eviction rate and I
saw it
firsthand landlords would dig for any
excuse to get rid of just the two of us
they lied we caught them bribing
neighbors to submit complaints and even
with the warning sometimes we wouldn't
be able to find a place in time and
would be on the streets in the alley
behind whatever job she was currently
working it
um this is a horrible thing to be a
homeless before the age of 10 with your
mother while watching um the landlords
get more money from the next
tenant I trust me when I say no landlord
needs it to be easier to make good
working people and children homeless
thank you I will be taking
questions any questions for this
individual this witness excuse me seeing
Barry thank you Mr chairman members of
the
committee uh for the record my name is
Elliot Barry I'm here testifying myself
uh on my own um on my own behalf for 47
years I was an attorney at in Hampshire
legal assistance and um probably had the
honor of representing more tenants than
anybody in New Hampshire history uh I've
also had the opportunity I was the
attorney who argued the Je case uh I
have appeared before uh representative
Lynn and always enjoyed it um but
there're just a couple points that I'd
like to go over uh that may not be clear
in the in the case of um
where it's been suggested that it's
really so difficult to uh evict a tenant
one thing that we should know number one
last year alone over 3,600 tenants were
actually evicted that's not the ones who
left after they got the eviction notice
it's not the ones who left after the uh
eviction action was started that's just
where a RIT of possession was issued
over 3,600
households in addition to that when it's
not easy right when you when you have a
behavior-based eviction if you look at
RSA
540 section 16 C you will see that there
is a very clear hearsay exception uh
that landlords can use to bring evidence
of complaints against tenants that the
landlord received uh on or near the time
that they uh that the complaint was made
and that is used regularly in The
District in the district division so
that landlords don't have to produce
live testimony in many many Behavior P
um behavior-based
evictions um um I want to also point out
that and remind the committee
that in under the conventional the good
cause law that we're talking about today
not only are there all these reasons
based on tenant fault but any legitimate
business or economic reason can be the
basis for an
eviction contrast that with our
manufactured housing Park uh legislation
which goes back to
1975 that legislation provides that the
only reason you can evict somebody is
for something that they had done wrong
failure to pay rent violation of park
rules Behavior which which threatens the
health and safety of others that has
been in effect since 1975 and the
industry is doing just fine I believe
you will see in the record a um a letter
from terara Reen who worked for the new
Community Loan Fund where they funded
the acquisition of I think 140 150
manufactured housing Parks that's
working fine when tenants can only be
evicted for something they do
wrong
so I'd also like to briefly um look at
the issue about risk taking a chance on
risky tenants number one when you've
heard about the market conditions and
you're comparing two tenants and one has
a
pretty basic record you a fine record
and the other one not so good do you
really think in this market that many
people are going to take advantage of
that and say Yes uh I'll take a chance
on you because six months later I can
evict you for no reason I doubt it but
then there's other the more fundamental
question is is it good policy to put
tens of thousands of tenants at risk of
an arbitrary
eviction in order to give a a select few
a chance at getting theoretical chance
of getting chosen when they're Dean
brisky I don't think that that's a a
fair quid proquo I also want to talk
just a little bit about the kinds of
people who are at risk you know will a
landlord evict somebody for ab
absolutely no reason no but I'll tell
you what are very typical reasons where
ca I've had cases myself you have a
family with the child and the child
cries at night that's what children do
that's what children do or they had to
take an upstairs unit and sometimes the
child jumps around you know that may not
be great from the landlord's point of
view or even the tenant below but are
you going to make that family confront
the risk of homelessness because a kid
acts like a kid another kind of eviction
which I have had time and again where
you have either you have seniors or who
are don't like me don't have the
faculties that they used to have or or
you have people with mental illness and
they act differently than other people
other people are uncomfortable about
around them that is a big problem to put
somebody like that at risk of
homelessness because they're different
from other people now somebody here and
I'm sure representative Lynn you thought
of this are there anti-discrimination
statutes both federal and state there
sure are and you know what the time
frame for HUD Housing and Urban
Development to process those those
complaints are the law says they're
supposed to do it in 100 days and in my
experience right now they're probably
looking at 140 160 days how is that
going to help somebody beating eviction
down the road when when that's not even
going to be litigated there even be a
determination of probable cause for
months and months and months probably up
to half a year um so and this applies
again of course you know another kind of
situation is where the landlord may be
just fine about uh representing uh about
uh uh renting to uh um people of
color and that's fine but maybe the
neighbor isn't so the neighbor makes
complaints after complaint after
complaint to the landlord about the
minority
tenant you know that can't be grounds
for revic of course but but the
complaints can't and the point is the
landlords this is the kind of thing that
does happen I'm not saying that all
landlords do this but this is something
the chance to evict for no reason with
no
explanation uh makes it very very easy
as the jish decision points out out um
you know I could go on and on and I know
you don't want me to and there's plenty
of other people here who could um who
have stuff to say I just want one more
question I think it was yours uh
representative Wallace you asked about
people with vacation rentals or um uh
recreational rentals there is a specific
statute called RSA 5 chapter 5 uh 40- C
which allows for evictions without even
having to go to court uh for
recreational and um and vacation
rentals and I'd be happy to take any
questions any questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
please
hello judicial committee my name is
Nicholas Patrick and I'm an independent
from Dublin New Hampshire and I'm here
to oppose House Bill
1115 RSA 542 which is exactly what this
is amending was made specifically in
1985 for
anti-discrimination if we were to amend
the bill the way they want this would
absolutely open the door for racial
sexual and religious
discrimination the Supreme Court of New
Hampshire agrees with me in 2005 they
made the decision that if we amended it
in the way that we did it absolutely
useless and my biggest question is what
other reasons would you need to evict
someone we already cover safety laws we
already cover Health laws we already
include just taking the rental
completely off the market and raising
rent not only that one of the Clauses
specifically says any other good cause
and my big complaint would be wouldn't
selling drugs fall under
that and then we already talked a little
bit about the vacancy rate so I'll skip
that part it's 0.8% for all units and
0.6 for two bedrooms which is the most
common and not only is this bill this
amendment to the bill wrong it's also
just cruel it's cruel to take children
out of a school district they're already
simulated into it's cruel to strip
parents from their Community they in the
relationship and resources that they
already have there and it's also cruel
to tear apart communities that will
absolutely increase
crime and as a resident of New Hampshire
I've already seen the brutality of
renting in this state and more
importantly I'm a college student at UNH
and the town of Durham has already taken
a part of discriminating against
properties and I promise today that if
this goes through it will abs absolutely
be used against students in the
state and will be further used to neuter
the education and talent that's needed
in the state and I am a proud Granite
stator but my state has failed me and my
friends who have no choice but to move
to other regions as the housing
situation here becomes unbearable for
the working class thank you and I'm
happy to answer any questions you might
have any questions representative
Smith I'm torn about asking this
question but as your representative one
of three Durham Representatives who were
sitting right here I was somewhat
surprised by you saying that the town of
Durham has taken steps to discriminate
against students do you have facts to
support that not not opinion but facts
so I mean I can't bring up the specific
meeting but specifically it's not I'm
not saying that you Representatives have
done it but on a a town level we've seen
different types of housing be built and
we've seen the specific types of housing
being built as well as our school
administration I don't know if you heard
about that had huge budget cuts but also
is having a huge housing crisis and
students are starting to flood outside
near campus housing and it's been
extraordinarily hard and we've seen and
also if you go to the town meetings and
look at not even the administration but
the residents themselves there's been a
lot of um I'd say discrimination and um
oppression towards the students well
thank you so clearly it's it's your
opinion and of course you're entitled to
it but you don't have the facts to
demonstrate well if you look at what
they're building it that is the facts is
what they're building the types of
departments they're building are for
students I'm violating a very important
Rule and that is we do not debate in
these hearings um I just felt it um
important to understand the great
difficulty that the town is going
through in terms of trying to meet
everyone's housing needs and I imagine
that at least the three of us would be
happy to talk with you and your
colleagues about things that we might do
to work together thank you absolutely I
appreciate your question as well any
further questions for this witness sing
none thank you Lane
Joselyn and you're asking for seven
two hello committee members um my name
is Lane and I'm reading testimony on
behalf of someone who couldn't be here
today so her name is Mel Bennett my name
is muel Bennett and I'm a student from
UNH as well as a longtime resident of
New Hampshire currently splitting my
time between Durham and Berlin I'm
testifying today in opposition to HP
1115 New Hampshire is currently in a
housing crisis and this crisis is
particularly affecting young people like
myself we need ten protections that
increase housing stability in State not
decrease it which which this bill would
do as a young person who calls New
Hampshire home I have found housing to
be one of the biggest barriers to my
personal success in the last year I've
moved at least seven times I've Liv I've
lived on couches in a tent brly in one
apartment and dorms in a shack and in my
car when it was 11
outside I've worked two to four jobs at
all times during this time period it's
not because of my lack of working that I
haven't been able to afford afford rent
is that as a young person in college I
simply cannot afford the going rate of
housing in the
state will I have not personally been
evicted I know all too well what it
feels like to lose housing in a
heartbeat is this what happened to me
this past August when I faced unexpected
car repairs and suddenly could not
afford
rent increasing chances of eviction for
tenants in New Hampshire is a dangerous
decision as more folks would would face
situations similar to mine some being
forced to live in cars on couches and
even on the streets for this reason I
urge you to oppose HP
11115 thank you for your
time thank you for being brief any
questions for this
TBO
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Keith TBO I live in
Swansea New Hampshire um I will be brief
I'm just going to make a couple of
points um I have been an housing
Advocate and served on our local Housing
Trust our local Housing Coalition boards
and I work for an organization that is a
landlord uh to people who are have
lesser
means if the main reason for this bill
is to for a landlord to take a chance on
someone that they otherwise wouldn't
they
shouldn't they shouldn't take that
chance they should allow they they
should move on to someone
else being a a a good tenant isn't easy
but once you've achieved
it it's an asset it's a lease is an
asset a home is an asset for someone of
lesser means they may have no other
asset that they can count on
think about assets you have that if you
had an issue in your life you could
count on they don't have that so the two
two points I want to make is if if this
bill is just there for a landlord to
take a chance and then get out of it
they're doing no help to that tenant
they're enabling them and they should
say no we say no to the residents who
apply on a regular
basis thank you very much I'll take any
questions you might have any questions
for this Witness
doosa good
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Tom
do roza uh here on behalf of housing
action New Hampshire where I serve as
the engagement and Communications
manager be very brief housing action New
Hampshire we're a coalition of uh 80
organizations we're United around
the simple goal of uh improving state
and federal policy so everyone in New
Hampshire has a place to call home many
of our members are landlords they
develop they build and they manage
affordable housing properties and we're
here today in opposition to HB 1115
since 2009 housing action New Hampshire
we've been working in partnership with
policy makers from across the Spectrum
this ranges from folks who see housing
as a widget in the free market and those
who believe housing um is is
a human right so the one thing that is
clear from everybody that we've worked
with over the years is that New
Hampshire does not have enough housing
uh and the shortage has adversely
impacted all tenants P particularly low
wage um earners as as Mr TBO just
mentioned uh so we would argue that at
this time especially in the midst of
this housing crisis it makes very little
sense to tip the scales more and create
an even more vulnerable situation for
tenants and we would urge the committee
uh to find HB 1115 inexpedient to
legislate any questions with with this
witness saying none thank you you TOR
on hello my name is tor Bamford and I'm
a resident of do uh as we've disced just
today good housing is hard to find the
price of a single family house is higher
than ever mortgage rates are as high as
they've been in a long time and the
rental market is saturated which drives
up the cost of monthly
rent the ability to renew a lease is as
normal a practice as refinancing a
mortgage for a landlord to evict a
tenant for no other reason than the
ending of a lease it then makes that
tenant vulnerable to homelessness which
which makes them vulnerable to financial
hardship and worse Health worse Health
outcomes and more homelessness financial
hardship and worse Health outcomes make
our communities
vulnerable for myself personally if I
found myself in this situation I know
that I have the privilege of being able
to live with family I would be okay
others may not have that privilege for a
number of reasons you've heard testimony
from some of some people with these
stories this
morning landlords should only be able to
evict tenants for a good cause thus
backed up with repeated evidence there
is a legal pathway for eviction and this
bill is not the right pathway stand up
for people who don't have the privilege
that I have stand up for the well-being
of our communities please oppose this
bill any questions for this
witness seeing none thank you the
please can you hear me now thank you hi
my name is Jessica Marson I'm aant
organizer with Granite State organizing
project but I am here today representing
myself um I wanted to start with a
couple things
um one thing to make sure everybody
knows ahead of time before I forget is
um court paperwork commonly when I have
a tenant that has a renovation eviction
um that comes into my tenant Clinic to
help um I have to just tell them you
know a renovation eviction is different
than a non-payment this can sometimes be
helpful when you're looking for a new
place make sure you show your next
landlord that this is why you're being
evicted what a lot of people don't know
is that after 3 years that paperwork at
the court is thrown away and what they
can go back to get is called a case
summary it doesn't list what type of
eviction all the nuances and motions in
there it just lists everything like um a
table of contents basically so tenants
are advised to hold on to their
paperwork so in the future 10 years from
now they go to apply they can explain
that eviction um so with our ra U the
mass renovation evictions we've had over
the past few years it's been very
detrimental in tenants trying to find
housing when it relates to
discrimination that's something I can
speak on huge I see it left and right in
the tenant Clinic I'm currently helping
two different tenants with
discrimination issues but I'll tell you
that that eviction paperwork moves a lot
quicker than a grievance or a HUD
complaint does to try and help them
through the Discrimination so they can
in fact become um
could almost become evicted before they
deal with that discrimination this would
make this bill would make it quicker for
that to happen currently tenants right
now are terrified to complain about
valid safety issues in their units
because they're scared of that
renovation eviction this will be the
second thing they're scared of it
commonly takes families at 30% to 60%
area median income 6 months to one year
to recover from a move I know that I've
had to go through multiple moves lately
with uh my kids leaving the house and
it's been detrimental to me um there's
not enough places out there I've had to
create programs that help a tenant show
that they are good tenants out there um
but this bill does not help any
minorities it does not help those single
mothers who are routinely and there's
facts there's a study on that that you
can find where single mothers are more
routinely evicted than fathers we're
seeing as simple t targets easy targets
we're terrified to lose our home for our
kids we'll do what it takes to keep it
um so I urge you that this is not the
time for this bill maybe when we have a
more robust Market but we have a good
thing right now which do cause where
other states are trying to be like us
why do we want to get rid of a good
thing thank you thank you any questions
for this
witness seeing none uh is there anyone
else that wishes to speak on House Bill
saying none we'll close the hearing um
Mr chairman oh can I just ask a question
uh it's very brief it might be for the
clerk do we have the current numbers um
for those who signed in support of this
opposed
kab standing
by online we have 10 in support 147
sheet 12 opposed here 12
yeah so um representative
Gallagher yeah I'm going to uh open the
hearing now on uh House Bill
1368 and I know we're running late I
that and I'm going to call uh
there's
area
all right so hi I'm representative Eric
Gallagher uh representing marrat County
District 20 which is conquered W
6 um and I am here to introduce House
Bill
1368 prohibiting termination of a tency
based on a tenant failure to pay rent
that was increased by Sur and price
fixing programs so um I'll just start
off by saying that wasn't my original
title for this bill um my
original title for this bill would have
been um relative to the right to inspect
source code of rent setting software for
tenants um so you may remember
from um the previous year of this term
uh I had a bill before this committee um
providing for a right to um inspect the
source code of
um software used to generate evidence in
criminal proceedings so um one of the
major criticisms of that and the reason
it died was uh well um it will hold
up um it will hold up hearings too much
and
um so yeah I could I could see that um
some criminal hearings do actually need
speed for them so um I was thinking all
right um what other sort of court
hearing could I introduce a um right to
inspect source code into so um while
thinking about that I come across this
um propublica article um
about
um
this company's algorithm um there's this
company called or software called yield
star that um landlords are
using
um for rent setting purposes um and so
when I learned about that I thought oh
okay this is actually a perfect
opportunity to con combine two of my
separate um issue area is um of interest
um both the um open- Source software on
the one hand and then housing on the
other so um I thought all right let's
move this right
into eviction
proceedings um so the thing
about um so the thing about yield star
is it's basically this proprietary
program which none of the rest of us
really know how it works for all we know
could be there could be some network
communications going on communicating
with other landlords to lead to some
sort of um price fixing setup
um where there's um illegal Market
coordination and if that sort of thing
is going on we should be able to have a
way to find out about it and I think the
best way to go about that would be to be
able to find it out during the eviction
proceedings for um a tenant so basically
the idea is that um tenant facing
eviction
um if they thought that their landlord
was using the software um would exercise
their right to inspect then then upon
inspection if it's found out that yes
they were indeed engaging in price
fixing then the ition would be invalid
um so yeah I see this
um as a tenant protection bill
um so um yeah part part of the thing
about free markets is they're supposed
to work when everyone um sets prices
independently rather than
colluding on them um because if they are
um
if you do have collusion then um it
can it can lead to prices much higher
than what the uh Market will otherwise
determine so um I think that
um yeah having a right to inspect source
code would be a good way of fighting
this I'll also note that
um I since having filed this bill I've
learned that there is also um Federal
legislation pending on this topic um
Senator Ron weiden is one of the chief
sponsors um although
I'll I'll note that um they filed that
after I'd already filed mine so um I I
don't haven't really had a chance to
look at to see if it handles things in
the same way or a different way um but
it is something that other people have
an interest in addressing legislatively
too um so yeah that's uh HB
1368 and I'll uh take questions on it
now all right questions for this
witness don't see any so oh yes I'm
sorry representative
man thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Gallagher for taking my
question I believe you characterized
yield Star as being proprietary so I'm
wondering how there would even be open-
source code to have access
to
well the idea would be to require to
make them to um have them make it open
source and also sometimes proprietary
companies will be violating um will be
violating the licenses of open- source
code that they make use of um so there's
certain um there's certain open source
licenses known as copy left where it
um that if you're going to use this code
you have to keep it open source and um
basically the way you find out about
that is by lawsuits um if if some if if
it is using open source code um without
someone filing a lawsuit about it then
that sort of um license violation can
just go by undetected so um I think um
giving another
chance
um giving um eviction hearings as
another venue for determining if that's
happen happening or not uh would be uh
um helpful for determining if that sort
of thing is happening other questions
yes representative D Lorenzo hi thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I am really confused I read
this bill and it didn't sink in um so
we're talking about uh yield star
software what do they do so basically
um so basically landlords will um
use this software to um for advice about
what they cons sent the r to they'll say
like um okay this is what my current
rant is and then the software will say
oh well actually how about you try
setting it to this value instead so then
they go and do that and then they can
um they whe When the tenants ask hey why
you guys they can they have it basically
gives them something to offload
responsibility onto oh the algorithm
made me do it therefore you can't blame
me for raising your rent um so yeah if
you're going to be handing off the
responsibility for how you make your
rent pricing decisions to an algorithm
we should at least be able to see how
that algorithm
works I follow yes please so um with
that are you saying
that
tenants deserve to know what factors are
driving their rent yes that's that's um
exactly it thank you other questions for
this wit representative tur uh yeah
thanks and and thanks for taking the
question um when you were talking about
yield star it it seemed unclear whether
or not we know that this software
actually does the type of sort of
background collusion I guess is what I'd
call it um that that's being referred is
that is that true do we know whether
this is actually happening um in in the
software or in any other or any other
software right now and and I guess would
that be covered by you know uh any law
prohibiting that kind of collusion um so
what we do know is that landlords are
using the software what we don't know is
uh
if it's uh enabling the sort of
collusion that I'm concerned about um so
and yeah the reason that or the fact
that we don't know is precisely my
reason for introducing this so that we
can know um you know um I I think you
know it if if you star truly
isn't doing
anything uh anything wrong then they
should be able to show us and show the
tenants whose rent it's increasing that
it's not doing anything
wrong can I ask one quick qu of course
do we um I guess I'm wondering the idea
of attaching this to the idea of an
eviction um seems a little tangential to
I guess the underlying question you're
really sort of trying to get at whether
or not um rent prices in general are
being fixed by this right as opposed to
I'm C curious about why the attaching of
this to the idea of an
eviction um well
because
um well because that's what the effect
that high rents has is in creating
evictions um you you know the um the
eviction
follows precisely or yeah one one of the
reasons that evictions can happen is due
to non-payment of the rent and if the
rent was too high because
um it
was priced in an improper faction then
um that that shouldn't be something that
tenant should have to
pay Mr chair representative Lorenzo
thank you for taking my question so um
when I was working in housing um I would
set the rent using a market study I
would go to three comparable properties
and find out you know you know what that
what those owners are charging for rent
and then make you know come up with some
numbers for my own property would that
be considered price
fixing
um I
mean I I think it would only be
considered price fixing if you were
using a specific piece of software to um
enter into an agreement with the owners
of those other pieces of property that
you're comparing against um if you're
just looking at them
independently and um not not talking
with the other owners at all then yeah
that's fine that's just the market at
work but um the it's the um
communication Factor um the Collision
factor that is um whe When landlords get
together um to make their pricing
decisions that is what I'm worried about
thank you other questions for this
witness representative orgon how does uh
how do they collect the data to feed
into the algorithm I is there some sort
of a is there some sort of standard uh
source for for for rals I mean it's not
like it's not like if you're trying to
figure out what to sell a property for
where all the uh where all the sales
have to be recorded with the Registries
of Deeds so there a public access uh
data source for it so how do they how do
they find the numb to feed into their
algorithm
um so it um I I guess I should probably
send around the article in question to
the um to the committee uh I'll email
that afterwards but um yeah it says that
um software uses aggregated Market data
from a variety of sources in a legally
compliant manner but that's the company
representative saying that so um it's
basically just you have to take their
word for it that that's how it works um
and I think further investigation if
into whether they're telling the truth
or not would be
useful other questions for this
witness representative
me thank you thank you for taking my
question um so I guess one question I
have
is if the source code is is allowed to
be admitted to to evidence it becomes
public record do is that the intent for
it to be freely available to everyone
intent um followup yeah I guess not
exactly followup just a like a secondary
question
um so what part of the source code do do
um what would you what do you anticipate
finding in the source code some sort of
connection between landlords yeah some
sort of oh yeah go yeah some sort of
network connection um using um like if
what what I'm imagining would happen is
there it probably has some sort of um
Telemetry in it where um you know it
suggests a price to the
landlord um they either choose to accept
it or not um and then it um basically um
if it phones home or yeah phones home
with that um data and then um the all of
the data that's been phoned home to
their servers then gets put into a
larger model that um takes all of that
into account um
that yeah that that would be the sort of
behavior that um I'd be concerned
about um followup yes so it it would be
some kind of excuse me it'd be some kind
of geographical data Maybe um some way
of identifi identifying the location of
these requests through IP address or
something like that um zip code I guess
um that like I I mean i' assume the
addresses of the actual units um being
granted would be part of it um
okay but yeah something like that other
questions for this
wit so I guess I just have one it if I'm
understanding correctly it sounds like
you're you're concerned about sort of
antitrust violations by landlords and
and that you would make engaging in an
antitrust violation of the kind you
describe in the bill a defense to an
eviction yeah yes that's correct
evictions are generally summary
proceedings um I'm just wondering have
you thought about what the what the
allowing essentially a tenant to raise
an antitrust violation as a defense to a
summary proceeding would the effect that
would likely have on landlords and on
what rentals would likely be if that
were something that
landlords had to worry about as a
defense cases I mean I'm not a lawyer um
so uh yeah if you could Define a summary
proceeding for me um which means it's
supposed to happen quickly supposed to
be if the proceeding supposed to be
started and finished pretty quickly um
well yeah um I guess the
um or and does it say in law
specifically that they have to be
summary proceedings um because I I
basically would um I basically would
object to that I think that eviction pre
proceedings should not be summary
proceedings it actually does say in law
and there's pretty strict time limits on
you know various kinds of
things uh Mr chair yeah yes the
representative VI um just a question um
representative Gallagher have are you
thinking also in terms of a class action
process um yeah I mean I don't think
that's in the bill currently but I would
be open to that sort of
um that sort of future
Direction um for legislation on this
topic other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much ref
thanks right is there anyone else here
who wishes to
testify on um uh House Bill
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 1368 and open the
hearing on House Bill
9797 and do we have a card do you have a
have you fill that ah can I get your
you great thank you all right I'm going
to represent uh recognize representative
geart uh the uh sponsor of the Bill
thank you chairman members of the
Judiciary Committee unfortunately I did
not print enough copies there are 14
going around but I did email the
and so hopefully it's it's in cyberspace
getting to I just didn't expect the full
attendance and I hate wasting paper you
guys have really good attendance I just
want to say all right so representative
Jason Gard representing Franklin
norfield and the amendment unfortunately
changes the essence of the bill but it
sentence so I'll read it just it's one
few sentences not withstanding any law
to the contrary where a defendant has
been offered a plea bargain in a
criminal case that requires that the
defendant be incarcerated a judge may
not impose a period of incarceration
that exceeds by more than 10% the length
of incarceration contemplated in theow
lest plea bargain sentence in cases
where the federal government exercises
concurrent jurisdiction over a matter
with New Hampshire a federal court shall
a federal court judge shall be bound by
this law now I understand that I'm
standing between you and lunch so I'm
going to go very quickly but just try to
hang on here RSA
1231 reads seated to the United States
jurisdiction is seated to the United
States of America over all lands within
this state now or Hereafter exclusively
owned by the United States and used as
sites for post offices custom houses
military air bases military
installations or other public buildings
provided that an accurate description
and plan of the lands so owned and
occupied verified by oath of some
Officer United States having knowledge
of the fact shall be filed with
Secretary of the State and provided
further that this
session secession is upon the express
condition that the state of New
Hampshire shall retain concurrent
jurisdiction with the United States in
and over all such lands so far that all
civil and criminal process isue under
the authority of the state may be
executed on the said lands in any
building now Hereafter erected thereon
in the same way and with the same effect
is that the statute had not been enacted
and that exclusive jurisdiction shall
revert to and revest in this state
whenever the land shall cease to be the
property of the United States that's the
justification for also applying this
bill to the federal court system that
New Hampshire has concurrent
jurisdiction in such realm
so very briefly sixth amendment in all
Criminal prosecutions the accused shall
enjoy the right to a speedy and public
trial by an impartial jury of the state
and District wherein the crime shall
have been committed which district shall
have been previously ascertained by law
and to be informed of the nature and
cause of the accusation to be confronted
with the witnesses against him to have
compulsory process for obtaining
Witnesses in his favor and to have
assistance of counsel for his
defense quote representative government
and trial by jury are the heart and
lungs of Liberty wrote John Adams
without them we have no fortification
against being ridden like horses fleeced
like sheep worked like cattle and fed in
clothed like swine and
Hogs this bill seeks to prevent what is
commonly referred to as the trial
penalty if a defendant chooses to
exercise their Sixth Amendment right
which I just read trial by jury then
they are punished with a sentence that
is excessively larger than what the plea
bargain was which to me doesn't make any
sense because if the government is
willing to give an individual a sentence
the fact that they wish to exercise
their constitutional right to a trial by
jury shall not should not increase their
sentence
multifold so just very briefly from
Wikipedia article that it's actually
very well written on this just I'll just
go very fast so in a ple baring a
criminal defendant waves their right to
trial and agrees to plead guilty to a
lesser charge that would have been
brought against them at trial or agrees
to plead guilty to the original charge
in exchange for a sentence that is less
than the maximum possible plea
bargaining is pervasive in the United
States with most criminal defendants
accepting a plea deal rather than going
to trial at the federal level just 2% of
defendants elect to go to
trial the trial penalty is the
discrepancy between the sentence the
prosecutor is willing to offer an
exchange for a guilty plea and the
sentence that would be imposed after a
trial many plea Bargains require that
the defendant wave certain
constitutional rights such as the right
to challenge unlawfully procured
evidence and the right to appeal the
loss of these rights is also sometimes
considered part of the trial penalty
critics argue that trial penalty has the
effect of depriving defendants of their
six men the right to a speeding and
public trial a 2015 statistical analysis
of Federal cases by Andrew chish Kim
concluded that defendants who exercise
their right to trial are penalized with
sentences 64% longer than they would
have received had they accepted a plea
deal Kim argues that this makes a trial
by jury less of a right and more of a
trap for fools the National Association
of criminal defense lawyers has seen a
particularly heart uh has been a
particularly harsh critic of the trial
penalty arguing that is now so severe
and pervasive that has virtually
eliminated the constitutional right to a
trial which has had the consequence of
replacing the system of trial by jury
laid out in the United States
Constitution with a system of plea
bargain trial penalties they point out
impose such harsh sanctions on choosing
to go to trial with prosecutors
sometimes threatening multi-decade
prison sentences if a plea deal of only
a few years is not accepted the trial
penalties amount to coercing defendants
to plead guilty this coercion they argue
unconstitutional and it goes on but I
think that'll cover exactly what I was
trying to get to and just on a personal
note my own situation in federal court I
was offered a plea bargain right before
trial of five 57 to 71 months and
because I went to trial I was given 20
years and the game is basically played
by a adding charges or B running charges
consecutive when they ought to be run
concurrently at the same time and this
happens at the state level too and
that's why I put the bill in I think
it's time that New Hampshire protects
its citizens from federal abuses but
also at state level as well you should
not be penalized excess ly 10% I think
is fair for the interest of efficiency
whereas Justice shouldn't be a fast food
restaurant it's supposed to be
calculated and well and our rights
should be protected especially right to
trial by jury that comes from the Magna
Carta that's
fundamental to the whole American
Experience let's say so if you have any
questions I'll take them hopefully I
kind of covered the basics but it's a
pretty simple
concept uh yes representative kab first
and then representative Oregon
representative Perez thank you Mr
chairman I just if if you could just
clarify what how many months did you say
that you were offered again well I
should I'm sorry let me clarify it again
the guidelines I actually misspoke the
guidelines federal guidelines called for
57 to 71 months right before trial I was
offered six to seven years if I played
guilty but I refuse because I'm not
pleading guilty
so okay all right uh representative
organ this sounds like a jury
nullification bill in Reverse like we
get bills in this committee and others
sometimes we say the jury which I guess
is true the jury can acquit an offended
for without being accountable to anyone
else but say you're saying the if the
jury the jury sincerely feels that the
plea bargain was too lenient for the
offense um they should be denied to
right at least or at least have right
severely restricted to enforce a enforce
a harsher sentence if they uh if they
come to the conclusion that uh that the
plea bargain was inappropriately uh was
not was not as harsh as it should be and
of course I'm a little bit confused but
I'll just say that at least I have
experience with the federal system not
so much the state but at the federal
system the jury convicts you on the
charges but they have no input on the
sentence which I also think is a extreme
miscarriage of justice so the judge can
actually consider factors that were not
brought up at trial into the sentence
and that also increases the sentence so
hence the reason most people 97% plead
out which is absurd and it's just
so yes understand thank you thanks for
taking my question okay you have to
bring this I'm not a lawyer yeah neither
am I okay so let me let me understand
that so if you were offered five to
seven years but you decided to go to
trial you couldn't be offered more than
10 they could could and you were found
guilty they couldn't go over more than
10% over that is that what I'm
understanding the lowest plea bargain
yes lowest plea
bargain well if they thought 5 to seven
years was enough it seems wrong that
they went up to 20 so they punished you
for going to trial for exercising your
sixth amendment the right right okay
that's fine I I get it other questions
for this witness representative
gon
thank you for taking our questions in a
plea bargain are you not typically
offered to plead guilty to lesser
charges but if you reject that the trial
is at the higher charges is that correct
okay my I I guess you could yes
technically but this is the problem if
you are only deemed so dangerous that
you need let's just say 10 years your
plea bargain is 10 years how is it
magically that after a trial you're now
found to be so dangerous you need 20
years that's I'm not an attorney I don't
know I'm just trying let's just kind of
look at the basic element to that for
only one thing happened you said I want
right other other questions so I I guess
the the only question I have is what I
mean if if this were If This Were to go
into
effect wouldn't the result
likely be
that defendants would not get the
benefit of lower of potentially lowered
sentences because a prosecutor would say
well look in the worst case scenario
where the defendant goes wants to go to
trial and of course the prosecutor
doesn't know whether you're going to
accept the agreement or not well 97% of
the time they do okay but right so the
prosecutor says okay if this guy does
not accept this agreement U that I'm
going to make what's the likely what's
the worst sentence what what do I think
as a prosecutor is what the sentence
should be and okay I and so as let's
assume in some hypothetical case I say I
think the pro the the sentence should be
10 years so now if this is an effect I
know that I can't offer a sentence less
than um uh more than 90 I mean less than
90% of that because if I do then the
judge will be barred from imposing what
I think is a good sentence so why would
I wouldn't I wouldn't that sort of
discourage me from offering a lower plea
bargain I think what would happen is you
would fill up all the jails and prisons
in the state and people would realize
okay we got to start prioritizing who
needs to be locked up instead of making
it into the human warehousing operation
that it is right now all right other
questions for this witness
representative
Stapleton yeah thank you for taking my
question and I a little confused over
this
but you were offered a were you offer a
plea deal because you became a state's
witness I referate other charges or I
refus to the the time was out of
proportion to the guidelines because the
guidelines don't have to be they're not
mandatory they're advisory after a
Booker this case called Booker with a
it's a drug case and because judges were
um hamstrung and had to impose sentences
according to the guideline even when
they didn't believe that that harsh
sentence was justified so because the
guidelines are option um advisory now
they can just go way above way below
it's it's just a
free-for-all other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you everyone thank you and
enjoy lunch thanks Jason all right um
all right is there anyone else who
1497 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 1497 and I
apologize for us being over but we were
so we'll we'll take uh a lunch recess
now and I'll ask uh ask you to return
you
yes
for
all right um it's I apologize for being
late it's now uh almost 1:10 uh and I'm
going to call the house Judiciary
Committee back uh into session and open
the hearing on House
Bill 1640 relative to qualified immunity
standards and I recognize uh
sponsor
thank you chairman members of Judiciary
representative hle serving the towns of
Dunbarton hooks at Allenstown and epsom
here on behalf of House Bill 1640
relative to qualified immunity
standards similar bills to this have
been before this committee I was looking
back probably every year almost every
session for the last several sessions um
it keeps coming up and the question
before us at the highest level
is when does uh someone acting on behalf
of the
state have some responsibility in the
decisions they're
making in the engineering world if I
have lots of time to do a risk analysis
I'm fully responsible as an engineer in
the decisions that I make hence we do
all sorts of testing to make sure the
products that I
design are going to work in the intended
Market there 's a difference between
someone working and having to make a
split second decision and I see a a
bunch of gentlemen behind me or officers
behind me who are faced every day with
making split-second decisions and this
bill in fact speaks to that and I will I
will get to
that but there's a difference between
that and whether it's a local employee a
state employee who has months to think
about a
decision and still makes a bad choice
where where does qualified immunity
end does it end a minute later does it
end 10 minutes later does it end a week
later a month later when does when does
how much time do they get to make a
decision before qualified immunity no
longer
applies it's a good question I think
this committee is is the right committee
to start thinking about
this and the reason I say that I'm going
to bring up in in a case of my own
personal family
experience I had a state employee State
actor who thought my son was in danger
of imminent coma or death imminent being
an operative word they went to the
courts and got um an exp parte
hearing and they came to pick up my son
well that's fine he wasn't in imminent
danger of K death I saw him just before
I left to drive up here this is almost
two years ago however that department
continued to pursue that case for four
months at what point does the department
have some responsibility for their
actions to continue to harm the citizens
state when does qualified immunity kick
in the men and women behind me in
uniform which are going to be here to
testify against this are faced every day
with a split-second decision but the
bill specifically carves out what they
have to do in various sections and I
quote um page two of the bill not
including the header right page two
lines 13 and following the United States
Supreme Court has interpreted the United
States Constitution to protect police
officers and other government employees
against claims of excessive force and an
arrest investigation stop or other
seizure under the standard objective of
reasonableness keep going um page
four right that this doesn't equal this
doesn't act right relative to federally
recognized doctrines of qualified
immunity further down on that same page
541 B27 right when evaluating a
government employees use of force under
under the constitution of this state or
the the United States the Court's
determination of reasonableness shall be
objective and made from the perspective
of a reasonable government employee who
was on the scene confr Ed with the
immediate facts and circumstances of the
claim why is that in there that's in
there to address the concerns that are
going to be raised after I speak because
we don't get the chance to have we we're
as Citizens we don't make those Split
Second decisions but the reality is some
people are tasked by our government with
making split-second decisions and they
shouldn't be second guess when you've
got hours and days to think about
it I think the issue that needs to be
addressed is when you have time to do a
true risk analysis of what's going
on is the person in danger of imminent
coma or death four months after the EXP
parte hearing for
example was that should that behavior be
covered under our qualified immunity
standards as a parent I would say no as
the parent of a child who was harmed by
these actions I would say
no we owe our citizens more than
that there is a point in time where
someone making a decision has the
ability to think about the consequences
of their decision and at that point in
time they are now they they now own a
portion of that decision and the longer
the time goes between when they' first
had the chance to think about the
consequences and when they make the
actual decision it goes from no
percentage a 0% ownership to
100% if you're if you have weeks to
think about a decision and you've and
you've had group meetings over the
decision and involved others and been to
the court multiple times and you've had
doctors tell you this is a bad idea I
think you own the
decision we shouldn't be extending
qualified immunity it ruins the purpose
of that in fact I would argue the
officers behind me don't benefit from
qualified immunity when others blatantly
violate the intent of that section of
law this bill addresses it I would ask
that you would pass House Bill
1640 um as filed so that we can start to
address this with that I'll take any
questions if there are any questions for
this representative Perez thank you
thank you for taking my question so the
way this bill difference differs from
last year's bill is that you see that we
are now actually protecting our uh law
enforcement and others who make those
split SEC second decision decision it
actually it actually uses the word on P
the bottom of page three yeah starting
in line 34 the court shall recognize
that a government employee often must
make a split-second decision intense
uncertain and rapidly evolving
situations sounds like police work yeah
the court shall not determine
reasonableness using hindsight or based
on facts and circumstances that are
later
discovered that's
different
than someone who gets weeks in our case
months to weigh out a decision and still
insists that my son shouldn't belong
with our household and he has trouble
sleeping every night wondering is
tomorrow the day the two police officers
show up a second time to try and take me
from my household do I get to sleep with
with my dog tomorrow night I challenge
any one of you in this committee to have
that conversation with my son cuz he
will tell you what it felt like no
13-year-old should be subject to that
type of harm the state owns
that could we have sued
absolutely that's not how we approached
it as a family we should fix it
legislatively and the way to fix it
legislatively is there is a there is a
Time domain from when the decision needs
to be made and someone has to make
someone has to make the decision to when
they get to make it and the longer that
time domain the more the individual
Bears the responsibility cuz they can
think and weigh the consequences of
their
decision other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you uh next I'm going to call
please
good afternoon chairman Lynn honorable
members of the House Judiciary Committee
my name is uh Richard gulla on behalf of
the 11,000 hardworking New Hampshire
public employees and retirees of state
employees Association local
1984 I come before you today to oppose
House Bill 1640 and report it out of
your committee as inexpedient to
legislate just as you did last session
on House Bill
647 the Practical effect of this bill if
enacted would be devastating to all
public employees I believe your
committee took an appropriate action
last year on House Bill
647 as it was most far-reaching and
damaging legislation to public employees
that I have ever seen presented to this
house house bill 1640 this year is no
different I will speak to the impact
this bill would have on all public
employees and rely on others to explain
the dramatic increases in cost to our
state county and local governments and
taxpayers this bill would destroy the
protections of all public employees
currently have which allows for the
orderly administration of government and
for public to be served in a more
adequate manner the unprecedented
exposure this bill brings to all public
employees will exasperate The Chronic
retention and attraction attraction
problems that we are currently facing at
all levels of government in New
Hampshire when trying to find and keep
qualified people engaging in public
service excuse me House Bill 1640 would
eliminate the protections of collective
bargaining agreements by creating strict
liability for violations of laws or
constitutional rights that leads the
termination regardless of mitigating
circum
circumstances currently a just cause
provision requires an inquire into the
following one the reasonableness of an
employer's position two notice given to
the employee three the timing of the
investigation undertaken four the
fairness of the set
investigation five the evidence against
the employee and six the possibility of
discrimination and seven the re relation
of the degree of discipline to the of
the offense and the employees past
record for example under this bill every
time a defendant wins a supression
hearing a police officer can be fired
every time a city clerk misrepresents
the election law they could be
terminated every time a building
inspector denies a permit that is
overturned he could be fired simply put
every allegation of misconduct is a
terminable offense the ripple effect of
this bill would encourage unwanted
timidity in the application of public
employment and discretionary functions
it would discourse vigorous enforcement
of the law and regulations due to fear
of reprisal and it will cause the loss
of productivity due to fear of aous
litigation in this bill promotes in
addition House Bill 1640 would create an
incentive for non motorious L litigation
to be filed against hardworking
employees and their Employers in that it
provides the most easily SA satisfied
prevailing party language for free
shifting in New Hampshire the insurance
company would settle suits simply to
avoid the cost of litigation this does
not serve Justice or accountability and
it provides a full employment for plain
of
attorneys House Bill 1640 and the
misleading in it that it claims that
public employees would not be
financially liable page three lines
6-9 section section six of this bill
bill but at the same time eliminates
multiple
immunities page three lines 14- 18 SE 6
of Bill 541
b256 therefore providing the means to
sue individual Public Employees leaving
them vulnerable under laws House Bill
1640 would create strict liability for
any perceived
constitutional or legal violation
without the regard for the intent of
public employees the minor nature or any
other mitigating
circumstances for these reasons please
recommend that house bill 1640 be an
expedient to legislate so that our
public employees feel protected not
exposed continue to do the good work
they do thank you for your time
testerman this would aage or this this
bill attempts to correct a problem or at
least what a perceived problem what way
would you do otherwise you know this
bill doesn't do it what would you do to
to correct that I think this bill
creates more problems no not that not
that it creates more problems what would
problems can you give me an example cuz
I'm not seeing the problems that you're
you're you're talking about just look at
representative H
situation he he he gets a A Child taken
away or or the potential of a child
taken away and it obviously was wrong
how would you how would you correct that
law I would have to give that some time
but I certainly wouldn't correct it this
way
other questions for this word yes
representative oron yes the
well first all I guess asking about
something I saw in a another bill which
was similar which is over in the other
body on really a topic but they had a
line in there if you did um not just
state employees but I think probably
anybody who did certain things would
have a waiver of sovereign immunity
which seemed uh but see I think looks
like the way this bill is written you
have almost a universal waiver of
sovereign imunity I'm trying because it
seems to be tied to like a violation of
any constitutional right which seems to
be uh could apply to any dispute between
a citizen and a government official who
takes an action that the citizen doesn't
like so this do this so you think this
remounts a to almost like a total waiver
of elimination of sovereign immunity if
I think ultimately the state or the
county or the municipality is liable but
I think if you start putting switching
that liability the individual employee
you're you're going to have a a a
chilling
effect other questions for this
witness oh yes representative
questions does the individual citizen
have have the right to hold public
employees accountable for their actions
when they are acting in an official
capacity and if they do have that right
right depending on the circumstance I
think they would hold the employer
accountable and then the employer May
hold that employee accountable but I
think the the the direct going after the
employee is going to have a chilling
effect the way this legislation is
written yes follow would you please
define chilling effect because I've
heard that about five or six times on
five or six different bills and other
than global warming I'm not sure what
chilling effect means well I think what
it means is if being a Public Employee
if I know I can I can be sued for making
a decision individually or terminated
for that why would I go to work for that
public entity
why would
you representative foret thank you for
question are there other groups I'm not
a lawyer Nei I was a nurse for 42 years
I did not have qualified
immunity um if I made a mistake I was
responsible for it I could be sued as an
individual now that's why I carried
malpractice insurance I'm just wondering
other than state and local employees
what other groups in um New
Hampshire are covered by qualified
immunity I don't know the answer to that
right now I'd have to get back to
you other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you next I'm GNA uh call on uh
Margaret
Burns or Margaret Burns I'm if I'm
pronouncing that incorrectly I
good afternoon members of the committee
I'm Margaret burns with the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and we
are here this afternoon in opposition to
House Bill
1640 so far in the presentations on this
bill there's been a lot of focus on
qualified immunity but it's important to
note that this bill is about a lot more
than qualified immunity and it's about a
lot more than claims against police
offic officers and it's about a lot more
than claims against the state under this
bill local governments are included in
the definition of government so even
though the language of the bill would be
put into RSA chapter 541b we see
government being defied broadly as any
County municipality political
subdivision as well as any government
employer being defined in the same
manner the bill creates a cause of
action for a violation of any right
enumerated in the New Hampshire
Constitution or the United States
Constitution currently there are very
few constitutional sections that include
a right of action and even not all
federal sections are actionable or
establish a right to private
damages and currently under some
circumstances if the circumstances
justify it there are immunities that can
apply to constitutional claims but under
this bill all of those immunities would
be wiped
out in addition the bill creates fee
shifting by requiring the government to
play to pay plaintiff's attorney's fees
and costs if the plaintiff prevails and
it also includes consequent shifting
meaning it would be the employer not the
employee that would be liable regardless
of the circumstances regardless of
whether there was any action the
municipality did take or didn't take
under the circumstances of the case in
addition to paying the cost of
litigation and increased litigation in
addition to the cost of plaintiff's fees
and and attorneys fees and costs
Insurance costs would certainly go up
and all of these costs would be passed
on to the municipal
taxpayer um there was a sub a
substantially similar bill in this
committee last year as you know um that
bill did many of the things that this
bill does and this committee saw fit to
recommend that bill as an expedient to
legislate 163 the issues that were
presented last year continue to be
present in this bill although this bill
is in a different form than the language
last year so we respectfully asked this
committee to once again recommend this
bill as inexpedient to legislate thank
you questions for this witness
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um you've been in the the uh the battle
on qualified immunity for a few years
can you talk to me a little bit about
how this bill is different from previous
bills that this committee has heard this
bill is I'm going to try to remember all
the bills that this committee has heard
one of the things that's very different
about this bill is that the language is
being put into an entirely different
statute so it's being put into a statute
that pertains to claims against the
state but it's clearly a section that
would have to do with claims against all
political subdivisions as well as the
state it also broadly would create a
cause of action under any of our New
Hampshire enumerated rights under the
New Hampshire Constitution as well as
under any right under the United States
Constitution so that that's very broad
language um and there's little guidance
and little statutory basis to adjudicate
claims that could be brought under any
of those Provisions um I believe it is
also different in shifting both
consequences and costs entirely to the
employer I can't remember that
specifically but that's an very
important point in this bill is that
regardless of what actions the employer
took to properly trained to properly
supervise if an employee acts improperly
the employer is on the
hook yes um is the is there a negligence
standard so I'm seeing as in um for
instance our new um Constitutional
Amendment on privacy if a government
agency knowingly or unknowingly violates
that right to privacy that would would
then be subject to if this was law that
violation would be subject as well is or
is is the standard if they knowingly did
it if they did it on purpose the only
standard in this
bill is the standard on the bottom of
page three starting at line
31 which specifically applies to use of
force it is not a standard to be used
for evaluating any other claim that
could be brought under any other
provision in the New Hampshire or United
States Constitution that's helpful thank
you other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
ramsy thank you Mr chairman hello
members of the committee uh I am Senior
Assistant Attorney General Jennifer
Ramsey and I work in the unit of the
Attorney General's office that defends
the state and its employees against
lawsuits brought against it um we filed
a fiscal note in this case and I in this
uh bill and I wanted to also come and
share with you some of our thoughts
about how this legislation if it were
passed would impact um our work in
defending the state and its employees
and also the state's um liability
ultimately um it's our view that this
bill would significantly increase the
volume and cost of litigation against
the state uh it appears to wipe out all
immunities for constitutional rights
claims against the state except for
legislative and judicial immunity we
already defend and indemnify against
claims for damages against uh state
employees and the state on a routine
basis um the difference in the lack of
the immunities would be that our policy
makers and even our Rank and file
employees would not be entitled to to
the same benefit of the doubt and uh
although the bill carves out hindsight
as a uh a reason you cannot judge the
conduct of a police officer in the case
of use of force there's no similar carve
out for any other state actor so in
cases against uh most state
employees uh the tri fact would be
entitled to use the benefit of hindsight
to judge that employees conduct and
you're exposing the state to liability
for for uh conduct when an actor could
reasonably have believed that everything
he or she was doing was lawful um but
nevertheless once a court declares that
that was not a lawful act then that is
going to create exposure for the
State uh I Al we my office also has a
concern um that this piece of
legislation applies not only to
employees but to contractors for the
state um when we contract with someone
the Hallmark of that contract
relationship is that we do not supervise
that individual we do not train that
individual um if if we do those things
then that's an employee not a contractor
so you would be um having the state
defend and indemnify contractors when we
have no control over their actions um
the bill would
also um kind of eviscerate the language
in the state's standard contract the p37
which permits and requires those
contractors to indify the state when
they when they commit acts of
negligence um the bill would also carve
out an exception from how our office
sometimes declines to represent and
indemnify state employees when we make a
determination that their conduct is um
is
um extremely inappropriate uh and and
currently that serves as a disincentive
to those individuals um to engage in um
wanting or Reckless conduct but under
this bill we would no longer have the
ability to um decline representation of
those individuals in that
circumstance um the bill also would
bypass um the board of claims which is
currently a helpful tool for resolving
smaller claims everything no matter how
minor would go to Superior
Court um the bill
also allows for claims to be brought by
any individual for a violation of a
right so I think proxy lawsuits would be
permitted under this legislation and
that bypasses the usual requirements
that an injured individual have standing
in some injury in order to be able to
bring a
lawsuit and um finally the fee shifting
provision that uh requires that
claimants can recover their attorney
fees if they Prevail in any way um would
uh I think operate as a disincentive to
State Employees and policy makers to
make the very changes which this bill is
uh attempting to promote so for all of
those reasons um we have concerns that
this bill um would greatly increase the
the volume and the
um and the expense of litigation against
the state thank you questions for this
witness yes representative
Smith thank here I am here you are thank
you um very much um I'm I'm not going to
focus on the fact that you might have to
increase the cost or the hours because
if if there's work that you're supposed
to do and it's going to take more time
and more hours so be it but what I don't
understand at uh was one of your last
comments about attorney's the attorney
Fe section being a
disincentive could you help me
understand that yes I'd be happy to
thank you so the um the provision
provides that if a claimant prevails in
any way whether it be through uh a court
order but also through settlement or
even if the state voluntarily chooses to
correct the practice complained of that
the claimant is in titled to its
attorney fece so if uh if the state
currently what our office does is
sometimes we will g a lawsuit and we
will see that the claiming is correct
and we will advise the agency that they
need to change their practice um and
sometimes agencies will do that when
something is brought to their attention
by a member of the public um this would
actually potentially disincentivize them
to do that and and put them in a
position of wanting to um defend their
costs
oh than the explanation I guess I'm slow
this afternoon because I don't
understand it but I'm I understand that
that is your explanation and I'll try to
parse that
um thank you other questions yes
representative
gon thank you for taking our questions I
I thought I heard you say and I thought
I heard it from someone else that you're
concerned that the state or the county
or whatever level of government is being
sued would be responsible for covering
the expenses of this employee so is then
the solution to that that we go after
the individual
employee um So currently the way that um
the indemnification works is that we do
in as long as the employee is not acting
in a wanting or Reckless manner we do
already uh indemnify the employee
against the consequences of any
litigation our office defends them
that's uh presumed to RSA
99d um this would take a away our
ability to decline to do that in certain
cases where the conduct is particularly
egregious and would require us to defend
even a very egregious um situation
y if
egregious under the jurisdiction of
whatever agency or
Department why would you not be
responsible as that department or Agency
for the actions of that employee uh we
we decline to defend for example uh in
the case where somebody is um is
violating the law uh like a committing
being a criminal
offense utilizing their their access in
a through State Employment to commit a
crime and the reason we defend that
decline that representation and don't
defend that case is because that person
liability other questions for this
witness so Mr Ry can I can I just make
sure that I'm am I correct in
understanding
that
to the extent there may be any
confusion the qualified immunity that
currently exists doesn't mean that a a
police officer or anyone else who who
engages in Reckless or wanting
misconduct is is entitled to immunity it
just said it just basically it UPS the
standard of culpability before somebody
can be held uh can be held liable if
they fall within the definition of what
of of an immunity provision is that
correct you are correct yes so so in
other words where where where you or I
might be if we were not if we were just
sort of in the private sector or
whatever while we might be held liable
for
negligence a police officer who is who
is acting in an official capacity would
not be liable for negligence but could
be liable if his conduct was Reckless or
wanton that's correct generally yes for
for state employees across the board not
not just police officer but state
employees across the board yes so it
gives it gives the state employees for
lack of a better term it gives them more
it gives them more uh more latitude that
might be to be to avoid liability that
it might be the case if somebody is not
a state employee so the doctrine you're
describing the qualified immunity
Doctrine in federal court provides that
protection in in the State uh statutes
that is uh some exceptions to the claim
statute that are found in uh 541 b19 and
they're we also call them discretionary
function immunity official immunity and
due care immunity when they apply to
State Employees in State Court thank you
other questions for this witness all
right thank you next I'm going to call
please
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Kate Horan I'm here
on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association of counties just to remind
you that is all 10 counties of your
elected and appointed officials here in
the state the association is opposed to
this bill uh and we will Echo many of
the comments from the previous speakers
um our main concern is there is no
protection for a employee who simply
makes a a mistake they believe they are
acting within the law but they make a
mistake for misunderstanding their
training or whatever whatever it is
there's no
opportunity for us to correct that with
the employee a citizen could just Sue as
they do the other concern that we have
is uh to Echo the comments of the
speaker from the state employees union
uh our County correctional officers and
our County nursing homes are
experiencing severe Workforce
shortages we are losing especially in
our nursing homes nurses to Private
Industry we are losing our correctional
officers to Walmart and uh dunad Donuts
who are paying better for quite frankly
less strenuous and less dangerous work
um so why is someone going to come and
work for the county in either one of
those situations when this would then
also open them up to being fired or
additional liability that they could
experience when they could be doing
something that is less risky in their
point whether that's working in Private
Industry or working for uh a nursing
home that is a private entity and not a
County facility uh I will also remind
this uh committee that the County
nursing homes are the nursing homes of
Last Resort we are the safety net that
is where someone goes when and you all
know this when they are out of money
they can no longer afford to be at the
uh at a private facility they are most
vulnerable elderly adults and we want to
make sure that we are giving them the
best uh care that we can possibly give
them uh I'm happy to take any questions
but
um I will conclude my testimony there
right thank you question yes
representative
Smith uh you just said something
that caught my attention um having to do
with the County nursing homes that you
want to do the best that can be done for
people who have no other options I'm
paraphrasing what you said yes
man' now so connect that to the issue of
whether people who are taking care of
those vulnerable people are to be held
accountable for inappropriate actions
thank you for the questions and we
certainly want to make sure if someone
is doing something criminally wrong that
they are being prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law um but if someone in
the County Nursing Home simply makes a
paperwork error they probably shouldn't
be at risk of losing their job or being
sued for a simple paperwork error and
there are no standards within this bill
other than uh what the sponsor
referenced around use of force listed in
this
Bill thank you other questions yes
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
would any if this bill were to pass
would any violation of 91a right to
privacy be considered an ability to
sue thank you for the question yes we do
believe
so other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you next I'm going to call on uh
Tyler
Gua close sorry if I didn't get it
right good afternoon chairman Lynn
members of the committee for the record
Tyler Goa I am the uh director of
government and political Affairs for the
professional firefighters of New
Hampshire we represent 43 local unions
in 2000 active in retired professional
firefighters and paramedics across the
granite state we advocate for the
well-being and safety of the brave men
and women that protect the citizens of
this great state today I'm here in
opposition of hb1 1640 due to the
potential unintended consequences it may
have on fire firefighters and other
First Responders throughout the uh
Community my members routinely are
called upon to make split-second
decisions in dangerous life-threatening
situations without qualified immunity
this can cause hesitation to act in the
best interest of the public due to fear
of legal repercussions firefighters are
often trained to take appropriate action
based on their professional judgment
without qualified immunity these
individuals may have been may be held
liable even though they acted in good
faith and within their training this
bill would also greatly increase the
liability of government employers and
expose them to a significant amount of
legal action and financial burden this
would be a negative impact on the
ability of government employers to
effectively serve their communities and
fulfill their responsibilities in those
in those um related emergency responses
I urge the committee to consider a to
consider other options as any act to
limit or eliminate any sort of qualified
immunity is an immediate red flag with
the fear of when you start chiseling
away at things like qualified immunity
eventually they will be all gone with
that I will wrap it up there uh our
president Brian reel has submitted
written testimony for you all if you
have any questions I'm more than happy
to answer questions for this witness
representative foress thank you thanks
for taking
so you're saying
did you say that if we eliminated
qualified immunity a firefighter or a
police officer instead of doing what
they were trained to do and would do
automatically might stop and say maybe I
shouldn't because I don't have qualified
immunity I don't believe that could ever
happen I don't believe the firefighters
and the police officers I know hesitate
at all and think about the consequences
so you're saying you think they would
think about not having qualified
immunity if the qualified immunity
wasn't there this could cause a
situation where a firefighter or a
paramedic or anybody in that line of
work could pause to hesitate in in an
industry where you don't have time to
think you need to act based on your
training uh that could be that could be
very
important other questions for this
witness representative
question the the the the term that's
used here is qualified immunity so first
I'd like to know what is meant by
qualified immunity so what is the
qualifications for it and then it would
appear to me that this bill is only
addressing or or seeks to address where
there is clearly some violation of those
qualifiers and how to best handle those
violations of those qualifiers so a
firefighter acting as according to the
training doesn't seem like it's a
violation of any of the
qualifiers so how do we how do we
protect
the the firefighter from any kind of
Retribution when performing his or her
duties according to training from the
one who does whatever wantedly or
whatever how do we balance that and if
that's if that's not what this bill is
actually doing then how do we go about
doing that of course representative
thank you for the question I to your
point I would say for the qualified it
would be by these standards in training
of what they are able to do as for a
solution off the top of my head I'm not
prepared at this moment I'd be happy to
uh provide you with some more
information other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you sir thank
next I'm going to call on uh Chief Allen
aldenberg
please
good afternoon chairman Lyn and members
of the committee my name is alen
aldenberg and I'm the chief of police of
the Manchester police department and
currently the president of the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs police
I'm here today today to testify in
opposition to House Bill
1640 the Hampshire Department of Justice
the Hampshire Association of counties
and Hampshire Municipal Association or
all agreement 1640 would result in a
significant increase in litigation for
state and local New Hampshire government
entities I am in complete agreement with
that assessment and as a citizen of the
state I have grave concerns about the
ability of local governments to operate
under such a barrage of civil litigation
I will however leave that critique for
the organizations to articulate that
further
my expertise and why I'm here today is
to share insights on the direct impact
of HP 1640 and what it will have on La
enforcement officers and consequently
the safety of New Hampshire
Citizens First I want to express
appreciation for the Bill's objectives
accountability within government is
crucial and nowhere is it more vital
than in law enforcement and in Public
Safety in recent years New Hampshire law
enforcement has made significant strides
in this area we have widely adopted body
cameras and significantly increased
annual training requirements Statewide a
conduct Review Committee staffed by law
enforcement officers and civilians which
now oversees complaints of Officer
misconduct at the state level and
Statewide standardization of internal
investigation procedures is underway
these represent major structural changes
that New Hampshire law enforcement has
willingly and enthusiastically
undertaken I point out these efforts to
illustrate New Hampshire law enforcement
and is no way an obstructionist or
hesitant to implement accountability
measures the New Hampshire law
enforcement Community will always be a
partner in any proposals to increase
accountability while allowing our
officers to do their jobs effectively
unfortunately the unintended
consequences of that will manifest if
house bills 1640 becomes law are
impossible to ignore and I have a
responsibility to articulate those
concerns today as you know 1640 will
essentially nullify almost all
government immunity while transferring
the financial liability from the
employee to the state as you know 1640
will essentially nullify almost all
government immunity in our state with ex
with notable exceptions for legislators
and members of the of the Judiciary
which I find
interesting the government immunity I
refer to is commonly known as qualified
or official immunity simply put it
Shields government employees who make
good faith mistakes while operating
within the scope of their professional
duties from civil litigation it does not
and I emphasize a point that we made
earlier it does not protect government
employees who know ly violate a person
whose constitutional rights as some
proponents of eliminating qualified
immunity seem to suggest my specific
concerns surround two likely all but
unintended
consequences the first is that 1640 will
effectively fundamentally affect our
officers willingness to engage with the
public in ways that we need them to 1640
transfers litigation liability from
Individual to the state however officers
will likely still be drawn into legal
proceedings potentially as a third party
intervenor
which could become financially demanding
on the
employee the burden of ongoing civil
litigation and risk of incurring legal
expenses May deter our officers from
acting decisively when necessary this is
extremely concerning as New Hampshire's
reputation is one of the nation's first
States safest states is probably due to
our proactive and engaged Law
Enforcement Officers the bill risk
creating a climate of excessive caution
that would impede Swift decision-making
diminishing our ability to combat crime
effectively
the systematic hesitancy will only serve
to embolden criminal activities
undermining the high standards of Public
Safety we strive to maintain in our
state while this analysis is my opinion
it's based on more than two decades of
law enforcement experience there is also
scarly named for this phenomenon called
D policing de policing has been
extensively documented and studied in
recent years it is defined as an I quote
the normative decline in proactive
police practices due to negative
external sources and is believed to
constrain proactive police activities
the phenomenon of deep policing is often
shown to correlate with an increase in
violent crime in areas where it is
studied I point this out to note that my
inclusions are not only based on my own
experience but also on recent studies of
US law enforcement behavior in reaction
to external factors the second
consequence of 1640 will be a
degradation of ARS morale leading to
issues with retention and recruitment
which are already at critical levels
locally and Nationwide
New Hampshire officers being mirrored in
ongoing civil civil litigation they had
previously been insulated from will
exasperate this issue we cannot expect
our police officers and future
applicants to ignore a significant
change in circumstance such as this when
making employment decisions even with
protection from Financial liability in
these cases the ongoing threat of
litigation and the potential for
officers to pay their own representation
at some point will have a negative
effect neither the concerns preious
outline should be interpret interpreted
to suggest that New Hampshire Law
Enforcement Officers should never be
subject to lawsuits or infallible my
argument is that current standard of
qualified immunity that police officers
have in our state is an integral part of
our delicate legislative and judicial
ecosystem that allows officers to do
their job 1640 would abruptly strip
these protections and risk creating
environment where law enforcement in New
Hampshire is apprehensive and unable to
address crime effectively to ensure
public saf safety which our all of our
citizens have become accustomed to the
following quote from the 2007 New
Hampshire Supreme Court decision in ever
vers GE company summarizes the need for
law enforcement officers to be insulated
from constant civil claims the public
simply cannot afford for those
individuals charged with securing and
preserving Community safety to have
their judgment shaded out of fear of
subsequent lawsuits or to have their
energies otherwise deflected by
litigation at a time at times lengthy
encumbersome so I strongly encourage you
to find 1640 inexpedient inexpedient in
legislate and I'm happy to take any
questions that this committee has thank
you Mr chairman questions for this
witness uh representative Alexander then
representative Greece thank you Mr chair
and thank you chief for taking my
question um I know specifically in gtown
we're currently down five five patrolman
positions through retention issues can
you talk to me a little bit about how
Manchester is working on their like do
they have retention issues similar to
gown you I have an authorization that's
a great question representative I have
an authorization of 272 police officers
from top to bottom as of this morning I
have 23 vacancies um what you are
finding with the applicants and good for
them um they they pay paying attention
more to these things perhaps 25 years
ago when I became a police officer um
they're asking these questions and I'll
take it a step further with my current
officers and employees that I have
they're paying attention to this and
they are saying to themselves
what more can we do as law
enforcement we're this is sense that
we're there constantly under attack
we've agreed to reform the governor's
leak commission body cameras all these
things that I mentioned that law
enforcement has
embraced and they're Al starting to say
to themselves is this really worth it is
this risk putting my family at further
risk and harm for me simply going out
and doing my job lawfully and again if I
could represented and you asked the
question earlier about to the sponsor of
this bill what could have been done
differently what could have been done
and perhaps it was I'm not certain but
we have a public Integrity unit in this
state that this body put into place we
have a conduct Review Committee that
this body put into place those are
avenues that a citizen feels if they
were wronged they can pursue those
Avenues to determine if an officer acted
inappropriately or engaged in misconduct
so again law enforcement has embraced
those things so there are things in
place for people to pursue a perceived
wrong yeah um representa gon you had a
question yes thank you and thank you
chief for your for your
testimony you said that immunity is for
good faith mistakes not violations of
civil rights and as I read through here
I'm only finding where this deals with a
violation of someone's constitutional
rights so it's not about the paperwork
mistake it's about a violation of civil
rights and then the plaintiff Bears the
burden of
proving that the government employee
violated a
right so how
does how does this in holding that
person and then and then the the
government agency has the ability to not
defend that employee if they believe
that they did violate the right so so
you can still get out of defending them
how does this strip away a law
enforcement officer's ability to enforce
the law and not be subject to because
look I get it everybody who's arrested
is going to claim you violated my rights
right I I I get it but how is this
actually going to do that when the
plaintiff Bears the burden and you can
still get out of paying for their
defense well you you're talking still
there's going to be some type of civil
lawsuit correct somebody's going to
allege that their constitutional rights
are
violated the somebody can claim that but
you they can do that now they can do
that now and and the judge can grant a
motion to dismiss they can sanction the
attorney who files a a a a frivolous
case or you know a case to harass a
defendant so there's all kinds of
Protections in here already and it's
only addressing civil rights or
constitutional rights not paperwork
administrative errors so I'm not really
exactly sure how how this affects the
law enforcement officer from performing
their their duties in the same way that
they've always done it in good
faith even what we're training to do now
sir right I I think our officers deserve
this level of protection that they
currently have because I'm concerned how
is that I'm asking you how is this
stripping that away I'm not seeing where
that strips that away in my my
interpretation it strips it away in the
sense of that we're going to open our
ourselves to additional civil litigation
that's my opinion of it and that's and I
and I take it to the street cop all
right that is responding to your home
for something in in progress serious in
nature and in the back of their minds I
can tell you because I I talk to these
men and women every day um and so not
the people behind me that hey chief if
you know what if what if I did what I'm
trained to do and although it was
appropriate I run the risk of still
being dragged through some type of civil
litigation even though so if that was
your son or daughter right can you see
how that fear can be real for a police
officer that hey I did my job I did what
I was trained to do but I'm I'm still
being open to civil litigation above and
beyond everything else that law
enforcement has agreed to put into place
to be more transparent to do more
training to be better in the community
we're doing we're doing a lot of things
on a daily basis to make law enforcement
better I just think this is going to
take us a step backwards that's my
opinion other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
Chief thank you chairman thank you
members of the committee now I'm going
please all right good afternoon Mr
chairman and uh members of the committee
my name is Frank Campo I'm a sergeant
with the state police and I also serve
as a president of the Troopers
Association um and on behalf of my
members I'm here to convey our
opposition to HB uh
1640 police and other per public
servants need qualified immunity to
carry out their jobs uh police officers
perform vital tasks that often require
decision-making under stressful
circumstances taking qualified immunity
away could lead to police officers being
hesitant to act when action is needed
most removing qualified immunity could
also open police lease up to unwarranted
lawsuits in which jur juries or judges
could second guess these uh decisions
that lead to that could potentially lead
to significant cost for cities uh the
police officers themselves as well as
the
state like everybody else police
officers uh make mistakes uh they must
be allowed some room to make those
mistakes without worrying about being
sued uh I believe the argument for this
bill is to hold public servants
accountable uh for their actions and I
understand the need for this uh the
Troopers Association is always happy to
see work done to improve law enforcement
uh the Lea commission was established
and made specific recommendations to
improve law enforcement in our state uh
the Troopers Association was happy the
commission EST uh was established and
agreed with the recommendations that
they made um but not included in the Lea
commission's findings was the need to
end qualified immunity so as I finish my
testimony here I would just like to
thank the committee for allowing me time
to speak and I'd be happy to answer
questions if there all right questions
for this witness representative gon and
thank you for taking my question you
said one of your concerns is that the uh
the employee such as the law enforcement
officer would uh then feel the pressure
of the the obligation for under civil
action right they they individually but
this bill says that the government shall
be liable and we heard the concern was
that this this cost gets shifted to the
government so which is it are we
protecting the employee or we going to
protect the government
I'm sorry um well as far as the um the
advice I received from our legal council
is um the individual employee would
still be uh subject to these um
potential
lawsuits other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you next U Michael uh G please G
sorry sir good
afternoon
thank you Mr chairman and committee
members my name is Michael gear I'm a
Salem police officer and president of
the New Hampshire Police Association I'm
here today to convey the New Hampshire
Police Association strong opposition to
House Bill
1640 I know this issue isn't new to you
last year this committee overwhelmingly
voted to recommend an expedient to
legislate by a vote of 16-3 on a similar
Bill HB
647 nothing has changed over the past
year except it has become even more
difficult to recruit and retain law
enforcement officers in this state and
this type of legislation won't help this
is exactly the kind of legislation that
will Ex exasperate uh serious
Recruitment and Retention problems that
every local government in the state is
facing
today I believe you you all are aware of
the employment challenges we are facing
fewer and fewer people are applying for
and entering the law enforcement in
Korea and a higher percentage of Korea
professionals within law enforcement are
leaving for a whole host of reasons the
feedback from many of these former
career professionals have stated they
are leaving because of the benefits and
the inherent dangers of the job this
bill will inflame the
situation expanding the ability to sue
the state county and local governments
for employee actions while on duty has
state employees and members of the New
Hampshire Police Association extremely
concerned about their ability to do
their jobs in good faith as the citizens
of the state want and expect them to do
I understand people are being told that
under house bill 1640 it is not the
public sector employees assets that are
at risk but instead the financial
liability will rest with the employers
meaning our towns cities counties and
state municipalities will hel will be
held accountable which ultimately falls
on the
taxpayers this bill targets employees
actions which will force the employees
to defend themselves while financially
absorbing the cost out of their own
Pockets this bill will likely promote
the firing of the employee upon the
expanded lawsuit bill when the employee
at the time believed they were acting in
good fith there is no question this bill
will have a direct impact on both local
and state government employees and their
respected government
employers these public sector employees
receive limited immunity from some
lawsuits while carrying out their job
description public employees
particularly our police officers perform
life-saving tasks that require
split-second decisions under very
stressful circumstances which are based
on good faith that is why police
officers received and need limited
protection so they won't hesitate when
acting on behalf of the public and
within their job
description contrary to what some people
may think police officers do not have
absolute
immunity they can be and should be held
liable or accountable when they violate
personal Constitution tional right they
may also be sued when they act outside
the scope of their job description or
they engage in Reckless Behavior the
narrow interpretation of clearly
established precedent that exists today
is
appropriate the sheer nature of law
enforcement work means there will be
arrest which at the time of arrest may
result in possible physical
altercations if more and more arrests or
the use of force to affect an arrest end
up with the threat of Lau the protection
of our citizens will be negatively
impacted because of the possibility of a
negative Financial impact on our police
officers and it's not just the police
it's other the First Responders one
example would be is a local fire
department if they were to use all
available assets into fighting a fire
but the house still Burns to the ground
this bill could expose those
firefighters to lawsuits even after
their heroic
efforts finally my testimony today on
behalf of the New Hampshire Police
Association and its members as well as
other law enfor groups like The New
Hampshire Troopers Association and the
New Hampshire Chiefs of Police
Association have been very committed to
making positive and sensible changes
when needed we were active in the law
enforcement accountability community and
transparency
commission commonly known as Le act and
we have worked with people from all
sides of the issues to come up with
sensible reforms in the areas that we we
can all support we have worked with all
interested parties and have supported
the legislation dealing with misconduct
reform um and also pertaining to
exculpatory evidence schedule I believe
we all can and should be proud of the
role New Hampshire law enforcement
Community has played in addressing these
areas these are the kind of changes that
will work this is what the legislative
body and the governor expected when they
brought all these stakeholders together
to resolve these issues within our state
house bill 1640 is extremely problematic
therefore today I strongly urge you to
vote hb6 40 in expedient to legislate
thank you and thank you on behalf of the
members of the New Hampshire Police
Association questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much sir next
please thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee uh I'm going to be very
brief uh because we have written
testimony to submit I want to begin by
saying I am not a lawyer and I am
certainly not a constitutional law
expert uh but I I do want to Echo the
concerns that have already been raised
today about Recruitment and Retention
this is a very very real problem not
just in law enforcement but virtually
across all areas of government I was in
here just about a week ago on a bill
related to School nurses and in
Manchester alone nine vacancies for
School nurses we struggling to fill
positions everywhere and legislation
like this uh simply does not help it's
only going to make matters worse I'll
just share a few other thoughts we also
represent uh public sector workers and
Public Safety in Massachusetts and as
you and this committee probably know uh
3 or four years back they did the
so-called police reform where qualified
immunity protections were stripped and I
can tell you that it resulted in a mass
Exodus uh many of those officers came
across the border to work here uh many
others retired three four 5 years before
they had planned to retire just because
of their concern and the their concern
is is very very real uh you know whether
or not they're they're sued personally
for this who who's responsible for it
whether it's them or it's the employer
ultimately they are pulled in and this
legislation allows them to uh intervene
or be an intervener and the reason
they're going to want to do that is
because any settlement would uh more
than likely result in their termination
so if they're not involved in it
although they might not lose their home
or be sued for their home they're going
to lose their job in a settlement which
brings me to another Point uh as I said
I'm not an attorney but I know enough
about the profession to know that the
quickest and often cheapest way to get
rid of a lawsuit is to settle it uh so
we believe this is going to result in a
number of lawsuits many of them
frivolous to be quite honest with you
and if the easiest path to do this
rather than litigate is to settle where
does that ultimately fall uh it it it
falls particularly in the rural
communities it's going to really hurt
the budgets and ultimately if you have a
lot of these settlements what's going to
happen is fewer police officers like the
men and women behind me on the streets
fewer teachers in the classroom fuel
work is to clear our roads of snow uh so
again uh I I know I said I was going to
be brief so I'm going to stop here uh
I'll give you my written testimony and I
will certainly do my best to answer any
questions that this committee may have
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir I got off easy thank you sir now uh
please
welcome scy thank you uh chairman Lynn
and uh members of the community uh
committee uh I would like to begin by
saying something nobody has said yet
Happy Valentine's
Day um it's a beautiful day for
Valentine's Day and uh I'll try to keep
my comments relatively short because I
know you've heard a lot of testimony but
I did want to clarify a couple of things
um there was a statement in regards to
account ability for for public employees
there are many levels of accountability
already existing for public employees
the first line of accountability is
their employers themselves every state
agency uh that hires law enforcement
individuals have their own Internal
Affairs bureaus
which which act as the Frontline of
Defense in addition to that you have
police standards and
training which has a misconduct
Committee in which complaints will be
filed and every complaint is reviewed in
terms of other public employees you have
Professional Licensing Board in which
they are held accountable and yes public
employees may be sued civy under the
current law however that individual must
act outside of the scope of their
employment and act in a wanting or
Reckless fashion that is the
standard now accountability takes place
and and already takes place and we see
that
already the other issue that came up is
the Constitutional viability uh or the
standard that set forth this creates a
cause of action for any constitutional
violation I think we can all agree that
we are a government of laws created at
the foundation by our constitution all
of our laws derive from our
constitution so
let me give you an example uh I believe
a question was asked what about just a
paperwork violate well you know the
right to information is is a
constitutional right 91a comes off of a
constitutional right so if for example
say a clerk um gets a 91a request runs
it by legal they say you can do X Y and
Z redacts it but leaves a date of birth
on the um on on something that goes out
a simple mistake
no harm no fail it's corrected and no
one ever sees it that individual can say
you violated my privacy act my privacy
rights which is also a constitutional
rights that individual would be subject
to according to this law per se
termination per se termination no
mitigating factors nothing to be
reviewed per se it would also give
attorney fees to the person bringing
that action and why because some of
these issues already are contained in
the law if someone brings a bad faith or
frivolous action the courts already have
the right to award attorney fees against
that party here you also have the right
to get attorney fees if you do something
in the public interest what this bill
does though and it's the most
far-reaching attorney fees Bill I've
ever seen it automatically Awards
attorney fees for any prevailing
plaintiff prevailing plaintiff under the
current law is that you have to have a
judgment against the other individual on
a majority of your claims so if you
brought 23 claims you're not going to be
the prevailing party for all 23 of those
claims maybe only one of those claims
okay this says any claim so if I bring
23 claims and I run up a a bill of
$300,000 the town or city or state would
be responsible to pay that whole
$300,000 even if it was about a minor
violation and it's not a May every other
prevailing or fees shifting bill that
I've reviewed says the court May award
this bill says you shall
award it gives an incentive uh uh to
bring relatively nonmeritorious claims
forward for the sake of gaining
money in addition ition I would like to
clarify something that um uh was stated
earlier in regards to uh this provides a
disincentive to correct things there
there is a a theory in the law and it's
under the negligence uh when you're
looking at negligence is that if I take
a remedial action it can't be used
against me in a court of law because I'm
correcting a problem and public policy
says you should correct problems rather
than have to litigate it to get it
corrected that's why it's not allowed in
court when you take subsequent remedial
action to correct the problem for
example if I um never Sal my driveway
and somebody falls and gets hurt and
thereafter I salt it every day and no
one falls again they can't use my
subsequent salting of that driveway
against me because I did the right thing
and nobody else got hurt what I might do
is say well if I'm going to get in
trouble I'm not going to give them a
reason to get me in trouble I'm not
going to assult my driveway at all and
that does not help public policy the
same thing would happen in regards to
the government don't correct a problem
until they tell you it's a problem
because if you do you put yourself into
liability and per se liability when you
say the individual um actor would not be
this creates a standard in regards to
per se this is the only statute I've
ever seen that creates a per
se requirement of termination it says it
is a per se reason to terminate that
would overturn overturn years
of collective bargaining within the
state of New Hampshire and take away
take
away property rights that individuals
have because when you have a just cause
provision in your collective bargaining
agreement you have a property right in
your job does that mean the legislature
in doing this should be held liable for
taking away a police officer's uh uh
constitutional rights no that would be a
ridiculous result and by the way the con
this this bill does provide immunity for
legislators and judges and it should and
it should but those protections that you
see as important for you to exercise
your discretionary functions at the
highest level of government should also
be applied to those who are the people
who are implementing the policies and
procedures dictated by others and with
that being said um I will uh yield my
time to whoever uh is is be Beyond me
and uh I'm willing to answer any
questions you may have
thank you uh questions for this
witness none thank you very much Mr
grupy good seeing you again good seeing
you
again uh next I'm going to call on
please
thank you very much Mr chair members of
the committee everybody in the audience
it's good to um see so many people
paying so much attention to an important
bill I'd like to um move through this as
quickly as possible and um first address
a couple of concerns about the language
of the bill that were raised earlier one
that it would give um um permission to
proxy lawsuits on behalf of somebody
else looking at the language I think
that literally requires a
two-word amendment in page three
paragraph Roman numeral 2 instead of
saying violation of a right it should
say violation of their rights and if you
look down the same page page three at
the bottom under 541
B27 instead of saying use of force if
that says actions the protections become
much broader and do not apply just to a
specific scenario those are very minor
adjust last months I already spoke with
a prime sponsor we'll be happy to amend
you know the bill to just eliminate
those two concerns right off the bat
because they are reasonable and they
were definitely not
intentional now in regards to a lot of
the U claims being made do you notice
how many of them are around the
split-second decisions people have to
make that's a reasonable concern from
people who have to make split level
decisions right Split Second decisions
you know you just got to decide right
now first we do have specific language
that you know was just we were just
looking at that explicitly states that
the court will consider those and give
them the benefit of the doubt for those
circumstances if there is any way to
make that even stronger for those
scenarios I'd be happy to but you know I
I don't know how to make it even
stronger than it is but the fact is if
you look at the data the vast majority
of qualified immunity claims are not
against those types of scenarios yes
they are about a quarter or a third of
the cases but the majority of qualified
immunity claims are for actions of
government employees who had plenty of
time to consider their choices and yet
chose to
disregard you know laws and
constitutional rights and right now the
qualified immunity
Doctrine is one of those doctrines
that's written in a very reasonable way
right he just says that hey you know you
shouldn't violate rights if the police
officer can be expected to be aware that
you know those are rights and they were
established you can bring action in
reality courts have led to some
impressive verdicts if I could just
bring up Jessup versus Fresno by the way
I intentionally chose a California case
because I don't want to go after one
individual Department in New Hampshire
or another the issues are very similar I
don't want this to come across as
picking on one city
right in that case uh two police
officers served a legitimate arrest
legitimate search warrant They
confiscated about
$275,000 in cash and coins and they
50,000 District 9 ruled that while
stealing is morally wrong those police
officers really had no clearly
established case laws to inform them
that stealing from a suspect is a
violation of their rights and therefore
no civil action can be brought this is
where qualified
immunity is excessive
where you know we pretend that somehow a
police officer who does not understand
that stealing is
illegal would be aware of the case law
hundreds and thousands of Supreme Court
and local District's decisions that
would then inform them that really
stealing has been established to be
illegal mind you the this Ninth District
did not even rule on whether stealing
was illegal under those circumstances
therefore allowing the same Doctrine to
be used again in similar circumstances
if other police officers commit exactly
the same crime this is a real concern
okay and it needs to be addressed we are
not in any way trying to attack police
officers or make it harder for them to
retain people if anything it's kind of
strange to see everybody in here being
unhappy about the fact that this uh
legislation would shift the burden from
the employer to the
employee I can assure you that if we
didn't do that everybody would tell you
that it's absolutely unacceptable for a
police officer to risk going bankrupt
over one decision that they made and we
agree with that which is why we are
shifting the responsibility to the
employer which has larger pockets and
ultimately the responsibility for
training and hiring and retaining those
people so I would urge the committee
to consider the fact that this is the
right way to do this and you know not be
that very concerned about that shifting
of the
liability one other comment that I heard
uh from a previous uh person testifying
was that we have to retain contractors
and they are not trained and we don't
want to indemnify them well if you hire
them to do work on your behalf you are
responsible for their actions if you
don't like it don't hire contractors and
do the work yourself I don't think you
should be able to shield from actions
from the consequences of actions
committed by people you authorize to do
work on your behalf when they break the
law it's your responsibility to hire
people who are qualified and won't break
the
law
the real real issue
here is that sometimes things happen
that are absolutely wrong and yet courts
use qualified immunity to not rule
against the plain tis but not even give
them the chance to make their case in
courts because mind you having the
ability to make your case in courts by
no way means you'll Prevail against the
government
agency okay odds are uh not very
favorable for people who make those kind
of
claims one last thing and really there
is much more I could say but this has
gone for a long time and I want to
respect everybody's time is
that I've always believed in talking to
everybody involved and working with them
and trying to address concerns I hope
that this bill will be passed if it
doesn't get passed I'm looking forward
to working with everybody who Express
concerns to see whether we can find some
way to address those very real problems
because these issues are real they
affect people and we do need to address
them and if this is not the right
vehicle fine we'll just have to figure
out what the right vehicle is but until
those issues are addressed we're going
to meet every year in the committee room
and try to find another way to do it so
one way or the other we have to find a
way to address this and I would urge the
commit to if there are aspects of this
that are not acceptable to maybe make a
suggestion on how to fix them that I'm
sure we'll be happy to work with thank
you and I'll be happy to take any
questions questions for this
witness oh yes represent
stap thank you and thank you for taking
my question I think I missed I missed
you said that there's a possible area
for amendment in this bill if I've got
that right what area was that I I
already suggested at the very beginning
two minor amendments to address two of
the concerns U here one to make sure
there is no proxy right to file lawsuits
on behalf of somebody else which is
definitely not the intent another one to
extend the protections at the bottom of
page three to all government employee
actions not just use of force what I was
saying at the end was that if the
committee feels that certain
improvements to the bill would make it
useful more useful I'm sure that both me
and the primary sponsor will be willing
to work and address you know as much of
those concerns and hopefully you know
have a bill that the committee is
comfortable recommended for recommending
for
OTP thank you other questions for this
witness I guess I do have one question
representative papich M uh you made you
made reference to the ninth circuit case
about the you know the the police
officers didn't know that uh when you
when you sees $200,000 it's not proper
to report you only so sees 50 and keep
the rest yes um yeah obviously that you
know when I hear those kind of decisions
that concerns me as much as I'm I'm sure
it does you but have can you give us an
exam an example of those kinds of
decisions being made by courts in New
Hampshire I mean is this I U is this a
problem in New Hampshire it is a problem
in New Hampshire if not of the magnitude
of what the ninth circuit will
do I at this point in time intentionally
chose not to have any examples from New
Hampshire because I'm concerned that if
I start bringing up specific cases it
will come across as chasing individual
towns and stuff I'd be happy to um you
know for now rest my arguments on the
general concerns rather than look at the
individual New Hampshire decisions if
there is a change with we need to make
to this approach in the fut future I'll
be happy to but I don't want to speak
off the cuff and uh change horses right
you know at the last moment okay all
right other questions for this
witness thank you very much thank
who thank you Mr chair just to make sure
that it's clear it's in the bill in
multiple places right the government
actor in this case is not personally
financially sorry personally financially
liable it is the unit that they work for
we put that in multiple times to make it
clear I hear people saying well
someone's going to be fired someone's
going to lose their job someone's going
to have to pay it's the it's the
government unit themselves just to make
sure anybody who hasn't read the bill
completely that's what we're holding
liable thank you all
right okay thank you very much yeah well
I'm sorry was there somebody somebody oh
somebody else that wants to speak sure
up yeah you know we gonna need I'm just
going to ask you you don't have to do it
now but before you leave will you fill
out one of these pink slips thank
you my name is I'm a chief provision par
officers and Association and I'm the
president for his uh prohan PR officers
Union okay um
I just wanted to either it's educational
I just wanted to learn you know as you
heard from the previous speaker
that the example that we were given here
was a case from State of
California and it's really Troublesome
do we have a problem currently in the
state of New Hampshire that really
directly have any kind of concern about
qualifying immunity all right uh most of
the time we try to adapt these policies
that apply in other states cases that
generate from and I understand
about creating a preventive measure so
we can protect our state and quite
frankly speaking I've been in law
enforcement for 22 years State of New
Hampshire has probably one of the best
mechanism through the New Hampshire
police standard training Council and the
based licensing agencies and departments
through the state to make sure
that public employees are not immune
from the Mal ass intent now if any
officer or Public Employee has done
something outrageous that violated the
policy of the department I think every
Department every state agency has their
own unit to investigate and determine
whether or not if that person would even
get a protection from the state uh I
would love to see if there is any data
which shows we actually have a problem I
believe I firmly believe that state of
New Hamshire we do not have that problem
it's a non-existent issue uh I think uh
sometimes uh we create laws that don't
apply for us and then we now are putting
our public servants in a position where
they may be hesitant about acting uh and
doing their their job I think the public
employees uh in this state do a great
job uh I have B I've been involved with
training I'm also an agent professor at
the universities I have researched and
read many many reports about specific
topic to qualifying immunity and I would
dare to say that this state have no zero
non-existent issue and if there are they
are addressed through the police
standard training Council or through the
state uh uh agencies that are tasked in
investigating and addressing uh any uh
misconduct uh in any kind of uh
employment so uh it's an nonexistent
issue that's like I would like to add
all right thank you questions for this
this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir please don't forget to fill out the
blue pink CL okay thanks uh all right I
don't have any other pink cards is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
House Bill
1640 right seeing none I'm going to
close the hearing on House Bill
1640 um do we have a we have no any
numbers
on
online there was three in support of
House Bill 1640 and a
opposed rep Horgan do you mind grabbing
in
opposition all right zero in favor 10
you
16 164 all right so I'm going to open
the hearing
now on uh House
Bill
1614 and rep recognize uh representative
sponsor thank you cherlin um members of
the committee it's a pleasure to be here
for the record my name is representative
Rebecca McWilliams I represent South
conquered and you're actually sitting in
one of my districts right now it's a
pleasure to host
you
1614 good government allows everyone to
have their day in
court and they can present their whole
case not starting with a giant thumb on
the scale assuming that a state agency
is always right unless they've made some
egregious error of fact or law most of
the problems that bad decisions cause
aren't necessarily errors but mistakes
of
judgment we should have a system that
allows appeal of bad judgment this bill
establishes a new framework for review
of decisions and rules of the Department
of Environmental Services to give less
deference to agency decisions and prior
quasi Court review through agency
councils this bill will address fairness
and the judicial standard for review of
appeals of Dees
decisions in our representative
democracy there is and there very much
should be a basic bargain between the
citizens and the administrative State
administrative agencies such as Dees
have substantial power given to them by
the legislature to write regulations and
issue permits on the other hand affected
voters and taxpayers are supposed to be
able to provide factual information
scientific economic Etc along with their
views about the policy wisdom or ethical
basis for regulation or for a project SE
seeking a permit if everything works
perfectly the agency makes a decision
and anyone who believes strongly that
the decision is too strict or too
lenient has an opportunity to appeal
that decision in front of a judge or
judges on the basis that the process or
the outcome was wrong this is basic
checks and balances and we trust the
public servants and defer to their
wisdom but we need courts to set things
right if mistakes are made or bad
judgment prevails
in 36 US states and the federal system
for nearly 80 years since the
administrative procedures act became law
in
1946 that is exactly how it works there
is fairness and checks and
balances 36 states have a provision that
the agency decision shall be reversed if
it is found to be arbitrary or
capricious New Hampshire does not we are
one of the 14 states where it is very
difficult for a citizen or a company to
get a full judicial hearing about the
merits of a regulatory or permitting
decision in our state we have boards and
councils for permits and a superior
court for rules to hear initial
challenges but they are only told to
consider whether the agent agency acted
clearly unlawfully or unreasonably that
is our standard of review and our rules
require the Challenger to prove so via a
preponderance of the evidence standard
at the next and final level the thumb on
the scale gets even heavier as the
higher court is instructed by Statute to
assume that the prior decision was
correct unless the Challenger can prove
by a clear preponderance of the evidence
that the agency was not correct this is
not merely a general tilting of the
scales towards the agency but it makes
the whole system into a verdict on
whether what the agency actually did was
legal and checked all the boxes rather
than what the citizens and companies
appealing that decision to serve a
discussion on whether what the agency
did was right sensible grounded in
evidence and fairly balanced competing
rights and Liberties these discussions
cannot happen in a state without a
modern system for judicial Ru review of
agency action so this bill changes to
rsas one for the appeals of Permitting
decisions and one for um AR arguing
whether an agency decision has been
arbitrary or capricious so there are two
key words that Chang at the federal
system in 1946 and this bill proposes
doing the same for our state uh to join
the well to be one less so we'd be 13
not including us um one less of the
states that haven't quite caught on to
the new legal standard so this bill in
no way prejudices whether or not or how
often an appeal on either side would be
successful it doesn't encourage more
litigation it only says that as long as
the parties both sides of the conflict
are in court anyway they deserve to be
heard on the merits and not just have
the agency always assumed be right from
the beginning
a word on the concern that changing the
standard of judicial review may increase
litigation um I would say I am an
attorney um and parties choose to appeal
for many reasons some strategic some
emotional but appeals on agency and
Lower Court decisions will always occur
this bill just changes the way that the
court considers the arguments from both
sides and I would say that Dees should
welcome being added to the 36 we could
be number 37 US states that have some
form of arbitrary and capricious review
of their decisions uh because it's nice
to have a court system that is told to
defer to your decision almost all the
time but wouldn't it be better to have
your decision upheld in court when you
were told that you actually got it right
so consider this bill a pilot to begin
applying the standards of the
administrative procedures act and apply
a broader arbit arbitrary and capricious
standard of review to one New Hampshire
agency Dees not because we have any
special or exclusive concern about Dees
uh but because piloting this change at
one agency will allow the state to gauge
whether it should be expanded to other a
agencies in addition Dees decisions tend
to involve controversial interpretations
of Science and economics the current
system in New Hampshire only allows
courts to correct errors when most of
the concerns about DS decisions involve
judgments based on facts and data that
may not be erroneous but may be poorly
reasoned so let's set the stage with a
real life example New Hampshire has a
waste management Council as a quasi
court for the first appeal of de's
decisions these volunteer positions are
appointed by the governor and the
executive counsel and there are often
vacancies currently out of 13 appointees
five slots including the chair are
vacant also note that among the
vacancies are slots for a public health
expert a municipal official an elected
official so the filled slots tend to
skew to Industry heavy opinions this
means that the New Hampshire Supreme
Court is instructed to treat the
decisions of this eight out of 13 member
group as correct on face value as their
standard of review agency Council
decisions should certainly be respected
but not assumed to be correct and nearly
impossible to scrutinize the second step
in an agency appeal is the New Hampshire
Supreme Court in a recent New Hampshire
Supreme Court decision appeal of Dees
and North Country Environmental Services
Inc which is argued on October 2nd 2023
the issue on appeal was that the waste
management Council the first Arbiter
ruled that it didn't matter that there
was was a broad scientific consensus
that testing for past chemicals should
be part of any landfill permit but there
was as yet no legal requirement for this
under current law any further
challenging Court would have to begin
from the premise that the council's
decision was correct if this bill is
enacted the reviewing Court would at
least be able to hear arguments about
the science and the wisdom of not
testing for pasas a fairly new
Environmental cabinet which we are
learning about and responding to in our
state but new information continues to
come to
light adopting and updated
administrative procedures act standard
of review allows an appeal on the merits
where one side of the controversy or the
other has felt unheard and should be
able to argue their case based upon
science economics policy or logic of a
ruler permit arbitrary in capre review
has worked well for the FED in these 36
dates for decades because it does not
entail judges substituting their
judgment for that of AG agency experts
it simply lets them hear arguments from
the most affected citizens and that
agency may have been irrational
inconsistent myopic or dismissive of
their respective comments more and more
as years go by Dees and other agencies
make decisions at the frontiers of
knowledge and policy to say that no
council or Court can hear complaints
about how the agency received and
interpreted factual information is just
not a sufficient standard of review
anymore so in summary House Bill 1614
responds to two very different but
compliment strains in American and New
Hampshire politics in one sense it
tracks through a much less radical way
the recent Movement by the United States
Supreme Court to reduce the automatic
deference that courts have been given on
elected agency officials the bill stands
for the principle that the courts have a
greater role to play an overseeing
agency activity but this bill also
tracks the Nationwide appreciation that
in the information age stakeholders have
important knowledge and perspectives to
impart in rulemaking and adjudication
and deserve a meaningful Forum to
challenge decision that arguably were
biased narrow or simply unwise when an
agency regulates strictly or weakly or
when it grants a permit or denies one
its decision should be made final and be
respected not because we said so and
that is why but because affected parties
have had a fair chance to challenge or
improve that decision most of the rest
of the nation found this balance between
too much and too little discretion
decades ago it's time for in Hampshire
to join to allow courts to look for
arbitrary and capricious agency action
we should modernize the process of
review and pass this bill and I'm happy
to take questions questions for this
witness representative Alexander thank
you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question so
I actually have two first one is I'd be
um anxious to hear your opinion on the
next public hearing that we're going to
have it um so if you'd stick around for
that that would be great and then number
two is um have you found the 36 other
states that have enacted something like
this have either lost Federal funding if
a Court's overruled um a department
decision or have you found that the the
federal agencies that award money or in
any way have continue to give them money
even if the decision's been overruled by
a Judicial Authority thank you very much
for the question um I'd be happy to to
stick around afterwards that's not a
problem uh to the second question I
don't have any information about federal
funds being rescinded that's not to say
that they haven't been I just don't have
information on that um but to just to
you know put a note on it the federal
standard review is the same as those 36
States so it is the arbitrary and
capricious standard review we're one of
the states who hasn't adopted that but
in terms of funding I just don't have
the information if something's been
pulled I don't know it okay so if I
could so are you saying this the New
Hampshire standard is higher and that if
we lower it to this standard it'll still
be in line with the federal standard uh
I think our standard is actually a
little bit more differential it's not a
higher or lower it is a
we defer to the agency's decision we
refer to the waste management council's
decision and so therefore we don't
discuss any of the things that could
have gone wrong in those two reviews
when we get to the New Hampshire Supreme
Court it's just the way that we've done
that historically and and just to say
that um with the administrative
procedures act there has been an
evolution in some of the states that
have been updating their laws to try to
stay closer to fairness and I would say
that we're kind of hanging back with the
other 13 states that haven't really
changed to try to find Transparency and
fairness on both sides you're welcome
represent
Andrew thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question is there data
available as to how many decisions Dees
makes a year and how many of those
decisions The public's not happy with
you know I think it's possible to get
there um I can ask around I think we
don't have that many uh Supreme Court
decisions if you're looking for that so
it would be a fairly easy review to get
you know the last five years of Dees
decisions that made it to the Supreme
Court and you know how it went uh but
big picture once again I want to say
that the intention is to start with Dees
because they tend to have more
scientific and technologically related
appeals um but I do think the intent
would be to Pilot this and slowly move
our way if this is successful to
updating the administrative procedures
act for all agencies in New
Hampshire other questions for this
witness so I guess I do have a couple I
guess I have two in particular um I'm
not quite sure I mean I there's no
question that the the words used are
different but I'm not quite sure that I
understand what is the difference
between the current current standard
which as I understand it is that uh uh
the agency action can be set aside under
current law if it's clearly unreasonable
clearly unlawful or
unreasonable what's the difference
between that and arbitrary and
capricious why you you seem to say that
one is different than the other but I'm
not sure I that I see how they are
different from each other uh so clearly
unlawful and unreasonable the current
standard um requires some kind of proof
by the petitioner which would be in this
case the the party bringing the appeal
right so they would have to prove that
there it was clearly so there would need
to be significant preponderance of the
evidence to get to clearly as opposed to
arbitrary and capricious where if you're
trying to prove arbitrary you have a
lesser standard of evidence to get to
arbitrary and
certainly so something is something can
be arbitrary without being clearly wrong
I I would say that yeah you can be
arbitrary you can look like you're
swinging left swinging right things are
coming out of the woodwork it's a
strange decision it could be arbitrary
without being clearly inaccurate or
wrong okay all right second question I
have is uh on page two that's in the
subsection
2E you say the order uh you you it says
the order is not supported by evidence
that is substantial when viewed in the
light of the whole record before the
court which includes the agency record
for judicial review supplemented by any
additional evidence received by the
court under this chapter so I guess my
question is is does this mean that the
Supreme Court will now begin accepting
evidence on
appeals new
evidence let me just go back to that one
more
time
I think the intent here is not to
relitigate the case I think the intent
here is to look at all of the pieces
that were presented and see whether
there was a mistake or it was
interpreted improperly right but what
about the supplemented by any additional
evidence that clearly suggests that the
Supreme Court can consider new evidence
and that's I guess that's what I'm
troubled by that would be unprecedented
I think so in the case that we're using
as an example here the P situation
supplemented by additional evidence
would include more information that's
come out about pasas in the time since
the case initially started um so it's
been several years we know more about P
today than we did two years ago right so
if we have additional information
based on the the data that we're
learning about pasas its impacts on
human health and how it spreads through
um underground water systems Etc then
that evidence should be allowed to be
shown to the superior court or Supreme
Court sorry that evidence should be
allowed to be shown because it's new in
that the Innovation and the information
has changed right there's new evidence
about the insidiousness of pasas so that
shouldn't be uh preempted from
presentation okay and does the other
side then if there if there if if
there's some contrary information to
that or does the other side get to
present that too and right it's
supplement and does the Supreme Court
then decide which is right they get to
decide factually which one is right so
that that is the underlying issue of
some of these Dees decisions and agency
decisions across the board is it may be
based on a rule that is out of date and
Time Marches On and we learn more
information about P right and the way
that Pas spreads through underground
water and so that information absolutely
should be applied but there's no
opportunity between the beginning of the
appeal where you in front of the waste
management Council and then when you
finally get to the the Supreme Court
there's really no opportunity to bring
that additional information forward so
because it's Cutting Edge you would have
to start all over again but you would be
precluded from appealing any further
because you've exhausted all your
appeals do you understand you're sort of
in this Catch 22 where you want to talk
more about what we've learned about P
but you can't well you could I mean I
suppose you could file a motion with the
Supreme Court asking that the case be
remanded to the to the uh the wetlands
Council or the uh or even to the dees
for a new information that might or
might not be granted but you would have
that opportunity wouldn't you to seek
that
relief technically yes but considering
that Dees is kind of judg jury and
executioner I don't think you'd have a
friendly audience to go back to with
with that additional information so the
idea is to have the court as that sort
of neutral third party to review as an
additional outside party rather than
trying to go back to Dees where you have
already lost do you understand all right
other questions for this witness
representative CH yeah thanks Mr chair
and thanks for taking the question
um I don't know there may be someone
from Department of Justice that's going
to testify I I'm looking and I usually
don't go down into the the financial
fiscal note too much there's a statement
in the fiscal note though that says uh
that the bill is inconsistent with other
provisions of Law and I won't read the
whole section but essentially that the
council's work is not um uh appealed to
the Supreme Court sections one and two
of the bill presume the decisions of the
department are heard at the Supreme
Court and then sort of above it states
that they're that they're not I'm
looking at they they don't have line
numbers but it's it's right at the split
of the page in the in the fiscal note
and I wasn't sure if you could that
resonated with you or you had a a sense
of what that that issue that's being
raised there
is sorry sure thank you for the question
um so the Department of Justice
represents Department of Environmental
Services on most appeals to the councils
would represent DS in a declar judgement
declaratory judgment action in Superior
Court Court department refers to the
Department of Justice for information
regarding fisical impact and then it
goes on to say it's not possible to
estimate whether there would be more
appeals or more litigation um so I guess
the the challenge here is really what
does this change in terms of cost for
Department of Justice and and it's I I
would I would say there's very little
change because people appeal for lots of
reasons and they're going to appeal
whether or not there's a different
standard there's just going to appeal
because they've decided that's either
emotional or logical for the next step
with their
claim other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much man
you're very welcome next I'm going to
please
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee my name is Adam kpo I'm the
assistant commissioner at the Department
of Environmental Services I'll give a
brief overview of the letter of
testimony we submitted um but before uh
before I get to the reasons why we're
opposed to this bill let me explain how
the appeals uh of departmental decisions
happen now currently decisions that are
appealed at dees are heard by one of our
four environmental councils the waste
management Council air Resources Council
Wetlands Council or water
Council um these councils are separate
and distinct from the department and
their own and have their own legal
council at doj the councils are supposed
to ensure all decisions are lawful under
our statutes and rules when a decision
by the council is appealed it is heard
by the Supreme Court for the
consideration that's the opportunity
that folks have to appeal now
now let me get to some of the issu uh
some of the issues we have with the bill
sections one and two of the bill create
unique standards of review for
departmental decisions and also creates
an entirely new cause of actions uh
cause of action for parties who believe
their rights have been violated it also
assumes that the department uh decisions
are appealed directly to the Supreme
Court um I didn't see anything in there
about the councils and as I just
explained to you um there's a process
currently in place and so it's unclear
to us whether or not that would overlay
on that process or if it would be a
separate appeals route um so I know
someone from doj is here as well to talk
about to potentially talk about that if
you have questions
there um this bill also creates new
criteria for review of Dees decisions
that depart uh significantly from the
standards of of review applicable to
decisions of all other state agencies so
uh RSA 541 dictates how appeals are
occur and this would as um the sponsor
had mentioned it I think she she had
called it a um you know a a pilot this
would you know skirt separate us from
the rest of the state agencies and how
how appeals are are
considered um under section two the
courts must Grant relief if any one of
no fewer than nine criteria are met we
are not aware of any real justification
at least to to date for this sweeping
change to be applied only to the
department or the environmental councils
however it's intended to
apply um in sections three and four of
the bill um it proposes to amend RSA
541a to provide uh Boutique standard for
the Superior Court to use when making
declaratory judgments on the validity or
applic applicability of departmental
rules um unlike the standard for all
other state departments the proposed
change in instructs the court to find a
rule invalid if it finds that that it
meets any one of the four criteria set
out in the
bill lastly uh the department opposes
this bill because it proposes CH uh the
proposed changes would create
significant confusion over the
applicable appeal procedures and would
provide both regulated parties and any
other potentially agreed parties with
new and expanded opportunities to
litigate Department decision and Rule
decisions in Ru making we believe that
the Bill's passage could lead to
significant increases in the frequency
of appeals and challenges to department
rules that will needlessly impact the uh
Department's resources and its
Effectiveness in carrying out its
Mission so thank you and I'm happy to
take any
questions questions yes represent excuse
me representative Manos thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
how does um Dees currently take into
account new scientific information new
factual information new developments in
the science sure sure So currently you
know that to my understanding and excuse
I'm Excuse Me I'm Only I've only been at
the department for a month so I may have
to I may have to write that question
down but my my understanding right now
is we would take that into account you
know in our if we do new Ru making or if
the legislature passes a new statute um
I know um for our past standards those
are set out those are drinking water
standards those are set out actually in
state statute
um so typically that's how that would be
done um separate from sort of appeals on
on these
decisions you have
followup So within the course of an
appeal from one of the counil from the
agency to one of the councils and then
potentially to the New Hampshire Supreme
Court Dees doesn't have a procedure or
an opportunity to weigh in on new
scientific information or new fact ual
information is that
correct Alan do you want to step in on
that one sure come on come on just just
identify yourself with a record if you
would
please thank you my name is Alan Brooks
I'm Chief in the Environmental
Protection Bureau Department of Justice
I do have a card in as well we do not
take a position on the bill I just be
testifying for information but I'm happy
yes New Hampshire Department and
technically I'm called an Assistant
Attorney
General so I believe the question was
information it depends on the program
some programs I think operate with
greater certainty Wetlands Etc a lot of
that is Doc permitting structure
permitting so the regulated Community
usually wants finality and the agency
does and there's not a lot of new
information necessarily that comes up
later other programs actually build into
their permits sometimes the ability to
look at new information and the
requirement to um you know examine that
so um waste is one of those uh they they
have the ability at least to put
conditions and permits for landfills to
continue monitoring and look at
different um you know aspects of it
that's actually something that's built
in various ways to enforcement programs
as well for hazardous waste sites uh EPA
has something similar that they do for
superf fund sites
but if the agency feels that it's
necessary they should have the ability
to condition an approval to allow for
new information to come in and and to
manage that
situation yeah
followup thank you but
but within an appeal the state of the
scientific
information at the time of a decision
the time a decision is made the in the
scientific information is a b and c and
then as you go through the Appellate
process to one of the councils for
example and then to the New Hampshire
Supreme Court the scientific information
can have changed so how within the
course of an appeal how is the change in
the science or factual information taken
into
account so I think if you as you've
noted the first step of an appeal is to
go to the council it used to be at least
for some of the councils that Appeals
were record-based appeals so basically
the clock stopped when the record was
completed Dees and so you didn't need to
have witnesses and do something else you
looked at the record that was changed
there's actually a Supreme Court case on
this that said it's now an evidentiary
hearing so now the councils will
actually allow new evidence to come in
through Witnesses experts Etc during the
appeal part of that process at the
council level the Supreme Court does not
they do not invite new facts they do not
review new facts they look at the record
representative
CH testify separately or or not um I
wanted to Bubble Up the question that I
I asked the sponsor a minute ago I
that's the section where I think in the
fiscal note it's talking about uh input
from the Department of
Justice in that part where it says
there's uh the bill is inconsistent with
other provisions of law is that
suggesting that there's sort of I guess
I'll call it a flaw or a need for an
amendment in this bill that would
reconcile sort of the way it discusses
the the process of of which whether it's
the council's or the the department
itself that would appeal to the Supreme
Court if I'm understanding what's stated
there yes thank you for that question
and uh I did actually probably write
that fiscal note so uh I was going to
testify about that today again not for
or against but simply to say is there a
disconnect between what's someone's
trying to achieve and what they actually
need to do um that would take me just a
couple minutes if the chair is okay I
can go through those comments sure yeah
please go ahead um so I think part of
the issue is just understanding exactly
how these um appeals work and I guess I
have the pleasure of doing them uh all
the time but 210 sets up a standard
whereby Dees decisions are appealed to
one of four environmental
councils our say 541 which is what is
being amended here um does not come into
play between the agency and the appeal
to the councils in fact 541 colon 2 says
that the entire Act only comes into play
if it's provided for by law in other
words the law for whatever you're doing
has to say this is going to happen in
accordance with RSA
541 Dees does not have that statute it
says 210 says that will be appealed to
the councils the councils have a statute
that at the end of it says appeals from
the councils will occur pursuant to 541
so they go to the Supreme Court they
follow that
process the changes in the bill seem to
assume that um by changing 541 you're
going to change the way that Dees
decisions are reviewed but you won't
because you're not changing 210 you
really what if you want to achieve that
you go back to 210 and you'd have to
change that whole structure um and do
something else there so for instance um
you know 541 colon 13 here and the new
541 colon
13A um you know 13A says Department of
Environmental Services orders of
decisions so presumably that means this
is how it's going to work for that and
then it says upon a hearing where a
party is seeking to set aside any order
or decision issued under RSA 210 those
decisions are not Dees decisions those
decisions are decisions of the council
and so you'd have to go back to 210
um and change that as well um so I I
think that might answer some of the
question that you had let me follow up
on that to see if you have more and then
I'll continue I guess um thank you that
that helps a lot um so is it your
thought that this could be amended to
clean up that conflict or that this
really would have to be a completely
separate piece acting on 210
it would be a fairly significant rewrite
of the bill and it would focus on 210
and again I'm not here for or against
it's up to the folks policy decide what
they want to do but it would be a a
fairly significant change to 210 and you
wouldn't see these things appear for the
most part in 541 at all okay can I ask
one more one more follow course yes
um it because this is content is just in
the fiscal mode um um uh when I asked
the sponsor she sort of pointed to the
fact that the fiscal note says because
of this conflict it would be difficult
to determine how much additional
litigation would be caused is the issue
more structural than just sort of the
the increase in litigation like would it
would it cause true sort of uh
dissonance I guess I call it within
within the law that really shouldn't be
present or is it or is it just to a
matter of the courts would have to sort
it out the actual comment that was
written was based on saying we'd have a
confused structure here because you
would not be matching up the two
sections and so neither Dees nor the
councils nor the courts would really
know how to reconcile that and that
would be uh some cost there now if you
redid it and restructured that in some
other way there may be a cost associated
with that I have to in order to give you
a fiscal opinion on that I have a
process I'd have to go through to
say other questions for this witness uh
I'm sorry I did have some other
information I just wanted to make sure I
was finishing his question is that okay
oh of course yeah go ahead um so uh you
already mentioned uh chairman about the
Supreme Court now taking in information
so I won't do that uh again the standard
has already been mentioned as well uh
about arbitrary and capricious we've
interpreted this language basically to
be very similar to the arbitrary and
capricious standard anyway even though
we don't use that language in fact the
old rule set for the Wetland rules used
to say arbitrary and capricious because
that's how they interpreted this
language I don't think that is would
really be a change if anything it may be
more slightly more differential to the
agency but uh in 13A it doesn't just do
that in paragraph two it sets up uh a
through I of reasons why things can be
overturned some of those are new some of
them are done by courts anyway U but it
says one reason that a DS decision can
be overturned is that it's not supported
by substantial evidence that's a very
new standard and a very low standard for
anyone that wants to challenge something
um again this is in 541 but it's saying
talking about taking additional evidence
it's talking about a motion for
disqualification was made that can be a
subject for overturning it but there's
if you're dealing with the agency
there's no motions for disqualification
that doesn't happen there so I'm not
sure what was
envisioned um there's also a provision
that's actually more lenient to the
agency in h that says um if the order is
inconsistent with the rules of the
agency unless the agency explains why
that inconsistency is reasonable right
now an agency can't operate in conflict
with its rules and this is saying well
they can if they demonstrate why so I
think that may want to be looked at as
well um and then paragraph three I don't
think the Cher mentioned this but
paragraph three for the Supreme Court
seems to set up a whole new uh Paradigm
where if a person's rights were violated
by the agency's failure to perform an
action there's a whole new complaint as
if we're in a civil action Supreme
Court's not set up for that and that the
court may hear evidence on material
issues raised in the petition and
answerers so they don't do that
either um and I just wanted to give one
of the U members asked about statistics
and data on these things if you want to
look at how many people are upset enough
about a Dees decision to go as far as an
appeal if you Google nhdes look for uh
rules and Regulatory pull that screen
down it's there's a page for appeals and
you can see the four councils all the
dockets and you can see kind of what
they do I'd say um probably two or three
a year for the air Council maybe five
for the waste Council um Wetlands is a
busy Bureau so they get more they might
get 10 or 15 a year um but I also just
want people to understand that if you if
you change the standard of review and
you make it easier to overturn a Dees
decision that it Cuts both ways so
you're making it easier for a person who
was denied a permit to overcome that
decision but you're also if you've
actually gotten that permit you're
making it easy for easier for uh in a
butter or someone else to overturn that
permit and so if you look through the
dockets for the air Council the last 10
cases um only two appeals were by
permites eight were by neighbors for the
waste Council it's split the last 10
it's basically five and five five times
a permit or an applicant didn't get what
they wanted and they appealed that five
times an applicant did get what they
wanted and then the neighbor appealed
that so there's there's not a you're not
creating a trend where one you know um
section of the public is being more
satisfied or not you're just basically
creating maybe more uncertainty um with
respect to an agency decision which if
that's your policy that's okay but just
no it doesn't favor the people who are
more protective of the environment less
protective or the people who want a
permit or don't want a permit it's just
basically it's a lower bar for whoever
wants to challenge whatever the decision
was other questions for this witness so
I guess I just have one I I'm as my
questions may have I'm I'm not
particularly persuaded on the merits of
changing the standard I mean I'm not
really sure it's much of a change anyway
but but the one thing that I that does
concern me
is we've we've gotten at least some
information um and I'm not talking about
at this hearing but but some information
suggesting that these various councils
which are as I understand it quite
large um that that is a a source of some
insufficient I mean inefficiency in the
time it takes for the appeals to be
resolved and it get then by the time it
gets to the court and goes through the
court process and I guess what I'm
wondering is would it make
sense to have instead of these various
councils to have an administrative
appeal tribunal one administrative
appeal tribunal that would be
sufficiently independent from Dees but
would handle all of those um you know as
opposed to these councils which are not
I mean they're they're you know I'm I'm
sure they're excellent people that serve
on the council but they're sort of
volunteers as I understand it and they
um there sometime they're not available
and they're switching we've heard
evidence of switching
between like you know not all of them
are if if it's it's a multi-day or
multi- week proceeding or something not
everybody may be there for for all the
hearing so would it make more sense to
do something like
that yes and I'm sure you're familiar
there's always a um kind of a conflict
between process and speed right so we
used to have a certified record appeal
those went very fast I could do two in a
day um but you didn't get to say
anything extra and so people weren't
able to be heard so they changed that
and they made the council's able to hear
more but now every hearing takes between
two and four days basically to get
through the council that means you need
four days when you have the council
members there um so I think there was an
efficiency in the council process we can
see whether that continues but last
session there were people looking at
this very closely and actually passed a
bill where it changed what you need to
do so I believe right now it used to be
if you had a you know 13 member body you
needed to at least have a quorum there
at this point I think it's changed to
say you need to have at least three
people um from the council there and
then the other ones can come if they you
know if they're able to so the hope is
that for scheduling purposes that would
make it easier um and I think there's
actually a chair of a um a council here
in the room who works very hard at doing
this job um and um can tell you a little
bit more about that but I'm sure that
there you know things could be better
but the idea was last session that that
bill um that pretty significantly
changed that process and looked at all
these different you know opportunities
do you want environmental l do you want
to have a one panel do you want to have
the four councils resulted in this and I
think it it may be wise to let that play
out for a while to see if that actually
helped okay all right good point other
questions for this witness seeing well
for both Witnesses and is there anything
else either one of you wanted to say
please I don't mean to cut you off all
right well thank you very much thank you
thank you all right
next yes yes yep know I got them from
please good afternoon I'm chip Kimble
and I'm the chair of the wetlands
Council a little quick history I started
my career for about 15 years doing
construction involved in construction
litigation and then found out I could do
better I wrote computer
software and I did that and in
1991 I began at the sandwich
Conservation Commission after serving 15
years there in 2007 I went on to the
council and I've been chair since 2008
and a half or something like
that so uh there's there's uh quite a
few questions that were arise that arose
that I can maybe answer before what I
was going to say um first I just want
you to understand that uh and it comes
out from one day at coffee as I was
leaving to come down here the Wetland
council person said go out there and
protect the environment and I said we
don't protect the environment we protect
the
statute and that's what we look at our
job as and
so when we're when we're there that's
that's it we're looking at the statute
and and on these appeals and looking at
the rules and doing that we aren't
wandering off
hopefully um because of somebody's you
know desires okay try and uh answer
repesent representative Alexander gave
us some good reasons for why she's
supporting this bill but I just want to
respond a few things I did get an email
this
morning uh that stated there were only
three missing members on the water
Council and three on our on our Council
um it's always a kind of a rolling thing
members of the council are
generally state state agency reps so
that's dot fishing
game uh state parks uh things people
people like that in our Council and also
representing I represent uh nire
Timberland owners land owners basically
commissions and Municipal Association
things like
that um there was a question about how
many permits and what happened we just
yesterday um had our meeting and I
learned about this yesterday morning so
we had a little chat about it we don't
have a specific position except that we
didn't like
164 um there are last year there were
about 3,000 uh wetlands and Shoreland
total permits there were 13 new appeals
where we calculated we have about 26 or
so in on our docket now some of them are
stayed due to other litigation or
attempts to resolve um the
situation and there was another comment
about new
evidence we do uh accept during an
appeal the new new evidence that comes
in and as
a and that would we take the department
record and then people can bring in uh
new evidence and we consider the new
evidence from both sides as to what when
we make our
decision
um but it's not a denovo review we
aren't going through every aspect of the
whole decision we're only looking at the
appeal that's been requested on what
particular
items um I I do have to comment and not
to be discourage disparaging on repr
Senator Alexander but this idea that
we're judge jury and executioner we
highly you
know we don't like that we we are separ
I'm not sure I'm not sure it was rep I
think you may have I'm not sure it was
representative Alexander well whoever
said that but and I'm not you know
that's not the only person that thinks
this but you know there's a there's a
just a thought out there that when they
come before the council they're coming
before Dees and we're just hand and you
know p with them but that's that's not
true
um as as far as the time to
resolve uh which was uh spoken
about I frankly only learned last year
when they brought this three uh member
Quorum up that some of the other
councils actually would have a multi-day
hearing and have different people at the
hearing at at the water at the Wetland
Council if you show up the first day and
then you don't show up the second day
just don't show up any other day or if
you show up on the second day not having
been on the first day they you know
you're out you don't even show so that
that's they shouldn't be doing
that say that um and as far as the time
I I want to mention that sp84 was
already passed by the House and Senate
and that was the carryover bill that
included the study committee to review
the dees environmental Council appeals
process okay which last year because the
members weren't appointed in time it's
like October was it then we couldn't
actually start the committee we were do
you know I think October 25th is when uh
representative Lynn was appointed as
chair of the committee and then we found
out we were supposed
to the committee is supposed to meet
with the council chairs and go over this
process to try to speed it up and make
it more consistent and I would suggest
that that's what should be done instead
of this bill at this point or certainly
the first part of this
bill um but that's been reinstated
assuming the governor will sign it initi
year will'll in in the summer get get
that study committee
going
so what I attorney Brooks has already
talked about the use of the word court
or the councils it's very confusing in
here what they're talking about are they
talking about the court are they talking
about The councils Who
referred to
um the list and I went through the list
and it was interesting to hear
representative Alexander talk about
particularly arbitrary and capricious
because I read arbitrary and capricious
and so that doesn't changed that doesn't
change anything to me in fact it's kind
of I've never
seen anyway that is uh doesn't seem to
me to make a change that they would
really want um the other items are
really I think we pretty much already do
all of the things that are in here in
the way that's
described the only thing is we seldom
have anyone claim a constitutional issue
before us they they'll mention it but we
don't really deal with it because we'll
reject it and it goes up to the Supreme
Court and if they want to agree with it
that's that's up to
them I would point out which I think
attorney Brooks said the same thing is
actually you know more differential to
the uh Department um right now this this
would allow the department to back
figure and back come up with a solution
for why they didn't follow the rules and
right now if they don't follow the rule
when they make the decision they can't
back out of it the way we read it and
the way we operate they can't back out
of it you know no matter how much hand
waving they do at the at the
three uh if by the court they meant the
councils
okay whoever they mean it seems like
that creating a whole new right for
somebody as a wide openen right to
appeal a decision of the
department
before or after at at any time during
the untold process whereas right now you
have the decision 30 days you have 30
days to appeal you appeal to the
councils and then you uh the appeal goes
forward so I don't know what
three
on the second part which is the
rules
um we already if a rule exceeds the
statutory authority of the agency we
would and that was part of the
appeal we would reject the rules and and
uh remand it to Dees and and we've done
that before
um the rules are created just to
understand how they the dees creates
rules in a draft they're passed on to
the council the council comments on the
rules any and and we have since we have
different members from representing
different consistencies they can go on
to their own agencies and bring the
rules to them and then after they've
done that then
the the uh Department responds to those
our
comments then revises the rules and
brings them out to the public and then
the public comments and it goes on to
eventually onto JL car so that's just so
you understand the particular process
some
moment I think that kind of covers it so
all right as far as the rules we didn't
have anything else but as far as
changing the whole process we didn't we
don't think it's a good way to do it I
think a better thing we to do would be
just make sure that the study committee
looks at that and that representative
Alexander and those people can certainly
you know bring everything up before the
study right questions for this
witness yes representative Manos thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um you you said that um on
appeal you can accept new evidence but
you also said it's not a hearing denovo
it's not a denovo hearing and I'm not
understanding that distinction what I
would mean by a denovo hearing is that
the permit application and everything is
completely reviewed all over again by
the council and the council makes a in
essence new decision on the permit on
the on the issuance of the permit or the
denial of per um what we do is we only
hear what the appeal is based on so the
appellant would might say okay they you
know they didn't consider the dees
didn't consider rule number 50613 on
Rule
30321 and so we look at 50613 and 30321
but we don't of our own
valtion go ahead and dig into rule
8002 which is to me a denovo would be we
start all over again we look take
the follow thank you Mr chair
so when you accept new evidence does it
have to be related directly related to
the
appeal or can it be new evidence
that never was raised at all or never
came came into the case never came in
before to the department is that what
you mean yes I mean and we did this just
a couple months ago um it was a dispute
about a an embankment that was a road
that was sort of actually a dam that was
sort of a
culvert and the issue was raised about
whether the eels came up to their or not
and so they brought in evidence as to
whether there were or were not eels in
this particular area below which wasn't
you know brought before the department
at the
time other questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank
you is there anyone else who 164 yep
up can can you just yeah I just give the
card if you would please to
you good afternoon uh Mr chairman
members of the committee um my name is
John Tut Hill I live in aworth New
Hampshire
um former state representative I
actually was down today at the
environment and agriculture committee uh
dealing with some bills related to Dees
policies and um saw that this this bill
was on the the docket down here at
Judiciary I don't have prepared
testimony but I would like to uh just
speak briefly about um years really of
experience with the environmental
councils in New Hampshire and I do think
that reform is critically
important I have reviewed the
legislative history when these councils
were created back in the 80s at about
the same time the dees was uh being
brought into into
existence um I've been before various
councils over the years from the 80s
forward um beginning with I believe
Wetlands
Council very early on
um and in more recent years we've been
dealing more with the waste management
Council and the air Resources
Council um councils are quite different
it depends who is on the on the the
various councils uh depends on the
vacancies where often the public seats
are remain vacant for long periods of
time so they are somewhat industry heavy
in some cases I will say that I found
the wetlands Council to be um the one
that in my view functions um the
best I've seen real problems uh with a
couple of the other councils dealing
with air issues and waste issues over
the
years um
I don't have a lot more to add to that
but I really just want to emphasize that
I think reform is very important it was
not a bill last year but a an amendment
I believe to a budget bill or to a
budget writer so we didn't really get a
hearing on this issue last year um when
the change was made uh having to do with
quarum and the Department of Justice
taking more of a role in sort of
supporting the appeal process but the
councils um they hear generally monthly
from directors of which whichever
division their you know is their subject
of expertise um so there's sort of a a
close relationship between Dees
officials and council
members
um when you're bringing an appeal of a a
agency decision this is a council that
is very familiar with the people who've
actually drafted and finally approved uh
permits
um I think we could use a a process
where there's a little bit more of an
arms length relationship between the uhu
board I think I hadn't heard about this
uh committee that may be doing a study
this year and I think that's a positive
step and I would hope that that would be
open and noticed and available uh to
members of the public who have been
through the appeals process there there
are a number of people who have come
before these councils appeals are not
constant I think the legislative intent
early on perhaps was more for the
applicants who had decisions which they
found um perhaps unacceptable or perhaps
needed to be modified to be sent back to
Dees for further consideration I'm not
sure that the process was set up for
Citizens and members of the public uh in
affected
communities so
um I support this bill I mean I read it
quickly this afternoon in principle in
concept I think it would need some work
um I think there's then a good comment
made earlier by the chairman of another
Council that um referring to courts is
perhaps going to be a problem um these
are sort of Quasi adjudicatory bodies
they've got another role as well and
that is to advise the department and the
commissioner on policy
development and they sort of got a
public out Outreach role or in terms of
education and that I just have not seen
happening over the years and to the
extent it does happen it certainly isn't
happening at open meetings or in any way
that is accessible to the public and
that's been a real problem in New
Hampshire in certain areas the
department overseas uh where where
policy is sort of stagnated not not in
all areas and often you're responding to
Federal requirements that are coming
down from Congress or from EPA for
example um in order to keep your funding
streams going you've got to be in
compliance to keep your state
implementation plans in place for
example
um so you know and Rule rulle making
obviously has to happen to keep
adjusting the rules to stay in
compliance that that's an important you
know role for these councils but again I
don't find that the the process
currently used at least by the waste
management Council and sometimes the air
Resources Council is particularly
transparent the rule is presented to
them by St
um and I think they're given a short
period of time I don't recall exactly
perhaps 15 days to get comments in and
then there's a if there are comments or
concerns there's a back and forth with
members of Staff but that doesn't happen
at an open meeting and that record of
communications is not easy to obtain
occasionally you can but you've got to
dig for it you've got to know it's
happening um and I I think that that
needs to be looked at as well just the
sort of the time frame that is used for
receiving public comment from um from
the agencies on these
rules all right I'll stop there I'm sort
of rambling on all right I do have I do
have concerns and I really urge uh that
we take a close look at at some pretty
pretty substantial reform of this entire
process thank you thank you questions
for this
witness seeing none thank you uh is
there anyone else who wishes to be heard
on House Bill 16
14 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 1614 and I'm going
to open the rehearing or second hearing
on House Bill uh
1602 and uh representor Alexander I'm
more we're more than happy to hear from
you I didn't want you to think that you
needed to testify again but we're more
than happy to hear from you if you want
to testify again well thank you Mr chair
members of the committee again for the
record Joe Alexander from um Hillsboro
District 29 golf toown
um I'm just here to say that there maybe
may or may not be some State agencies
testifying today I'm certainly in favor
working with them um but I think
representative MC Williams outlined why
we need in specific situations
specifically related to housing why we
need something to make it so that
appeals to appeals of state agency are
seen in an independent way and that they
are done um when Common Sense should
prevail it prevails so with that I'm
just asking that you um listen to Dees
and I've I've had I was supposed to have
a meeting with them last Friday but um I
had a family emergency so that didn't
happen so um but we plan on working on
an amendment to present to the committee
thank you all right questions for this
witness all right thank you I seeing
none all right um
uh Adam crepo and Mr Brooks if you want
to come up too since you know you you
were sort of a tag team before and I
think pretty effective so maybe you can
do that
again well thank you and just to clarify
uh the Department of Justice does not
take a position on this bill I think
Dees May yeah so again uh just for the
record uh members of the committee I'm
Adam kpo I'm the assistant commissioner
Dees I'll just give a brief overview of
the uh of the testimony we submitted uh
you know the we understand that the lack
of housing Supply is one of the most
important issues facing our state right
now with that said we are neutral on uh
HB HB 1602 with some notable concerns
with the language um the legislation
would appear to allow the housing
appeals board to affirm reverse or
modify decisions made by state agencies
this is concerning because many of de's
per uh permitting programs have a
federal component associated with them
in many cases EPA delegates authority to
Dees to ensure Federal uh requirements
are adhered to uh for example the state
issues Wetlands permits and a
modification made by the housing appeals
board should this bill pass um could
trigger the need to work with the Army
Corps of Engineers to see if those
changes are acceptable to them as there
is of often a federal overlay with our
per with those
permits
um if the housing appeals board modifies
a Dees decision that has conditions
required for federal compliance we would
end up in a situation where applicants
would be out of compliance with could be
out of compliance with federal law
depending on what they're modifying or
reversing um as I I won't go into our
our Council process I talked about our
environmental councils on the last bill
so you're well aware of that um Dees
programs were designed by the
legislature to be protective of the
environment and public health so
overriding a permit could have
uh an ill ill intended result um you
know for example the subsurface Bureau
has been very successful at approving
septic systems that protect drinking
water wells we'd be concerned about the
housing appeals board modifying or
reversing a decision necessary to
protect the public in public safety with
all that said Dees is committed to
creating efficiencies in the permitting
process to ensure state agency uh
decisions are timely and the conditions
on those permits make sense from from an
economic and environmental perspective
um we'd be open to working with the
sponsor uh as as he had mentioned uh we
had a meeting last week we're in the
process of rescheduling one um to find a
path forward that address specific
concerns um I'll just say it's my
understanding that the the impetus for
this bill may have come from um some of
the concerns outlined at the special
committee on housing uh that that the
house um created and so um we we'd love
to work with folks to figure out you
know what what are the specific concerns
how can we address them um without such
a broad sweeping change so so that's
that's where I'll leave
it thank you and I'll Echo those
sentiments um essentially yes we're very
concerned about housing as well and we
appreciate all the efforts to make
things more streamlined we just wanted
to raise people's uh awareness of how
sweeping this relatively small word
change would be and uh again example
obviously you now know my background
because I've been here for a
while the legislature previously decided
that in the environmental field that the
issues were so complex that they
couldn't even be reviewed by one Council
they needed four councils those councils
have expertise they do this for a long
time the issues in my field are very
complicated again hearings last between
two and four days and they're very
technical very
specialized uh air program I'd say is
the most so waste um following close
behind but for instance an air permit
Title Five permit probably among the
most complicated permits you could
have that is a Clean Air Act requirement
you you don't have to go to the federal
government right now to get those
permits because you can get them from E
from uh Dees but that's because Dees is
a delegated program under EPA if they
lose that
delegation then you'll get a Dees permit
and you have to go to EPA to get a
separate permit and it's very
complicated and so you want to make sure
that you don't end up impeding something
where we have a good relationship and
we're able to provide uh those Services
uh faster so I again would applaud any
effort to continue talking uh about this
issues and kind of synergize what a
solution might be questions for this for
the either of these Witnesses so let me
just ask one qu I
mean one of the I guess I have two
concerns one is if we were to allow the
housing appeals board to have some
review authority over decisions of the
Department of Environmental
Services would that review
would the housing appeals board
replace I mean would would would your
view be that that the housing appeals
board should replace the councils
or should the should the review go from
Dees to the councils to the housing
appeals board and then to the Supreme
Court and if that I guess my concern
would be if that were the were the case
I'm not sure we've added yet one more
layer of appeal I'm not sure how that
furthers you know um uh moving forward
with housing uh and meeting the the
current situation so uh the way I look
at this bill it applies to All State
agencies not just Dees so um you know
think about a DOT driveway permit or
some other you know permit you might
need to get from uh the Department of
Natural and cultural resources or
something like that um so I I think that
kind of speaks to your question a little
bit but I'm not sure that I think it
might create a separate path Alan do you
have any thoughts on
that it would be very
concerning for me to have either of the
two things that you just described occur
either to have a housing appeals board
without the expertise replace the
councils or to have an additional layer
of appeal those things I don't know the
housing appeals board the the councils
by necessity just to give people Fair
notice and ability to get things
together and to get to a hearing and be
heard takes a long time so um I would be
very concerned about that and again
obviously it doesn't just affect
Environmental Services one of the ones
that came to my mind uh was Health and
Human Services right so if there's lead
paint in the building or something else
and they have to issue an order should
the housing appeals board really be
reviewing that it's just something to
make sure that you're thinking about as
you're considering what this bill might
do I wonder if if I could ask just one
other question I mean that what you just
raised is the the thing that actually
persuaded me that we should have a
second hearing on this is at the at the
last hearing we we heard from uh what I
think were very legitimate concerns from
the Human Rights Commission about how
the Human Rights Commission might be
implic might be impacted by by this and
I have to say candidly I had never you
know the idea that that that that um
that the housing appeals board might
have some role in that uh in in you know
reviewing decision of of the Human
Rights Commission was I it just hadn't
occurred to me but I think they raised a
legitimate Point we've now talked about
the Department of Environmental Services
and Department of Transportation you
raised the Department of Health and
Human Services what I what I guess I'm
asking is would it be possible for the
Department of Justice to provide the
committee with a complete listing of you
know
any any state agency that potentially
could have
some role in housing that would be
subject to their decisions would be
subject to review by the housing appeals
board if we were to adopt this this bill
or some version of it I'd be happy to
take that question back I can't tell you
right now uh the Civil Bureau has a list
of all their civil Bureau clients we
have you know Department of energy that
may be impacted I suppose Environmental
Services fishing game that may be
impacted if you want to develop housing
where there's threatened dangered
species Etc that's just for my Bureau um
I mentioned Health and Human Services
but they my at the last count I bet
there's more than a hundred uh agencies
that have some level of counseling that
they get from the Civil Bureau and I'd
have to ask them um you know who could
be
affected I would be very interested to
hear what the housing appeals board
would say about uh us us saying here's
your new jurisdiction is that you have
the planning board zoning boards and 100
state agencies or I think they might
have some they might have something to
say about that I would think Mr chair Mr
chair they did say something about it
and they said that they support the bill
as
written these all of these
agencies at the last public hearing they
said they didn't think there would be a
whole lot of cases amounting from this
and they said that they support it as
written okay all
right any other questions for this
witness I'm not sure that I remember
that yes representative Andrew
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question my concern is with
the housing appeals
board have the
expertise that Wetlands or somebody in
DS had in DS
has would they be able to go through an
application and answer all the questions
that might come up I
mean I know Dees has has to have experts
here here and here is this house appeals
board going to have that expertise is my
question and I presume representative
Alexander could tell you more about that
board but what I can tell you about the
councils that we have is they're
specifically set up with the
understanding that probably not any one
of them would have even enough expertise
to decide so it's chosen to be okay
let's have one person from fishing game
one person from do and then specifically
somebody who works in that industry
someone who has certain years of exper
experience Etc who can actually bring
something to the table with specific
background on all of those topics that's
how the council's
function other questions for this either
of these Witnesses seeing none thank you
Kimble good afternoon just a couple of
quick comments here first in in response
to the comment on the federal um overlay
situation just want to make it clear
that one of the best things that Dees
does for the citizens of State of New
Hampshire is in the case of the Clean
Water Act they protect the people of New
Hampshire from having to go before the
Army Corps of Engineers because if you
get a New Hampshire permit or Wetlands
you have generally except for very large
projects met the requ requirements of
the clean Clean Water Act and and as
they mentioned there's some other areas
that we do that so we don't want to
touch that um our our question reading
this is just how in the world does this
work what is a housing project is that a
single family who has gotten a culvert
permit who the abutter objects to and
what happens if one AB butter objects to
it and appeals to the housing appeals
board and the other butter objects to it
and appeals to the Wetland
Council if they still have that right um
so that would need to be
clarified um another thing is there
seems to be a possible standing conflict
here they're referring to standing in
from 6774 and
6775 that doesn't necessarily consistent
with the standing that we have in the
Shoreland and Wetland I don't know about
some of the other Dees programs or
anyone else's any other
agencies um and so the question is if if
one person appeals to the housing
appeals board and there are other
appeals to all sorts of other agencies
does that mean the whole kitten Kaboodle
goes to the housing appeals board or do
on and I guess I I'll just say that from
our experience at the wetlands we don't
have a lot of what I would call housing
housing appeals the kinds that I just
mentioned mentioned or
subdivisions types of housing appeals
but when we have them it's always Dees
has given them the permit and people are
trying to stop the project whether it's
a single family home or whether it's a
subdivision and what we need to be
concerned about is I'm very concerned
about the the permites because we have
what I call motion sickness in this
whole process which is that people want
to stop at keep issuing motions getting
objections waiting for decisions blah
you know on and on and so we need to
look at the pathways and see which one
is the shortest to solve the housing
these housing problems um and if we're
longer I I you know if the councils are
the longest process and maybe we should
give it to somebody who's faster Well
we'd like to be faster too that's what
the study committee is about but I think
that's what you need to look at so all
right question questions for this
much uh let's see there was
uh from the on from the online signin
there was no support and 30 opposed to
the bill nobody neutral um is there
anyone else who wishes to be heard on uh
yes
thank you Mr chairman um I wasn't sure
if I was going to testify I will put in
a pink card Ben Frost uh New Hampshire
housing um at the first public hearing
on this bill I after after the hearing
closed you charged me with coming up
with an amendment um and I have done
part of that uh recognizing that we
would hear from uh folks from Dees and I
wasn't sure how to address that um have
some ideas but it's not drafted I do
have an amendment drafted that um
addresses the concerns raised by the uh
uh building officials Association Mr
Sherman and Mr McKinny both testified
and expressed concerns I drafted
something and uh they told me this
morning by email that they were okay
with this um so that's that's good news
and I also Incorporated the amendment uh
proferred by representative Gibbs that
was uh
31h um happy to I only have one copy I'm
happy to give that to you or to email it
uh to you as well um and likewise I'm
happy to work with the committee and
with the sponsor and with uh the
Department of Environmental Services and
anyone else on amendments to this happy
to take any questions right questions
for this um
witness well no thank I thank you very
much for your efforts on this and and I
um you know I
there's speaking personally I would like
to see this bill be able to move forward
but I for the various reasons that we've
all seen I think
there's there are very legitimate
concerns about you know what exactly
should be the scope of the uh of the
what exactly should go to the housing
appeals board and what should not
correct and and Mr chairman I I I had a
question that the committee might wish
to ask uh Dees or the Department of
Justice uh and that my question was how
are the federal overlays
protected in the appeals to the councils
and to the Supreme Court uh in a way
that they wouldn't be protected in an
appeal to the housing appeals
board sure that is an excellent question
I wonder if we could just ask gentleman
if you could uh that's that is a very
think
thank you so they're not sacred uh it's
not to say that either department or U
the council could make a decision that
was wrong but the protection is simply
the expertise and the familiarity so for
instance if you're on the air Council
you and you've been there for some
amount of time you understand exactly
how that Federal program works and to
say wait we can't change these
requirements because these come from the
Clean Air Act you know how they
intertwine you know what if you're on
the Council and I'm sure um chairman
Kimble could tell you this that he has
great familiarity with
this is what is the state programmatic
general permit like okay that's the
permit that the Army Corps gives the
state in total that says so long as you
get a uh State weling permit that
satisfies ab and C you do meet the sgpp
maybe some big projects come out and
here's how that happens the people on
the councils are actually quite familiar
with how that works they tread lightly
on that and they um they understand how
the framework works so the only
protection I would say is expertise
there's no specific thing that says
anyone could not make a decision that
was
incorrect okay so can I just follow up
on one question on that so if
um am I understanding correctly that in
other words if the depart if the core of
engineers gives the authority to Dees to
issue some permits uh some you know
permits that you've talked about um if
the if
Dees issues
those in a particular case that is that
you know the federal government doesn't
like they think that it somehow violates
the the federal law but Dees doesn't
think that issues the permit it goes to
the wetlands Council the wetlands
Council affirms it goes to the Supreme
Court the Supreme Court
affirms then what is what is the what
does the core of engineers do about that
appeal to the Supreme Court US Supreme
Court or it's more of a practical matter
and there's a lot of layers to it and
there's a lot of different ways that
programs get delegated So Clean Air Act
program is delegated by letter basically
that says the state can do it so for
Clean Air Act EPA can do what's called
over file on a particular case and they
can say we don't think we agree with
what you did and we'll have the ad admin
istrator vpa take an independent action
but behind that action is you may get
decertified uh as a state and then you
wouldn't be allowed to do that there's
also grant funding in play SG um I think
it's now just general permit but the the
Army Corps permit is a little bit
different in process so the Army Corps
has the ability in the permit to pull
out any project that it thinks is
actually not fulfilling the uh Army
Corps requirements because the idea is
that our state program is restrictive
enough protective enough that if you
meet the state you will meet the feds
they have the the ability to pull that
out but the program will look at it and
say do you actually deserve to have your
general permit reissued or are we going
to be doing individual permits for
everybody in the state of New Hampshire
because you're not able to do it and
there's probably three other ways that
things get delegated but it's
essentially comes down to are you going
to be allowed to keep doing it and are
you going to get the funding that goes
along with some of those things thank
you
questions from the committee no
represent representative WS thank you
thank you for taking my question would
um would an amendment such that um the
housing appeals board would not be able
to reconsider any any uh decisions that
involve perming um involving Army Core
of Engineers you know so Shoreland um
The Heritage uh you know all the other
Provisions you've got to do in the uh
the Clean Air Act if we carve those out
of this process would that give us
enough protection to allow this to go
forward as to not be metalsome in those
types of permits yeah and thank you I
didn't mean to seem too anxious to leave
you seem like very nice people stay as
long as you want um I I would say that
I'm not sure how many carats you would
need I provided you some examples I'm
not sure if the carats start to be so
cumbersome that it's very hard to
understand and everything that you need
to do um I think that I would be
interested in you know this kind of the
meritorious idea of making sure people
have access to housing and everything
else that might go along with it to say
what do you need to achieve and then how
can we change it to focus on what needs
to be done rather than having a very
broad uh provision with many many car
VES great thank you other
questions seeing none thank you very
much anyone else who wishes to be heard
on House Bill
1602 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 1602
yeah yes
before you end this session um I've just
realized that our colleague
representative steton has um a floor
Amendment on
1589 that um looks long and
complicated and I wondered if it
would be appropriate for him to just
quickly tell us what the differences are
since we're going to have to vote on
that tomorrow no no not 158 1589 is the
Veterans that's that's going to that's
going oh you're talking about going it's
going to go to the floor that's cor sure
yeah yeah yeah no I'm sorry yes yeah
that's correct that's why I'm concerned
okay
sure yeah it multiple pages and I'm
sorry for that but all is it was they
just
restated the prior amendment I think
it's 033 h but with the change the
singular change to
quantify the uh
foreign um definition in veterans
definition um by by adding the the few
words that I had suggested before do I
have it here someplace I'm sure I do but
I don't know where I think you probably
remember that if that's what it's just
that I looked at it and I thought
there's no way I was going to be able to
go line by line and see and I'd rather
use your brain than fine I would have
preferred that they did that in a short
paragraph right um but I don't control
that stuff and I don't know how to
control it so I had to take what they
offered
unfortunately um but
um but so those of the only change the
changes that were made were the changes
that we had talked about here in the
committee yeah um that was off of um uh
chairman Lynn's uh Amendment
0334 H identical wording just
modifying the um Roman 3 veteran
definition Part D A current or former
military member of a foreign Allied
country and then it goes on that has
been under command of involved with uh
us or Coalition forces that's it
terrific thank you very much can I just
can I just follow up on one um I know
you and I had exchange about did have
has is representative Moffett Avail
aware of and do he is he on board with
yeah I I copied him through the process
okay okay not the latest floor amendment
I sit next to him so I'll bring him up
to speed okay yeah no I just want I mean
he was you know intimately involved in
this the prime sponsor I just wanted to
make sure he was he was aware of it all
right he did send us all an email I
reluctantly entered that process and I
won't want to do it again thank you all
right um
we've had a long day I think we uh I'm G
to have another long day tomorrow so I
think uh unless anybody has anything
else um I'll see you all tomorrow and
remember uh Republicans uh N9 o'clock
here for our
caucus tomorrow tomorrow morning right
yes
I